[Music]
the stakes have never been higher and
I've never been so high as we are right
now here in Toronto you can see the
beautiful CN Tower behind me as the Sun
Peaks through the clouds on another
amazing day here at the 2023 Champions
chess tour final we have day two of the
semi-finals coming up it's Chile
downstairs chil chess with Levy and KY
on our YouTube channel and it's chilly
up here so if you don't mind let's get
downstairs and let's get to it because
day two of the semifinal finals starts
right
now you've heard the sayings The Road
Less Traveled rubber meets the road I'm
on the road to nowhere that need to get
up and go to just shut up and drive to
Parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's all over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move check me there's been
curves Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
the w we see a reaction Magnus is
Magness Mouse slipped oh my gosh look at
Jan's face some have pulled over but
some what is he doing slamed that foot
to the floor and just kept going any
second nakura is the winner not a of
vajra the Frenchman he wins the AI cup
after six stops along the way it's time
for the greatest proven ground and
online chess to drop that final pin in
the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think the this
is the strongest final there's ever been
I know that it will not be easy it's
nice to play in top tournament Magnus
will want revenge with my last
tournament of the year I'm a bit
desperate to end it well having the
opportunity to play against the best
players in the world it's always a
challenge and I enjoy it it's going to
be a very close fight it's going to be
very exciting live from Toronto Canada
this is the 2023 Champions chess tour
finals and it starts
[Music]
now
indeed it does start right now shout out
to Wood Harris shout out to our awesome
hype video it's the CCT finals you know
the drill we're getting set for day two
of the semifinals here in Toronto so
much action about to go down on the
board we are downstairs now no longer on
the roof here with KY and Levy inside
the playing Hall where all the action
has been taking place all week and guys
Boy A lot happened yesterday yep I'm
going to skip past the first question
which is was it hard to steal Ray yota's
suit from Good Fellas oh listen I
appreciate it but it looks good it looks
better on you I appreciate it shout out
Joe bananas Jo but you're looking good
are you feeling good and what was your
give me your biggest takeaway from day
one of the semi
biggest takeaway was we got everything
we could have asked for in the match
between Fabiano and Magnus and damn not
Beck Is For Real yeah that was that was
the takeaway so we'll see if he can get
to the finals yeah your your thoughts oh
the T up honestly I mean really for me
Abdu satov is swinging it's more like
you know that guy that you know you're
running you're running the race right
and you know the guy's behind you but he
like really behind you like is he really
catch is he actually faster than me now
maybe he's you know what I mean what's
going on that guy and I love what you
said that got everything we wanted
because we didn't know how we were going
to get another epic Fabiano versus
Magnus match we kind of assume that it
is usually going to be epic between
those guys but you know Magnus was a
moment away from losing right one game
away and he comes storming back in
Armageddon and then of course as you
already said Notre Beck uh showing that
he is here to stay at the top well we
just gave you our takeaways if somehow
you missed it we're going to give you
the Highlight Reel show you what went
down right now I think that Magnus is
about to get checkmated and Magnus he
slows down but he's got six 6 seconds to
decide now The Rook can go onto the C
file and win the queen he gives up his
Queen Magnus Carson surely Fabian is
going to take it wow he just blundered
the pawn with cheze he should have
pushed the other one the G Pawn wrong
choice there and Magnus is alive look at
those white pawns paralyzing The Black
Queen five doesn't know where to go but
now it's winning for mag he brings his
Rook all the way down Rook it he chooses
the wrong Square he trapped his own
Queen and it's handshake Magnus Carson
does the unbelievable he wins down a
queen look at that that big move that is
big chess by nbec Abdu satov a rook
sacrifice impressive stuff there Abdu
satov game over if he sacrifices his
Queen right now Abdu satov he does it
it's on the board Abdu satov finds the
finishing touch this is simply game over
weso resigns Abdu satra The Comeback KS
trikes again Magnus drops his night back
a big blunder according to the
evaluation bar can black just continue
the journey with his night Fabiano K are
really bringing him his aame today
Magnus Carlson is about to go down in
game three well we see resignation that
one is over Fabiano in control from
start to finish pure determination from
nyb it's just grit his hard work is
paying off one move away from winning
that pawn is about to get to H2 there's
two of them black has two of the pawns
though and Wesley resigns n Abdul satov
also gets the backto back Victory and
takes the lead in his patch the only way
to keep Black's Knight alive is to
repeat and draw and handshake Abdu satov
takes it it's handshakes Abdu satov wins
set one of the semi-finals against
Wesley Soul Black Knight Will trap this
white king Magnus has spotted it all all
Magnus Carlson need is a draw and he's
about to force the draw this is
unbelievable recognition Fabiano just
frustrated he got so close he tried what
he had to but in the end handshake
Magnus
wins
wowers wowers it was amazing the usbeck
dragon spitting hot fire as he takes
down Wesley so and uh he didn't even
need Armageddon like Magnus did Magnus
of course as you saw there come storming
back to win an Armageddon and that's
where we sit if that's where we stay we
would have a Magnus Carlson versus Notre
Becka duat turov final who knows if
that's what we're in store for yeah but
uh again real quick thoughts on uh on
the the big the big the big the big play
we just saw there well yeah I mean I
think it's important to point out
Fabiano was was dominant in the first
three games yeah he almost won three
nothing right but we're talking about
Nock that's really the star he came out
guns blazing against last year's uh
Global chess champion right and that was
uh Wesley so he took him down after
losing the first game he stormed back
twice he won in convincing fashion had
absolutely no problems putting the match
away did not need an Armageddon
yesterday 19 years of age the only other
player currently sitting here that has a
World Chess Championship and that is in
Rapid chess and uh doesn't get much
better than winning at around 95 1.2%
accuracy versus the second most accurate
chess player in the tour which is Wesley
so only behind Magnus yeah weirdly
enough it actually seems like you know
people forget all the time and even even
I like you say it every day but then you
forget that he's a world rapid Champion
bro like he if you said if Magnus was
World rap Champion oh you expect that W
oh you expect that you know five time
right but n backck is like oh man I'm
the I'm a world rapid Champion I'm right
behind you guys I'm about to bring the
heat and show you I am a world champion
just like you Magus you always know that
at some point the next generation is
going to start breaking into to this
group and start winning these events
right we all kind of want it right you
have Magnus and Fabby and Hikaru and
Wesley they've been dominating for years
but then when it starts to happen it
makes you a little uncomfortable you go
wait a second are we ready for this I
mean like let's just no born in 2004
yeah iow I think I was think I was
graduating high school in in 200
all right let's let's show everybody the
uh the fun fact here which is that Notre
is the youngest World rapid Champion he
won it as the second youngest behind
hoyun second youngest World rapid
champion in history right there and uh
you know again he's he's uh he's a boss
right there we see the ranking of of
world champions in any format and Hoy
fun man I didn't realize she was so
young when she won by the way sorry I'm
just like staring at that stat yeah and
and and I mean she won it it she won the
World Championship overall shout out
shout out to Hoy fwn great friend at
chess.com she's done commentary with us
before so I apologize I fumbled a little
bit looking at that cuz I was like she
was 16 yes Nock is the second second
youngest player in history to win a
world championship she won the overall
Women's World Championship but he won
the world rap at 17 years of age and I
think I think he won it in like a tie
break versus y pishi who's like that's
no slash man that's a top five rapid and
Blitz player and classical player in the
world two-time Challenger for
not at the but I mean he's got the
nerves and he's gots to it
up we're going to move through talking
about his opponent now Wesley so the guy
who dominated we've been calling him
flexy Sano all the things you talk about
but KY despite what was the dominant
story line through the round robin
portion it could all be slipping away
from Wesley if he doesn't hold on tight
right now yeah in fact it was the nerves
it was something we haven't seen from
Wesley all you know six seven matches he
played here until he played nck in fact
when he play nck here you know it got a
little shaky you could tell even nck
said himself he could just smell the
blood in the water as he like stares at
his opponent which is very uncomfortable
imagine I'm just up Danny your move bro
y your move you know what I mean don't
get your makeup on my
shirt I did that last time too but stare
you know staring at you that close right
is it's uncomfortable right I I hate
that like you know you just playing
somebody and they just like this and
then they're just oh yeah yeah how how'
you like that
moveo yeah that doesn't feel too yeah he
just stares at you you know and you
can't stare back cuz it's your move it
is a little different playing OTB when
that stuff's going down right I mean you
feel like if so was shaky which is what
Notre Notre Beck said he felt like so
was a little shaky maybe something has
to do with the psychology you think a
little bit there 100% probably a little
bit I mean he doesn't stare at people
because he thinks they're handsome I
mean I maybe he does I don't maybe he's
like damn Wesley's got he's got some
nice stuff going on the face he he's
looking at him cuz he's like I'm going
to bury you into the ground with my
moves not these fist not yet and that's
how he took the lead on day one like I
said yesterday this is Wesley's worst
situation in Toronto two years in a row
he's just he won last year and he
destroyed the round robin phase and
today he's looking at potential
elimination third and fourth place so
who said chess was not a contact sport
right full of emotion and intimidation
seriously and it is something that you
can feel when you're here and you can
see it as the players look at each other
but all right we also had a lot of fun
with Wesley maybe he's feeling intense
right now but he was feeling pretty
relaxed after the round robin stage and
he and I got up to some top a little bit
off the
board all right first game we're going
to play is rapid fire all right
basketball H Kobe Kobe all right
baseball uh
shoot well the one who play at the faint
Lis cardal they have some young players
I think what's Mike mintini up there I
like him I meet him what about what
about soccer Leonel Messi because he's
very consistent okay also since back in
college days he was already number one
and he's still okay he's until recently
number one football my homies I watch
him I watch also his commercials okay
tennis yovic yovic all right I love it
golf I guess everyone says Tiger Woods
but there's this uh very pretty girl
page sparing up all right I like it all
right what about uh
poker I only know Jennifer
Shah yeah I only know her and
you hear that J Shah you're the goat
you're the poker all right chess chess
uh Danny wrench okay come on you're the
best I appreciate it I'm going to say
Wesley so then you said favorite right
the favorite or who's the goat who's the
goat goat yeah hard to choose I'd say
fisher for now but I I I suppose the
right answer is Carlson but I'll say
fisher because he's American okay just
boxing I'll pick my boy KY oh I love it
yeah he he hasn't done it yet but he I
think he might be one of the greatest
ever when he's done probably yeah he's
uh pretty pretty good your favorite
movie well say Lord of the Rings first
comes to mind okay classic I can watch
it uh over and over again but there I
know I like the the very the newest bat
the Batman Okay three hours now the
latest one so I like it yeah it's I
think it's the best Batman movie ever
okay favorite book I like his history
like World War II two books World War I
I have tons of those also books about
Napoleon like I'm a big fan of Napoleon
although the the the new movie was
horrific was it not good haven't seen it
yet yeah me I don't know really Scott
personally like the actors were good
they did their best like haen penix I
think did a good job but the story was
not accurate at all okay yeah you would
you would know yeah so I like I pretty
much read everything about Napoleon
favorite TV show he the crown a TV show
The Crown yeah yeah yeah I love it yeah
we're going to go watch it right after
this tournament the the the latest
season I love that's great that's great
favorite author I'd say sam Shanklin if
he writes more books well that's the
first thing that comes to mind like I I
really want to read leby roseman's book
so I'll get there one day well on L I'll
ask you who's your favorite chess
Creator uh well hikaro I I I love uh his
uh twitch streams although since his
twitch websites I've been following him
less but when he was in which like I
enjoyed watching his uh title Tuesday
stream especially like yeah favorite
chess game of all time okay my my game
against Sergey kakin in
2017 Norway was an amazing game my win
against dingler in 2015 in bilbow in the
Kings Indian was also pretty epic like
that was the last time he literally
played the Kings Indian with black uh
but I think you broke him you broke him
in his Kings Indian relation sh I broke
his Kings Indian yeah for sure like he
never played the Kings Indian again
after that so you guys should really
check out that game that was my most
beautiful game one of my favorite games
of all time Wesley so over Gary Kasparov
it was a Blitz game but I covered it
recently and like everything you need to
know about Chess series thank you that
was a you did yeah thank you that was a
game right there all right yeah I wish I
play like that again well what about
Wesley so Magnus Carlson 2023 Champions
chess tour not bad today 9 G5 yeah was
pretty good I made him jump you did that
was good that was good I hope I can play
it
again Blitzer classical graphical online
or OTV over the board E4 or D4 E4 Fisher
or Kasparov uh yeah it's hard question
but I go with Fisher at the moment
closed or open positions
open open positions Searching for Bobby
Fisher the movie or the Queen's Gambit
on
Netflix m yeah it's a tough question but
I go with the Queen's Gambit
okay Wesley is hilarious by the way we
had to edit that down because we talked
for a while he gave a lot of answers we
need that we need these guys we need
these guys to open up to tell us about
their interest cuz we need all the fans
watching at home to care about them not
just their chess moves like Wesley's a
great interview so thank you Wesley
thank you Wesley thank you Wesley that
was awesome it was great there's more
coming your way if you follow our
YouTube channels you can get into it but
we have got to get into the next match
boys we've got Carlson 32 over Carana
because of the Armageddon
tiebreaker he uh he's getting set today
for uh probably a very very motivated
Fabiano so let's move over to that one
if you're Magnus Wes uh uh I almost
called you Wesley because I'm thinking
about Wesley if you're Magnus Levy you
acknowledge that you didn't necessarily
have your best chest yesterday you also
acknowledged at this point you kind of
have an issue with starting slow yeah so
how do you fix it if you're magnus's
coach for a second I mean if I if I knew
I would probably be up there playing as
opposed to commentating uh the first
three games did not go his way the last
two did very much A Tale of Two matches
within one match itself uh we will see I
think Magnus is capable of adapting to
whatever happens in the first game or
two of today's match so remember the the
the second set is at Best of four if
Fabiano clutches it out and wins that
set then they play a slightly shorter
set which breaks that tie so we might
have a bunch of Chess today um as we
talk about the highest I mean ELO of all
time right it's really hard to against
well you mentioned Fabby clutching it
out Levy and um let's remind everybody
that these two guys we're watching are
two of the three obviously with Kasparov
highest rated players in history so
sometimes I think we take it for granted
but they may they may go down as always
being two of the top three together
right I mean these guys have had
incredible careers their rivalry is
insane and KY your thoughts I'm just
going to ask do you think Fabby clutches
it out yeah you know if Fabby does what
he did yesterday and just stay in the in
the groove here you know hey Magnus he
knows what he needs to do of course
Magnus is like hey if I'm playing at my
best if I'm feeling good I'm going to
play good I'm one of the best to ever do
it right but if fa can do what he did
yesterday and just repeat and stay
consistent and stay in his own lane
there he might have a chance actually
really uh as he did yesterday you know I
thought Fabby was going to crumble when
he blew that first game but he didn't
yeah he almost won the match right I
think he's the guy we always say is the
most stoic the most present you think
that that's something that's really
going to pay off for him today well look
my picks were were Carlson and and so
right because I just thought they were
the favorites in their matchups um but I
can't change that pick because now that
I know the results of the first day of
the semi-final but I will say it almost
felt like Fabiano lost a couple of Min
matches within that match yeah right
because he was up 2-1 that fourth rapid
game with white Magnus would just showed
up just vintage imbalance creating a
complicated position that he won and the
Armageddon was very tense but it came
down to a couple of critical decisions
so you lose a couple of now you got to
wipe the Slate clean and you have to
show up to we'll see if Fabiano can put
on a good fight right uh and I mean I'm
just hoping for as much chess as
possible so well we're all hoping for as
much chess as possible we want long days
here in Toronto because uh that means
we're having a lot of fun and all right
more ad breaks or ad or more ad breaks
we want more ad breaks we want more
subscribers we do appreciate everyone
and uh we want more time with Ka we're
going to throw over to her right now let
her take it away and talk about catching
up with Magnus
Carlson hey Danny I'm standing here in
the hotel Lobby Bar where the venue for
the CCT finals is and I have to say you
guys are looking surprisingly fresh and
feisty this morning because I hear you
guys were spotted at a bar here in
Toronto last night having some drinks
playing some bug house with the chess
brass and I also hear Magnus Carlson was
there to hang out with you guys and to
have some fun and speaking of fun that
was one of the top goals for Magnus
Carlson this year I met up with him in
January and I asked him what are your
goals for the 2023 CCT season if you
could list your three goals that you
hope to achieve in 2023 Magnus Carlson
is looking ahead to yet another year
with exciting chess but first let's go
back to 2022 I would say on the board it
was mostly Pretty good overall um I
think it was one of my better years he
definitely seemed focused at the board
as the 32-year-old finished the Year by
winning back the rapid and Blitz world
championship titles was relief uh a part
of what you felt there uh heading into a
year where you will give away your your
classical title the timing is perfect
like if there was one time that I really
uh there really one of those titles
would be now but yeah it just gave me
gave me joy and like still when I I
think about
it makes me smile uh it was a really
great moment and joy is exactly what the
world's best chess player wants more of
in
2023 just want to you know to play and
have fun and I feel like that's true
more than in a long time especially now
that I have these rapid and Blitz W
titles though I can just relax and have
fun I think I look at it at least
sometimes a little more philosophically
than before that you know if I have a
bad event I have a bad event then I'll
hit back in the next
[Music]
one
number one is win a game with 1 V3 okay
and second is to have fun and third one
is to win a game from minus 10 position
that's for the
tour and here they are Magnus Carlson
top three goals for the 2023 CCT season
and yesterday he was able to check one
of those goals off because he was able
to come back from a minus 10 position
against Fabiano Karana in the first game
so let's see today Danny if he able to
also take off those two other boxes back
to you
guys I love it I'd say the second one is
also checked off cuz we did have fun
last night I think Magnus is having fun
and we actually were joking about that
video that when is he going to have a
chance to win a game minus 10 we
literally talked about that when the
tournament started wasn't even minus 10
there was an
M value say it was like a BMW model of a
car it was like M10 or something I mean
it was crazy it was check obviously
finding a check made in 11 we all know
stockfish says that evaluation that just
means you win the queen then you win the
game but uh it's crazy I can't and but
credit to Fabby for winning the next two
games you said it like seriously I would
have I would have been pissed absolutely
will he play 1 B3 that's the question if
he really wants to round out that list I
don't know if he is but we're going to
we're going to round out our show open
here by reminding everybody of what the
format is we've been doing it all week
you're having a blast let's remind you
of what's ahead as we get closer to
crowning the 2023 Champions chess tour
champion
the semifinals are set our top two
finishers from the survival bracket
Fabiano kowana and Notre Becka dorov
have advanced our survivors now join
Wesley so and Magnus Carlson in a single
elimination bracket as the number one
seed Wesley has chosen his first
opponent Notre Beck and we move one step
closer to determining who will be
crowned our champion of
[Music]
champions
the match is rolling on the updated most
recent odds as of today Magnus now an
87% wow favorite that's I mean it makes
sense right he won the first match he
was at 71 and kind of kind of cut that
in half and now it's 133% uh only for
Fabian caran in regards to his chances
who knows what those odds makers are
really up to behind the scenes fiddling
with math I don't I don't necessarily
believe in math but no I'm kidding I
think those odds science I'm not going
we're not I'm not so into science or no
I'm kidding but it it I think the odds
check out we'll see what happens
obviously today something interesting
about that Magnus was the pre-tournament
favored obviously at 50% I believe
yesterday he was still in the 50s maybe
he broke 60 and now he's at 73 according
to the math which we saw that means that
they're taking the odds that he will
play nerb in a final right that's so
that's a little if I'm Nord back I'm I'm
beating Wesley I'm going right back to
I'm pissed about that fighting the
statistician that CH has you think this
Notre back guy looks for bulletin board
material oh 100% I think actually think
Wesley is the one right now on the back
maybe watching the broadcast and he's
like oh yeah you think I'm all wholesome
and soft and like cute and cuddly okay
yeah wait wait till we get out here
today Right Wesley is out there being
wholesome and soft and cuddly we hear
him laughing you can hear his laugh
anywhere because because it is uh it's
amazing and it's genuine all right uh
speaking of amazing that's our crew in
Oslo they're pretty good at what they do
David Robert and Tanya I don't really
have any better cue to throw to you I'll
just ask how you doing this after
we're doing great Danny love the buildup
also big shout out to Levy suit great
color there loved it and we're really
excited about of course the chess that's
coming up we will keep checking in with
all the action with the gang in Toronto
but we have uh set two of the
semi-finals that are about to begin what
are we expecting from the players today
Robert well for some players it might be
their last match for Wesley so and Fabio
caran in particular they have to bounce
back right now they have one set to win
and if they do take the second set of
the match we go to set three and they'll
have to do it all over again it's Magnus
versus Fabby and Wesley against nbec
Abdus satra of the Magnus Fabby match
five decisive games a thrilling
thrilling match Magnus looks like he's
just rolled out of the bed shows up to
the game is down a queen wins the first
game it's down two games wins the set
how do you beat someone like that how do
you get over the psychological battle I
think nobody knows that's the answer how
do you beat Magnus Carlson because
you're always is fighting the unexpected
no matter how strong he plays no matter
how he starts the game no matter whether
he plays Mimi openings he's always
eventually going to bring his best when
the critical moments do happen when the
clock ticks down so Fabby is up against
it but if he can start like he did
yesterday he's definitely got a chance
and these two will be playing the other
semi-final match and it's always good to
see Wesley in a happy mood he's been
having quite the field day on Twitter
enjoying himself looks extremely relaxed
but it's time to get his game mode on he
playing catchup to n's set one win let's
listen
in switching chairs I get it I have my
technique now like I can slide
it it's good for not usually play
musical chairs as a kid he's probably
got a little bit more recent experience
does Wesley get to pick magnus's chair
as
well wow maybe the players are
superstitious choosing their lucky
chairs
here
okay I feel dizzy just watching those
chairs go round and round and wait Fabby
now he's moving as
[Music]
well how dizzy are you guys getting I'm
struggling to keep up with these musical
chairs here they are think they are
ready just all right to make sure that
we the players in in Toronto are ready
with their chess and it's time to get
into the chess for nbec satro he took
set one this is set two Wesley has to
win to take it to set
three for nck he's the guy who knocked
out Hikaru Nakamura in the survival
stage Tak set one against Wesley so is
Wesley feeling the pressure because
Wesley had this incredible run in the
round robin but we've seen him get a bit
shaky at the end yeah Wesley earlier in
the event he did have that one match
against Maxim where he won on demand in
game two but he hasn't had his back
against the proverbial wall very much
and being in must-win territory for
Wesley so can be a bit uncomfortable and
the games they're off and we are off
Wesley so what will be his uh opening
approach in this one a set that he has
to win on demand he does the usual takes
his glasses off and it's one V3 Cowboys
everywhere are rejoicing Magnus Carlson
said one of his 2023 aims is to win a
game with 1 V3 can Wesley pull it off
for him wow Wesley so loving the moment
loving Toronto and surprising us this I
would never ever have predicted he has
played 1 B3 as recently as the world cup
over the board in Classico in Rapid he
has years in years ago produced a course
I believe for chess base uh on this
opening before he'd ever even played it
over the board but uh this is really
rare to see at the top level white gives
up any Ambitions in the center and
starts playing on the flanks look at
this last move he's feel headed a bishop
brought white light squared Bishop out
and now White's Knight sits on the edge
of the board and nobec replies in kind
and this is one of those openings where
I say do not try this at home because
both players just put their Knights on
the rim Wesley just moved his light
score Bishop for a second time before
developing his kingside knigh are
castling it's going to be this a
situation where you're like what in the
world my coach Tommy to develop all my
pieces Castle don't block some Pawn
pushes so my other Bishop can get out
this is wacky chess and maybe it's what
Wesley needs do not try this at home
unless you're Wesley so but that said
Wesley is the one who's got his head in
hands already plays a very
unconventional opening approach right
here is the kind of opening that you
want to play in this format when your
opponent has little time it's rapid play
you want to get them out of opening
preparation but so far
nbak has played quickly and this is the
first move that he slows down on what is
going on in his mind is he trying to
counter the night jumps that are coming
from White next yeah nck he's trying to
just gain his bearings in this position
of course he wouldn't have expected 1 B3
when the move came when the time came he
will have faced it before throughout his
though and now he's just going back into
those memory banks that mind Palace he's
recalling what his opening Theory said
maybe he's trying to get Wesley out of
his preparation either way this opening
M Wesley here is going to look like a
genius or it will backfire and uh yeah
we love to see it though either way this
approach in set one it was nbec who
played the better chess in critical
moments and in this matchup there were
several critical moments as well between
the two highest rated players in the
world fighting for a spot in the finals
Fabby has to win this set it starts with
the kingspawn opening and are we going
to see another archangels by Fabby that
worked so well the moment of truth is
now wow and Magnus Carson repeating his
strategy yesterday which somewhat
backfired yesterday one win one draw
with uh sorry one win one loss with the
white pieces for Magnus Carlson but both
games he was suffering it's Fabby though
who switches things up it doesn't put
the bishop on C5 puts black Bishop just
on E7 so no dark Archangel today going
back to more classical Waters Robert and
we saw Magnus look to the side because
he probably was anticipating that Fabby
might go back down his chess course he
may have spent a lot of time outside of
playing in the pub watching some chess
videos seeing what Fabiano had in store
for him but this is some classical chess
opening lines and Magnus playing a quiet
variation from the white Side Pawn to A3
he's not challenging Black's Advanced
Pawn on the queen side over here so this
might be a longer battle who do you
think that suits more normally I would
say Magnus Carlson uh but then then
again Fabiano is still well within his
opening preparation and unfortunately in
this opening the Spanish in general
there's not much new Under the Sun for
Fabiano he would have studied it all
before and you can see by his quick
response he's ready he's prepared he
with black was the first to launch a
surprise and uh Magnus now the first to
think and for set one U Magnus showed up
straight out of bed but it's clear that
was quite a wake up call for him
everything that happened yesterday he
was so close to losing set one and uh
today looking sharp playing a sharp
opening as well despite Fabby losing set
one it just feels that Fabby just needs
to do exactly what he did on day one
because he could have pretty much
wrapped up the match in three games yeah
Fabby he just needs to be maybe a bit
luckier a bit sharper when the clocks
are really ticking down low uh that's
the only thing that stopped him in game
one yesterday but he did everything
right um you talked about Magnus looking
sleepy yesterday looking a bit sharper
today is that just because of the hair
quality SLI back today for Magnus
Fabiano meanwhile always looks sharp uh
Bishop out to G5 still a new position uh
still a well-known position sorry Robert
well yesterday we talked about air
quality hair quality and today we really
do need to talk about chair quality
because we saw the Arbiter Judith she
was fixing the players chairs making
sure that they were sitting in their
proper seat and right now we see that
Fabiano he thrusts his Pawn forward to
C5 we are seeing some trades so by
pushing the C pawn two squares the
square next to it that D5 square is one
that is accessible to whites pieces so
Magnus he's playing for these pluses he
has the control of that key Central
Square and for that night on the rim for
Fabiano I do expect it to jump back
there it goes I feel like we're still in
the framework of these two players
preparation and for Fabiano he is making
his responses very quickly yeah both
players well versed here just a mark of
respect to each other as well both
playing pretty much their best
repertoire not messing around with any
kind of surprise openings No 1 B3 in
this one it's all about playing
classical chess minimal risk uh just
play your best and right now Magnus
again thinking surprised by this last
move which looks very natural looks very
normal I think Magnus just he'll take a
pause here one minute or so decide upon
a plan which pawns to push uh
potentially on the queen side and then
he'll go for it but uh looking very
balanced in these early stages we see
Loi girl there in the background some
chill music so far a chill start to this
game and Magnus he's very concentrated
because while he may be up a set he of
course has inside track to the finals we
saw the predictions beforehand 73%
chance to win at all 87% chance to win
this match he's not taking Fabiano
lightly Fabiano did outplay Magnus a day
ago in those first three games where
Fabi did score two points in those three
games and it could have been even more
had he not blundered away a winning
advantage in the first one but Magnus he
looks ready for what's about to come
today and for Fabiano he may be shaken a
little bit after yesterday's result but
he's clearly not broken I think what's
about to come on the ball board today in
this position is uh Fabby going ahead
with the Queens side pawns moving
forward that a pawn will March up the
board where the square the Knight has
just vacated we can expect the B Pawn to
move forward meanwhile Magnus eyeing a
central break trying to get D4 in but
you always have to watch out Fab's
Bishop on F6 will open up if there is a
break in the center I'm once again
liking this position for black out of
the opening who would you say has won
the opening battle so far are o early
days despite the fact we are out of the
opening normally signaled by when both
sides have finished castling and
developments here pretty much most of
the pieces have been developed um I'll
still say that the players are aware of
the middle game plans they know roughly
what they should be doing which porns to
push uh which pieces to put on which
squares so I'm going to try and hold off
on answering that one for now Tanya I
think it's the next five or six moves uh
will dictate who has won the real battle
uh I don't think Fabby has anything to
comp complain about so I'm inclined to
say black especially after this last
move Black start Square Bishop would
just drop back to G7 a nice hiding spot
the fien ketto square after all but uh
yeah still maybe too early to tell we
get some Kings Indian like Tendencies if
that Bishop is able to slide back and
the F Pawn goes forward for black
because the side that controls the pawn
breaks it's often the side with the
advantage you hear me say this all the
time that's a key Pawn break available
to Black and for white you can strike on
the queen side maybe you push your Pawn
to B4 maybe you push a pawn to A4 you
have some choices here if you're Magnus
Carl
I like that Fabby is playing quickly
yesterday that served him very well when
he had a lead on the clock he also was
able to dictate some of the course of
action over the board and for Magnus
he's trying to determine which Pawn to
push how do I deal with this he does
play B4 and it remains level but I like
the chances that both sides have here
they're playing on opposite flanks yeah
maybe I'm just too biased because I like
these positions with black I play them
with black and it just feels that uh you
managed to get the space on the queen
side you can think about expanding on
the king side there's A5 breaks there's
potential F5 coming in next you have to
watch out with the D5 Knight jumps
though it's going to be an interesting
fight it's one of those position that
starts really slow and strategic but
once you get a break in once the pawns
start disappearing from the board the
position suddenly explodes yeah and it
is likely to explode eventually just
judging by the way they were both
playing yesterday as well often there
would be slower starts a bit of buildup
a maneuvering phase for 10 or so moves
in the middle of the game and then
suddenly it's just chaos clocks are down
tactics Galore left right and center and
right now this does feel like the Cal
before the storm in this game and uh
meanwhile we might be able to switch to
the other game shortly because that one
is much Wilder a very different type of
game happening in the other semi-final
right now and uh here we go Wesley so
against nybeck Abdu satov and wow white
porn landing on D5 he might have started
with a flank opening 1 B3 very quiet
porn push but Wesley has now gone to
that Central strategy and put pushed
everything forward in the middle of the
board to my eyes just at first glance
superficially it looks like he's
achieved a lot here Wesley so and look
at the clock Wesley is up nearly five
minutes on the clock against one of the
quicker players narbeck is the one who's
often pressuring his opponent on time
and this last move D5 it's causing NB
back to pause here because the bishop on
B2 he started as the B3 cowboy and that
Bishop on B2 it's on the longest
diagonal if black sticks a knight in
front of that Bishop's diagonal Knight
E5 the White Queen jumps out to D4 and
it's not even threaten a Checkmate it's
just Black's pieces are a bit loose in
this position and if you have to part
with your Dark Sword Bishop if you are
not you're not going to be happy there's
such long-term pressure on this diagonal
I certainly prefer Wesley's chances yeah
I'd agree with everything that you just
said Robert and that last move D5 black
really doesn't have those many squares
with the Knight the one place you don't
want to go right now is the edge of the
board because you're just going to fall
off the ledge well I was talking about
Knight A5 because it just ends up
getting trapped there with the move B4
uh David while Knight the other knight
move that you were pointing out I think
that's just not a happy move Knight A7
has no future meanwhile you can't drop
your knight back to E7 either because
black white just captures the Knight on
F6 and that would just destroy your
kingside Pawn structure which means that
your move Robert might just be the only
one and it feels as if Black's pieces
are getting in the way that Bishop on F4
the Knight on E5 if the Knight was to
jump to the center of the board just
looks a bit unstable but it's probably
the only move that nck had
and he's played it the Knight has just
landed and I love Robert's move Queen
into the center always lining up on the
diagonal uh with queen and Bishop this
battery can be uh really promising long
term and it causes some immediate
difficulties um there's actually two
moves that I'm quite attracted to here
for white uh firstly parking the queen
in the center also even bringing this
Knight to the edge of the board to
develop it with gain of time with gain
of tempo forcing this bishop to move
away but ultimately Wesley he's achieved
everything he can hope for in this
opening uh if he's feeling ambitious
he'll probably play this queen move I'm
looking at Pawn to D6 as well just
clogging up Black's development that
looks a bit tempting too Wesley so
spoiled for choice I think he's achieved
everything he can hope for especially
today where he needs to strike back
against somewhat amusing because white
hasn't completed his own development but
that D6 idea that you're mentioning it's
a good one to just shut down that Bishop
before it even thinks about getting into
play so Wesley he's a bit spoiled for
choice at the moment I I think if I were
him I would try to maximize my time
Advantage because this position isn't
going to get any simpler in the near
future if there's an imbalance of an
Dark Sword Bishop for white compared to
a knight for black that's a long-term
Initiative for Wesley and I think he can
use that to his advantage and that is uh
almost a five minute advantage on the
clock for Wesley saw and a good position
out of the opening putting pressure on
black species now setan had a very
different narrative when nbec managed to
get good positions out of the opening we
saw him convert technical end games we
saw him play well aggressively sacrifice
pieces and wrap it up when it was
required but this is the first time that
we see Wesley get an initiative out of
the opening and this reminds me of some
of a term that Magnus Carlson coined
anti- young player chess and 1 B3 do you
think that's what Wesley's achieved with
this yeah because they prepare so deeply
these days uh thanks to the accessible
engines uh the players they can study
all of their opponents games B3 is not
something you study in depth unless
you're playing against hiar Nakamura who
plays it all the time online and I do
think that the top players they be they
come more ready for it because of all
this online experience they get against
these top players who do choose to go
the B3 Cowboy route but in this position
I think they're both in novel territory
and I have to say that Wesley he he did
the best he could and he has a nice
chance here yeah it feels like both
players freestyling and this
hand-to-hand combat uh it tends to favor
the more experienced player or the
player who's more comfortable in the
type of position uh that is achieved and
yeah he needs to stay clear of those
long uh kind of technical end gamees
Wesley so today abdor was just too
strong yesterday you have to learn from
your mistakes try something new and
that's what he's been doing so I love
the approach with white bit strange to
see Wesley tank for so long right now
almost three minutes of thought in this
position where yes he's got two or three
tempting moves that we mentioned he
brings his Queen into D4 Robert's first
instinct very powerful move gaining time
against Black's Bishop but yeah two
three minutes he could have played this
instantly it was so natural almost
automatic and Abdus abov now needs to
think uh hopefully he's been thinking
Wesley's time he needs to react very
quickly and in that third game yesterday
Wesley had uh he was holding on for deer
life in an end game but with just a few
seconds on his clock it's where he went
wrong I think Wesley you know he was so
dominant the first six matches in the
round robin stage he maybe was a little
bit complacent lost to Fabiano in a
match that really didn't matter but then
he's fa facing off against a really
hungry nir Beck abusara of somebody
who's determined in every single game he
plays whether it's in the park or more
on the grand stage of the Champions
chess tour finals he wants it he's
always going to dig deep so for Wesley
now he really has to dig deep and he's
doing a great job I really like his
position control the dark squares and I
think it's the kind of position that we
need to dig deep into because black
doesn't have uh so many options on the
board we see with that last move Wesley
hits the bishop on F4 the Knight on E5
is hanging there's no way to stay
connected to that the only two moves
that come to my mind David would be that
you either capture the Knight on E3 or
fall back with that Knight on E5 to D6
defending the bishop on F4 I'm not a big
fan of retreating with the Knight
because I feel I'm opening up the
diagonal of the bishop and the queen I'm
already eyeing moves like that white
knight jumping to G4 uh putting pressure
on that black knight take it please take
it let me give you a checkm in one not
going to happen but these kind of things
would at least terrify me so Bishop
takes Knight would be my move of choice
here what would be your
approach I didn't even notice night G4 I
must admit Tanya I thought white would
just develop but your knight G4 would
scare The Living Daylights out of me and
uh yes maybe black can cling on by
dropping the oh dropping the bishop back
putting the Knight on the edge of the
board but this is ugly uh really really
scary stuff uh just purely due to the
diagonal so I agree Bishop takes E3 none
of that business you take off and then
uh ideally try to support your knight in
the center next move the problem is
after Queen takes Bishop uh with this
diagonal opening can you support the
Knight do you have to move it anyway
it's a double attack a double hit on
your uh piece here in the center the
question is after Pawn to D6 can Wesley
get greedy and capture a pawn if the
answer is no but due to pressure on the
E file then I think this is what Abdus
should be going for I think this would
provide at least some compensation for
the pawn definite compensation it's just
one of those moments where I remind
viewers that we and you have the
evaluation bar off to the side the
players don't so n would know that he
has some compensation he just doesn't
know how much is it Justified and even
if not taking that Knight on E5 like
let's say black does take the Knight on
E3 and the queen takes back and you
played Pawn to D6 if white plays a
simple move like Knight to F3 just
continues the development it's a
long-term Advantage thanks to that dark
Square Bishop for white black doesn't
have a counterpart so for Wesley as
we're seeing these trades I would not
take that 9 E5 but no doesn't even give
him the chance wow dropping back fearing
that pawn sacrifice but this night is
not well placed later it will come under
Fire from Harry the hbor over here and
also it does give white the opportunity
at some moment to even uh sacrifice a
pawn throw a pawn away to block in this
bishop so again for Wesley multiple
tempting moves watch out for the white
king even castling Queen side if
Wesley's feeling super ambitious in this
game because he has so much space here
he has the better Bishop the better
pieces and wow this one is shaping up
this warming up really nicely and just
how difficult that decision to give up
the dark Squad Bishop for nbec you can
see it on the clock he took three
minutes between two moves to decide it
was one of the Lesser evils he is
feeling the pressure White's pawns have
given so much space the two Bishops
Super Active especially the one on B2
and Wesley is Unstoppable today he's
just going all out he doesn't think
about development just yet the H Pawn
moving forward H5 is a threat on the
board and the one thing I immediately
notice is that if black was to slide The
Rook to the center of the board David
something that is such a natural move
that Bishop on B2 is quite the monster
and comes to their rescue because you
just take away the Knight on F6 a key
defender of that Rook so rookie eight is
not an easy move or the one that you
want to make here um and we will Deep
dive into this but we are getting uh
some insights coming in from Toronto
with
Levy Levy Wesley incredibly ambitious in
today's
opening yeah thank you Tanya uh and also
I noticed that we're matching uh so
that's very cool uh and I mean we're
looking at the game here in Toronto and
we're blown away by what we're seeing it
couldn't have gone any better I have a
question I kind of want to ask the
entire panel over there in Oslo how much
of this is Wesley's preparation and
knowledge of the position and also how
much of it is nock's utter shock at
getting hit with 1 B3 pretty
non-traditional opening and he might
have just gotten himself into trouble
right it could he just could be reeling
from the very first move of the game
yeah leev it feels like a bit of both at
least to me it feels like the shock the
surprise and kind of that Steely
determination to still play principled
moves to still try to uh be as kind of
ambitious as possible it's kind of come
back to haunt nbec and how would you
recommend to the viewers out there
reacting to a surprise like this one uh
follow nock's approach Fight Fire with
Fire or just try to survive in the early
stages because clearly what's happened
is backfired never an easy choice right
because when somebody hits you with a
surprise you don't know how deep their
preparation goes and for Wesley he's
shown that he can achieve a good
position so I think for not he's doing
the right thing for classical chess
standards using your time but as we look
right now he's three minutes 30 seconds
remaining Wesley's nearly nine it
doesn't seem like it's a good territory
for nck
so what's the next move the position's
good the time Advantage is strong but
black has three pieces pointing at
White's G4 Square so I really want to
play F4 here and I wish I could teleport
my Pawn on G2 to G5 and my H Pawn to H6
all in one go but I also kind of just
want to play slow with like Pawn to F3
and maybe long Castle so nothing can go
to the G4 Square what kind of stands out
to you we've got two grand Masters on
the panel so what uh what stands out to
you what how do you actually turn this
attack into a full point you can't just
pause the and say I'm better and get a
win that way well I can do that because
I'm sitting in this chair but in all
seriousness Levy you you make a great
point that white has several options I
would first play Pawn up to H6 just to
carve out all of the dark squares in
front of the black king and then maybe
later as you said instead of pushing up
to F4 maybe you can even sit the pawn F3
taking away critical jumps from the
black pieces but H6 right now for Wesley
David that's what I'm looking at at
least yeah I love it combine all of
those ideas kind of the direct approach
approach lengthening the diagonal of the
white dark squared bishop and then take
the slow approach as Levy mentioned just
get developed get kind of fully
organized before launching that attack
against the black king the black King's
not going away anytime soon these
long-term advantages are not fading
Wesley he's made that move Pawn to H6
look at all those dark squares Levy do
you think we'll see a checkmate at the
end of this
game I mean that's it it really is
looking quite bad H6 G6 now we have the
queen and Bishop diagonal there for
Wesley and and we do see a long Castle I
think nbe can't sit and wait he might
have to create counterplay with
something like Pawn on B7 to B5 at some
point he may have to Chuck upon invest
upon for some counterplay but this is
what I will leave you with and send it
back to you guys Wesley won the first
game yesterday so this is a potential
disaster for nck in game one but it's
not the end of the world right he is
going to come right back just like he
did yesterday potentially so uh he also
will come more prepared against 1 B3
that's the food for thought I will leave
you with and if Wesley wins this game I
still think we could go all the
way absolutely and it's uh not over till
it's over when you're playing against
the world's very best players for nbec
he's in early early pressure he did lose
game one off set one went on to strike
and take the match and it looks like
this is going to be a tough start for
him as well I'm just looking at those
dark squares around the king that Queen
lands on G7 that's Checkmate and can't
you just get rid of that Knight on the
center of the board push that F Pawn two
steps ahead F4 would be my first T in
the position what's wrong with that F4
for the score I think you just win a
piece nobec suddenly head in hands I
think he might have miscalculated he's
relying on a trick uh to bring the Black
Knight forward to eye up a fork B3 is
loose if you take this Black Knight now
whoops a royal fork and you lose
material but I think he might have
underestimated that this Pawn can simply
be defended uh it's not actually that
easy to hold this square but even if you
drop back the queen uh just to protect
for one more move this diagonal is still
open if the Black Knight moves this is
always going to be Checkmate just to
show and uh how else to keep the game
going you have to LEAP into the center I
guess with the Black Knight but now you
again you just moved the queen it's
actually quite clever yeah it's quite
clever from nordbeck and that's the
thing he is such a fighter because the
queen needs to stay in line with that
Bishop otherwise no no Checkmate there
if you move your queen back oh I'm
hitting your knight E5 with my Pawn your
knight E4 with my queen now the Knight
moves away from the E5 score and The
Rook on E8 protects the Knight over
there on e4 the game continues in fact
black wouldn't even be that much worse
so this is tricky stuff from noer Beck
maybe Wesley I we see the evaluation bar
in the live position after F4 Knight C5
it still says that white is much better
maybe it's just like one of these just
absolutely brutal moves like King B1
just like you're not going to Fork me
you take my Pawn on B3 I Dro My Queen
back to C3 and now really both Knights
are under attack but I have to give
notbe credit he's giving himself a
Fighting Chance white doesn't have so
much shelter in front of his own king
that's actually an amazing resource when
I first spotted F4 Knight C5 firstest
was not even on my radar and I'm sure
for most of us it would be a difficult
move to find threatening a fork but
that's not the main thing the thing is
it's not easy for white to actually
defend that B3 Pawn so to think about
just Sid stepping with your king giving
it away for Wesley if he does the
calculation takes his time right now and
spots this defensive resource of King B1
that you pointed out this could be a
quick game then yeah this would be
almost over white would win a piece this
Black Knight would drop still some work
to be done to wrap it up to conver the
advantage but I think ultimately this is
the key moment if he if he finds King to
be1 at the end of this two three move
sequence he should win with white and he
plays the first move F4 Moment of Truth
he plays King B1 Wesley so has a
decisive Advantage the Knight is falling
in the next move love this style from
Wesley just playing this ambitious chess
from the very start of the game he's
finding the tactics when necessary so
it's not just like Wesley only enjoys
These Quiet positions and we see the
position on the left hand side that is a
very quiet position between to Magnus
Carlson five on a Carana we see that
both sides have Queen two Rooks Five
Pawns in a minor piece it's very even on
the left side but on the right side
we're going down that line Wesley so has
a huge advantage and this is the Wesley
that we saw in the round robin stage and
then he lost the last match to uh
Fabiano Carana and we saw him struggle
on day one but this kind of precise
chess is exactly what happened in the
first few days in Toronto and Wesley is
back in form back in form it feels like
the Beast has woken again it's woken up
from that Slumber of just a couple of
days off there wesle so and yes the
Black Knight is jumping dancing around
but white is up material white has an
extra Bishop now for just one pawn and
uh yes even if black gets another Pawn
for it it's all about the black king
there's always going to be checkmating
ideas on G7 and actually yeah I don't
see too much resistance atorf he really
needs a miracle now and let me pointed
out that on set one it was Wesley who
got the first win in but it was a very
different game the entire game it felt
as if it was Advantage not a back and
then in the time scramble Wesley managed
to get some tricks in and win it but
this one start to finish Wesley has
dominated from the opening stage he
takes n back by surprise then plays
energetic chess with that H Pawn moving
forward playing on the dark Square
weaknesses and now he's up material by
the way also on the left side we see a
lot of moves being blitzed out but I
think the evaluation Still Remains level
there's very little material remaining
on the left hand side between Fabiano
and Magnus that's Advantage Fabiano
drawing with the black pieces that's
what you're told to do at the highest
level a very solid start for him but on
the right hand side n debeck i we don't
really see him play too solidly very
often but it's not the type of game that
he wanted out of the gates against
Wesley you don't want to give him that
confidence because Wesley's win in game
one yesterday that was from Notre going
too far he had an extra Pawn in an
endgame but then he couldn't hold
himself back couldn't show that
restraint end up losing here is just
Wesley blowing him off the board yeah
when Wesley has nothing to lose as we
saw earlier in the tournament against
Magnus Carlson in that amazing
Armageddon uh then Wesley just displayed
some incredible chest it's as if Wesley
so turns into mik tal somehow just
sacrific his pieces attacks checkmates
and uh he's doing the business there
meanwhile back to the left hand side of
your screens Magnus Carlson against
Fabiano Carana level pawns but things
are changing pawns are dropping um
actually if anything I would probably
take Fabiano's position if he can
stabilize in the next move or two
because White's remaining Pawn on that
left side of your screens the B Pawn is
weak Black's Bishop is about to unleash
itself and uh become a very strong piece
I think Magnus needs to pull the break
now and uh there should still be ways to
force the draw but ultimately it should
just be level and Fabby had to fall back
with the queen to defend that Rook on B8
which was hanging so no time to pick up
that Knight on F3 he needs to watch out
for his clock though fabbi is down to
about two and a half minutes Magnus has
uh a three minute Advantage almost on
the clock is it time for Magnus to
liquidate the situation further pick up
that E5 pawn and he'd be be happy if
black was to pick up the B4 Pawn can
Fabby actually make something of the pin
if Magnus was to go Knight into Pawn at
the center of the board I don't actually
think there's a way to exploit the pin
because white can always defend it but
it does look like as daveid would say
hoovering off the pieces is the way to
go so if Magnus can just get them all
off it'll be equal but on the right hand
side of our screen the evilart went down
a bit nbe quickly responded and it went
right back up so perhaps missed
opportunities there for nir beaar I
don't think he's mentally resigned
because he always gives a fight and he
is opening up a line on the right hand
side in front of the white king but
apparently there was a better move yeah
there was a better move uh not an easy
one I think he played the most human
approach Abdu sator of he's trying to
open up whes King which doesn't look
like it has too much shelter so still
some counter chances against Wesley's
King there but he could have actually
brought the black queen forward into E7
difficult move eyeing up the A3 porn
there was a pin on the eile uh now
Wesley has stabilized the only safe
Square for the white king is the one in
the corner but luckily it's protected by
that beautiful darkart squared Bishop
which landed on B2 as early as move two
and is now dominating the board
dictating the play Wesley still a piece
to the
good nbec Abdu satov as always just
never giving up and I think there were a
lot of takeaways from day one and one of
them was that you just continue to fight
it out till the end and he has
sacrificed his Rook for that Bishop that
you were pointing out which controls key
squares on the queen side and now a
black can think about stepping up with
that Rook to B2 to create some chances
to at least create a Chaos on the board
a huge threat Queen takes Pawn as well
as the knight in the center of the board
Under Fire and what's his move here is
pretty easy he has one move that defends
the Knight and defends the pawn queen
diagonal to to the right hand side Queen
E3 protects both the black king is also
about to get checkmated so it's not just
the white king in danger the black king
actually may be even more trouble so
great recognition by Wesley also great
time management by him he's been leading
on the clock from start to the finish
and now not back just down to a minute
left and his chances are going out the
window and I want to draw your attention
to the left side of the board because
that Central Pawn was grabbed by Magnus
Carlson and we were talking about
whether you take advantage of the pin or
not Fabby instead of hoovering all the
pawns off the board steps up with The
Rook to the Central File attacks that
night white has moved the Rook as well
are we expecting all the trades on that
E5 Square pick up that B4 Pawn draw
agreed yeah Fabiano kowana has the
chance to draw pretty much on the spot
if he trades off the white knight in the
center of the board over there if he
takes it it's a draw guaranteed he's
looking for more he's trying to look for
options to keep the game alive but
ultimately there was nothing else he
takes takes takes takes the Rooks off
the board as well black will take the
pawn and dead draw we see a handshake
Carson against Carana it is a draw first
game between the two top players in the
world world number one and world number
two ends in a draw three more rapid
games to go meanwhile Wesley putting the
finishing touches in his game has nbec
managed to muddy the water from a
practical
standpoint yes and no I'm going to say
yes he's muddied it it looks a bit of a
mess right now uh Wesley so chose Messi
as his favorite footballer this position
is the definition of Messi but I do
think he's going to win it I think he's
just got too much control he's got an
extra Rook nbec trying his best to set
up these sneaky traps attacking White's
Rook on D1 now threatening to maybe
bring the black Rook to B3 but look at
this Wesley so so energetic Knight to C6
counterattacking against the black Rook
watch out for the black king Checkmate
on the back rank incoming and I think
this will be the Clincher there's
Checkmate on the back rank there's a
Checkmate if that Queen lands on G7
everything is a problem for nirc he's
also down an entire Rook right it's not
like he has material compensation and I
think that's the point even if he
doesn't deliver the check and the Queens
get traded off that's an end to the game
as well where there's one check that
black gets in do not step up with that
King to A2 that would be a mate on
Wesley so he blocks it with the queen no
time to pick up the Rook on D1 because
black screen is hanging on F6 and that
is it it's handshakes Wesley gets the
job done in game one on his route to try
to level the mat Scar and take it to set
three we heard that interview with
Wesley and Danny Wesley talking about
his best game ever against Sergey kakin
which was a beautiful one you should all
look that up but this game right here
that was also a sight to behold he just
crushed nyback never gave him a chance
absolutely and I think that was the more
impressive thing than the actual win
itself that how it was Wesley dominating
from start to finish the Magnus Fabby
game which ended in a draw was peaceful
throughout and I think for that Fabby
should be relieved with the black pieces
once again neutralizing out of the Kings
Pawn opening keeping everything under
control but Wesley was uh the MVP of
this round yeah this was Wesley so at
his best back to another level and uh I
want to show some highlights from that
game from that classy Victory against
Abdu satoro in the first game of
today we will uh get to that segment and
throughout the Champions chest the
players right now are in Toronto playing
over the board but throughout the season
they have been setting up their Opera
browsers and been playing some
spectacular spectacular online chess it
is uh the first the world's first ever
chess team browser with some really cool
features including a built-in VPN you've
got the missenger on the side and the
best part my favorite part Robert
there's a chess.com integrated on the
sidebar you click it and you can stop
playing chess
immediately I mean I'm it's bad news for
a lot of people out there who need to
stop playing so much chess I know some
of you are playing chess into the Wii
hours you know who you are maybe take a
break every now and then but it's really
cool just one click away you get to go
and play your friends or anyone on the
internet the offer Raza you've got to
check it out and David's going to show
you how it's done while analyzing a key
position as well David that's right
Tanya Robert uded to those chess addicts
out there I am one of them and I'm going
to show you not just how I play but also
how I analyze these games so this is my
start screen nothing special going on
until you see the Opera browser I'm
going to open it up this is my homepage
you see the cool background here
chess.com integrated indeed I'm going to
go to the shortcut this is uh my
favorite feature you can go there
minimize it when your boss comes around
at work if you're secretly playing some
chess games and uh this is how I analyze
so right now you have all the options
here of course I'm going to go in to the
Champions chess tour finals and uh here
we do see us on the screen our broadcast
but not just that I'm going to go into
the games where Wesley so did defeat uh
nbec Abdu satov and this game we see if
I can maximize which I will try to do
here uh we do see the game we had
earlier weso did win and it was just
this one moment I wanted to highlight
The Classy moment where he clinched it
all the way back in in the early stages
of the middle game with this beautiful
Bishop along the diagonal here we have
the computer moves the accuracy
incredible 947 and 94.7 in a complicated
position but it was here Pawn to H4 want
to remember at home push those Rooks
pawns especially when your opponent has
a Sitting Duck a sitting Target here
like the black king and just a few moves
down the line the H Pawn was the one the
wrecking ball it wrecked the black
King's structure there were all sorts of
checkmates and later this diagonal
became the essential one Wesley wrapped
up the win of a piece just a few turns
down the line Pawn to F4 and he went on
to clinch the
game Opa is amazing and the speed with
which Wesley so got the job done in game
one is also amazing and before we start
game two we got a couple of minutes the
perfect time to get your Opera browser
on go. chess.com
Opera best ever chess team browser in
the world and Wesley s got a smile on
his face after that fantastic game won
from start to finish forless play and
meanwhile nbec Abdus satra will be
fighting it back we will be back in just
a
[Music]
few nbec Abdu satoro is a phenomenon the
teenage Prodigy from usbekistan had his
first big breakthrough in 2021 when he
won the world rapid championship since
then he has smashed through the 2700
barrier and even LED his country to
their first ever gold medals at an
Olympiad it is Abdu zoro's endgame
skills that truly set him apart from his
peers he has a very mature approach to
the end game as evidenced by this win
against Magnus Carlson in the 2021 World
rapid
championship in this position Abdu
sattorov had white he is ahead in this
race Whit porn only being one square
away from promotion and after a car move
by Magnus playing the pawn to B4 he
didn't get tempted he wasn't greedy he
did not capture this Pawn instead
delivering a very accurate check this
immediately provoked a mistake from
Carlson the end game is winning for
white anyway but Carlson Advanced his
King to the corner and this cross check
forcing the queen exchange won the game
for Abdu satoro after the queen
disappeared white is about to make a new
Queen and he went on to win the
game a new open for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
[Music]
things
who doesn't love the Mitten flashy and
it is on our mer store some great gifts
that you can pick up for the holiday
season head to tescom do shop it's
bigger it's better and it's cuter than
ever and speaking of plushies it is time
to get to some plush chess as Wesley so
gets the early lead in his match against
nbec Abdus satro and he gets it done
taking off one of Magnus Carlson's goals
for 23 win a chess game with one B3 and
speaking of Magnus Kaia got up with the
world number
one game one is a draw and is that a
good result for for you Magnus uh when
uh well Fabby will have to win this
match um I think it's all right um I
wasn't thrilled about the way
um yeah I wasn't thrilled about the way
that I that I handled it I I think my
play was a little bit too too soft I was
thinking after all these exchanges that
I might have some uh good Bishop versus
uh sorry good knight versus bad Bishop
scenario at some point but it's not
um I think it's not remotely
um realistic so um yeah I I I yeah I
think that was a bit of a m misjudgment
like generally white doesn't have much
in general but the way that I played it
just made it really easy for him but um
yeah at least it's nice to have one game
that's
not um you know like
yeah yeah all right M today we have been
talking about your goals today because
yesterday uh you checked off your goal
of winning a game from minus 10 position
um so first of all uh resourcefulness I
guess was like the topic for you
yesterday what is the topic for you
today well clearly in the first game a
bit of solidity but uh I'm I'm sure the
match will take off eventually all right
and uh two more goals here have fun I
have to ask you have you checked that
off in the CCT season this season oh
yeah I mean I've definitely had lots of
fun in in different uh tournaments and
um finals as well it's been a little bit
stressful at times but it's uh still had
some fun moments right so we're going to
get that checked off but the third one
to win a game with one B3 I know you
can't reveal your openings but do you
have an ambition to make that happen
before the CCT 2023 is finished I
haven't won a game with B3 this season
no okay then uh then I might have to try
and funny that we are talking about that
because I don't know if you checked out
Wesley Soul game he played with 1 B3 and
I think he just won that
game yeah I mean what's not to what's
not to like like it's not a terrible
move okay okay well uh not to reveal any
of your opening tactics but what is it
about for you rest of today I don't know
really um I mean so far that's a bit of
a tentative start uh but um yeah we'll
see what he what he uh wants in the in
the in the second game all right well go
have some fun Magnus thank you for
stopping we will get that checked off
Magnus Carlson confirms he has had a lot
of fun in the CCT season this season so
back to you guys and we've had so much
fun as well Ka there giving some opening
ideas maybe 1 B3 needs to check that off
his list he doesn't have that much time
but there is also a world rapid and
Blitz coming up later yeah Magnus has
time to check that off his list he's
having a lot of fun that's a good thing
and I was just thinking he said his play
was a little bit too soft that was the
first draw between them yesterday I I
don't know who was Paul Dano and who was
Daniel de Lewis but there was definitely
blood today we have a quieter start in
their match but Wesley on the other hand
he got the job done against nck in game
one how much would you love to see
Fabiano throw one B3 at Magnus right now
just to be a bit of a troll just to get
in magnus's mind uh it feels like all
the players are having fun out there in
RTO BBY needs to get in on the action
yeah he does and we did have a lot of
action with five decisive games
including the Armageddon between these
two in set one a slow solid start
between the world number one and world
number two but there was it was anything
but solid on our other matchup Wesley
still going all out today I think that
nck would have preferred to be solid but
Wesley gave him no chance at all Wesley
was in a punishing mood he delivered a
knockout very quickly that was barely
even a game I don't think nck even felt
like he got his feet beneath him so
we'll see what n brings in game two he
actually has come back from a deficit
three different times in the Champions
chest or finals here he's proven already
that he can do it yeah includ cluding
against Hikaru in the survival stage as
well losing game one striking back and
then knocking Hikaru Nakamura out on day
one on set one of this very semi-finals
nbec Abdu satov lost the first game and
then strikes straight back what does he
need to take away from those two games
is exactly what he's thinking about he
starts with the white pieces what will
be critical in the opening in this one
well firstly he needs a better opening
than the previous game luckily starting
with white he'll dictate the nature of
the play the horn structure and uh maybe
he'll be able to land the first surprise
I think that would be key for nobec but
then just do what he's been doing
throughout the tournament as robbert
mentioned he's come back so many times
his play is decisive by nature and he's
got to take inspiration from these
semi-finals in general we've had 11
games including yesterday's Armageddon
nine decisive results only two draws it
feels like something's in the air out
there and he can take inspiration even
from the first game he got into big
trouble against Wesley so but finding
that resource with Knight D7 Knight C5
not a back is sharp it shows that he's
not going to go down without a fight but
he's playing Wesley so and you look at
Wesley he's ready for game two and we
are ready for game two as well and in
just a few seconds we will have the
first moves nbec abdat playing catchup
he starts with the white pieces will it
be the king's spawn opening it is the
Queen spawn opening Wesley there
adjusting the pieces zop and what is he
going to start with Knight to F6 ooh he
lingered on his Knight for a second but
NOP it's uh symmetry copy cat chess D4
D5 and the Queen's Gambit offered by
Abdu satoro rejected swiftly by Wesley
so going for the slav defense one of the
most solid openings in chess and uh what
variation of this slav will we see how
ambitious will nbec be here all the
knights are out now and decision time
does black just set up more pawns on
solid squares does he capture white Pawn
here we go semis slav and uh the
triangle variation where black just puts
PA p in the center it's interesting
because Wesley in classical chess as
well has often chosen to play Queen game
at accepted positions where he takes
that pawn on C4 but he doesn't want to
give ner backck the center when you
steal that pawn it is a Gambit white
would control some key Central squares
namely the E4 Square so Wesley he's
adopting a much more solid approach he
says that my Pawn triangle is going to
keep control of the center for now I can
develop my dark Square Bishop Castle my
king I think that Wesley's taking the
right approach thus far and very
instructive how Wesley waits for white
to first develop the bishop and then
captures that Central C Pawn forcing
nbak to waste one move by having to play
the bishop twice and immediately strikes
with B5 this is still within Theory
territory that Bishop the light Squad
Bishop that Wesley has will come out to
B7 and often these positions are again
about getting those Central breaks in
for black if Wesley's able to get the C5
going but right now under control what
do you make of this Choice by Wesley to
dissolve the center yeah interesting
choice it means that he's deep been
opening preparation otherwise Wesley
wouldn't be playing like this giving
white extra Central pawns lovely shot
there I've got to say with both Fabiano
and Magnus super curious super
interested in the opening developments
before they get ready for their own
games these top players they love love
chess they want to learn all the time
and uh okay they go off ready to start
their match but in the meantime it is
nbec the first to slow down NC's
thinking here because he has a big
Choice does he push his Pawn in the
center E4 they say is best by test and
he can test Wesley right here to see if
Wesley understands the Dynamics of the
pawns pushing but I think that right now
nck should be happy with the outcome
even though he's the one thinking it
will be a fight in the center with nbec
expanding with E4 and Wesley trying to
break with C5 and meanwhile this Fight
Continues with Fabiano starting with the
white pieces and once again we see him
employ the King's Pawn opening and this
time no Sicilian B Magnus Carlson his
opening of choice for the Armageddon a
more solid approach thankfully we will
not see a bin the ccil was killed
yesterday Bano Carana beat Magnus
Carlson the white side of that rosim was
Sicilian so now we get an Italian game
and it's a quieter start there could
have been a fried liver for those of you
who are learned chess as kids where
everyone's playing the fried liver going
straight for that F7 Pawn not here not
against Magnus Carlson there's a ton of
theory there and at the highest level
that theory often allows black to
equalize yeah just looks like normal
things happening on the board and shout
out to air things uh for showing us the
air quity out there in Toronto looks
like perfect conditions for the players
we see the chairs we see the uh kind of
Esports Arena we've built for them and
no complaints about the uh conditions
great uh yeah great temperature Magnus
loves it warm out there 25 degrees in
Toronto I'm jealous sitting here in
Norway where it's freezing outside but
uh in the meantime early days it is the
Italian opening and Fabiano very
ambitiously brings his Bishop out so
he's feeling good he's feeling ambitious
in this game as evidence this last move
it is risky why Bishop could be
misplaced if he gets kicked about but it
is provocative at the same time asking
black to push pawns forward and that's
the kind of Chess you need to play right
now and that last move by Magnus it just
signals that he wants to keep everything
under control in this position wants to
keep it as solid and basically ask Fabby
to show his cards to try to create
something Magnus not getting provoked to
push the G Pawn forward just yet we see
Fabby trying to get play more space on
the queen side that a pawn can further
down the board to A5 a technique that
got him good results in set one it did
indeed and right now I think that Magnus
has a bit of a passive position but he's
okay with that if he keeps drawing the
games the good news for Fabiano in
particular is that a 22 tie there are no
ties with Armageddon on the line so for
Fabiano if he just draws the next three
games he still have a chance in
Armageddon but mag says I don't want to
risk losing I don't want to play
anything overly ambitious why should I I
won set one I have the inside track to
the finals yeah historically Magnus has
such a monster score in Armageddon chess
uh Norway chessed the event earlier this
year he won seven in a row there only
losing one eventually this tournament
he's only lost one Armageddon Magnus to
Wesley so and uh yeah I think Fabiano
it's nice to have that safety net but he
needs to strike earlier and these Pawn
pushes it does show he's being ambitious
Magnus Unsure how to react this is
always frustrating when the opponent
pushes their Rooks Pawn on either flank
so far up the board do you block it do
you let it continue advancing we've seen
that backfire on multiple occasions that
white porn could well become a queen
later on it's so close to promotion
later in the end game a real Ace card up
his sleeve and Magnus pausing For
Thought does he want to waste time even
looking at the queen side maybe he
focuses on the other flank uh right now
and if he does that then he's uh
provoking or inviting Fabby to push that
Aon even further down the board if white
if it's white to play I think A6 becomes
a reality in the position you really
want to break down on the queen side for
Magnus the choic is does he continue
with development or waste that one tempo
pushing his own a pawn stopping the
Advance on the left side of the board I
would be tempted to pause and go A6 here
yeah it's magnus's style as well not to
allow pawns too far kind of too deep
into his throat into his position here
and uh it's actually magnus' style to
push his own Brook spawns up the board
as far as possible as early as possible
so Fabby taking a leaf out of magnus's
book and okay he doesn't block its
advance so white might well be able to
establish a really strong Pawn on A6 in
the next few moves first a question
light Bishop trade or no light Bishop
trade Fabian has to decide what to do
with this tension right now I think he
more orless has to trade the light score
Bishops but does he want to actually
take that black Bishop on E6 and we see
him just grab it now double pawns
they're often criticized not seen as
particularly good in the end game but at
this stage double pawns means open files
that Rook next to the black king it's on
a semi-open line there could be an
attack in the future and now the A6 pawn
it doesn't feel as strong because if you
push it up there for Fabby you can can't
really capitalize on the light score
weaknesses without your light score
Bishop yeah therefore Fabiano just
completes development he gets castle
with the white King Super safe now and
mnus needs to deci uh decide upon a plan
White's plan is simple White's going to
expand on the queen Side Pawn to C3 Pawn
to B4 throw pawns forward maybe uh kind
of eventually aim to open the center but
uh just really tense right now and wow
onas isn't forced Magnus did you not
realize not to get the memo he puts a
Pawn on B5 we say wow because it's such
a anti kind of intuitive move I think
we're so uh kind of the idea is so
ingrained deep within us that we can
never allow aason at any cost that we
sometimes forget these types of moves
exist and uh yeah he's basically saying
I'm byp passing your porn if you don't
capture me on passant right now White's
a porn might stick out like a sore thumb
but if Faby was to on passan that only
helps Magnus to develop his pieces
without moving it even wants and that's
that Rook on a that will be very happy
after the a pawns move on to the B file
I would be surprised if Fabi Ashi
decides to go a takes B6 the on pan that
you're talking about natural moves like
put that C2 Pawn to C3 and I've got a
big threat on the board would be
something that I would consider here
David I want to go Queen B3 next but
just as I said Fabby takes a drastic
decision he decides to go for the trade
on B6 does this surprise you at all
Robert I am surprised because I think
that this allows black to continue his
plan he's just trying to trade off
pieces that pawn on E6 it's hard to
Target it it's a maybe the one weakness
in Black's position and Fabby he's
continuing to develop like nothing has
happened at all but I don't know where
he is going to strike because if you
push D4 in the center that eventually
will allow a series of Trades black will
no longer have double pawns so I don't
think that Magnus is the least bit
unhappy and we first have to trade Rook
something like that but the point still
stands that it will allow black to UND
double the pawns and that means that
there's no issue whatsoever I think
Magnus just like Fabby in game one is
super happy in game two yeah Magnus
described his play as a bit soft it
feels like White's play has been a bit
soft here as well not able to achieve
anything much and like you said Robert
if you trade off Rooks and then go D4
this is kind of the only uh kind of
logical way to make progress right now
or at least the most direct path but
yeah just a series of Trades why should
black ever be worse here I don't see it
black can always block the center push a
bunch of different porns depending on uh
his taste right now and looks very very
level to me yeah well Magnus Carlson can
afford to be solid Fabby cannot this is
one of his two whites and he has to find
a way to break through and he has to do
it soon this game looks like Magnus
should be happy out of the opening
outcome no big weaknesses rook's getting
traded off on the aile while on our
other board to me it looks like the kind
of opening that you want when you are in
a must-win situation well not in this
particular game but over the match nck
has to score somewhere we see an
asymmetrical Pawn structure there is an
offer of a knight on e4 but more
importantly the fight for the C5 square
if white is able to control that white
does end up with an advantage out of the
opening and black can go wrong here in a
number of ways for example a tempting
move a rookie it's a great move from
Wesley so you don't want to push your
pawns too soon that was a lesson I was
about to try to teach everybody because
if he had pushed his B Pawn too early
that gives white just hands it over to
light squares and that would be light
Square domination it' be hard for black
to fight off for those squares so I
think that this is a great start for
Wesley is he going to strike with C5
it's a question that will remain
unanswered until Wesley actually plays
that move because that's the key idea
yeah just building up Wesley keeping the
tension and uh body language it doesn't
look like Wesley's too thrilled with
this position but at least he has no
weaknesses and if he does get that uh
kind of C5 break we will show this on
the board shortly but um if it's all
about that square all about that PN
break and Abdu sator of not obvious
moves to clamp down yet he still needs a
bit of uh a helping hand I would say
here in order to fully achieve exactly
uh what he wants right now White's goals
to shut down that C5 break not quite
attainable right now so really tense
position really balanced but nybeck I
wouldn't say that this is exactly what
he would have been hoping for he would
have maybe wanted something a bit more
Dynamic rather than playing for these
small uh kind of strategic preventing uh
porn break type of ideas but it's never
easy to achieve that when you're playing
against a player like Wesley no no tough
to beat tough to beat and in this one
tough to crack as well the position that
we have in front of us uh once again it
is a fight for who gets control of that
C5 Square I'm looking at natural moves
here for white you know you're playing
on the white side you want to get your
Rooks into the game you want to get them
onto the Central File the good news for
nbec right now is that because of the
pressure on the pawn next to the C Pawn
the B Pawn the B5 Pawn C5 isn't exactly
easy to achieve for black and black did
have a free move I think he can get away
with C5 simply because the Rook on C8
stares down the path towards the black
queen on C2 so C5 is a huge idea and you
see that ner Beck first trades and he's
trading some more so he is doing
everything he can to prevent the C5 push
because now if there's a knight trade
again in the center as the Knight covers
C5 you can't play C5 because the bishop
is loose the queen B6 for black that's
often the way to solve your problems is
you defend your Bishop you reinforce the
C5 score but white is just in time to
push with B4 now and truly clamp down on
the queen side so not's doing everything
right here he keeps posing this question
can you get C5 in will you be able to
make it work and for the moment it
doesn't seem that easy to accomplish for
Wesley yeah the big question is does
Wesley have options does he have to
trade off a set of knights looks like
the White Knight is heading into the
square and just to show what not to do
uh kind of The Nightmare scenario for
black is to just kind of ignore this uh
to allow the White Knight to park itself
on C5 to have to trade off and to be
left with a horrible horrible uh Bishop
this is why we're talking about this
Pawn break so much because suddenly you
could find yourself with a dead piece
stuck behind its own Pawn here on C6 and
white would have the bishop air white
would have a bind on the dart squares
this would be oneid of traffic and
actually I think long-term white simply
winning so you have to act very quickly
Wesley so before a white knight lands on
the Square or before white is able to
clamp down with a move like B4 the more
you're breaking this down the more we're
looking at this position it just feels
like this is advantage back unless
there's something immediate and I think
Wesley realizes exactly all these points
and he's going all out for it he makes
the move C5 one thing is easy to spot
that if white was to take the B5 Pawn
black captures on D4 really good but my
question what happens if white was going
to take the Knight on F6 I want to
deflect your Bishop from E7 and capture
the C5 Pawn but wesy relying on a very
nice tactic the queen D5 at the end
lining up his bishop and queen to the G2
Square so you have to stop Checkmate
white is forced to do that otherwise you
lose and then Queen takes C5 and there's
no way black is really in any danger at
this and in fact Rook takes C5 if you
push F3 IV was think E4 perhaps instead
just to force the matter and after the
Queens are traded B5 is defended A5 may
not be but B2 is loose so too many pawns
are hanging for both sides to give
anyone an advantage yeah really
beautiful tactics and he played 1 B3 in
the first game suddenly his long uh his
kind of uh long piercing Bishop in this
game as well on the long diagonal is the
key piece look at the G2 Pawn it's
vulnerable Knight takes C5 was going to
be the other move I wanted to suggest
originally but again Queen to D5 type of
ideas here threatening Checkmate and
this is just really awkward to answer
how does white uh kind of block this
Checkmate threat the answer is if you
push your Pawn to E4 you might just
collapse on the C file this would be a
disaster town and if you push F3
suddenly look at these white Bishops
lined up skewed on the defile so noet
correctly did avoid this he went for the
other option as tan mentioned but
already Wesley so throwing the tactics
out there hidden uh kind of gems there
from Wesley the tactics and Bishop takes
I'm assuming he's going to appear on the
board is he really contemplating taking
with the pawn oh my gosh oh that would
be ugly for the black king but maybe not
objectively bad maybe the black king
will Shuffle out the way the black Rook
would land on the G file later wow
Wesley so he's paused for a reason and
when the top players stop when there's
natural moves it means they're thinking
about something a bit crazy a bit spicy
but he does go back with the bishop and
take do you think if he drew the first
game instead of having one he might have
really considered G takes F6 there's no
need to risk it but the engines they
approve of it and Wesley was
legitimately thinking there so you know
that he kind of wanted to play it yeah
but Bishop takes KN given the Matt
situation such a good human approach
here and for me it's also so impressive
just this excellent understanding that
the top players have the grand Masters
have of these critical moments we were
looking just to stop we were looking at
Queen D5 instead another way another
tactics to actually equalize the
position yes white can take the bishop
thank you very much give me your Bishop
on D3 uh and I think then black will be
attacking the C5 Pawn but just
understanding these critical moments
that you need to break out now or you
pass over the advantage Wesley sensed it
he sensed that moment and energetically
played C5 yeah that's the thing we talk
about players Styles we say certain
players are really hyper aggressive
they're very direct they always kind of
have this itch to do something we say
other players are solid they like to
curl up but ultimately if you give a
good player a position where there's
only one way to keep the balance or they
need to act energetically kind of in
that specific moment more often than not
they play the position rather than uh
anything else they go for it they find
the best moves so that was the case
Wesley had to break out with C5
otherwise he would have been suffering
long term he found it uh yes he had to
rely on tactics yes he had to calculate
a bit but he pushed himself to do it and
uh I think black is totally fine here to
your point Wesley so is one of the most
accurate players in chess history he may
not always win games because he doesn't
take risk in moments where some people
make make a speculative decision to go
for an attack but he is incredibly
precise and he will punish you and right
now n irck he's the one who's deep in
thought right now can I continue this
game but perhaps if he does continue if
he doesn't take this bishop get to a
position with opposite colored Bishops
where it should be equal maybe he's the
one who can get in trouble his pawns are
split after all there's pressure all the
way down towards the white king So for
nck Who's down 2 and a half minutes in
the clock I think he might just have to
settle for that half Point by just
getting into opposite Bishop position
but he needs to be precise to even get
that half a point at the moment and we
see the clock situation as well Wesley
ahead on the clock so for norback uh the
next few moves are quite critical now he
can either take the bishop on B2 but
there is a check on the board that he
can throw in as well all the way on 87
does that change the position in any way
the Dynamics of the position potentially
it does force the black king into the
corner and uh I guess the question is
now do you take this bishop or do you
just move your Rook out the way I'm not
sure you should delay too much longer if
you move the Rook for example then the
bishop just gets out of Dodge just moves
away and no good discovered attacks
against the black queen actually this
Pawn is being rounded up watch out for
Black's Queen coming over and striking
against the king side wow he plays the
same idea just a different order but I
think again if this bishop check isn't
scary as we just showed it's just a one
move threat black just Dodges then
Wesley has the time just grab a pawn be
greedy and Dav just complete that line
because I think it's that's the key
point this threat on G2 that after if
you do grab the pawn bishop check on H7
only move for the king to h8 Bishop C1
would hit the queen and the bishop on H3
but it's got to be Queen G5 G5 F4 and
queen takes C5 yeah know everything is
defended but I actually I think I
understand just to finish this line the
queen trade is more or less forced and
black has just stolen two pawns but I
think I understand what nck missed he's
not going to play Bishop C1 in this
exact sequence that we're going down
he's going to try Bishop H7 check and
then Bishop to B4 but after Bishop B4
Queen G5 F4 there's no more Queen takes
C5 the bishop defends the C5 Pawn now
your Queen's under attack but Queen
takes G2 check is the problem that the
queen trade his forc Bishop takes G2 and
now all the Bishops are hanging for both
sides that White's Bishops and Black's
Bishops are under attack and your rook's
under attack on F1 so if you take this
bishop in front of the king black simply
takes this bishop on B4 and how many
pawns you going to be up three no two in
the end but it's uh just going to be a
winning Advantage for black yeah yeah
just simple calculation here and I think
this is well within Wesley so's
wheelhouse he does take the pawn he's
gone up material and nck has no good way
to justify his sacrifice it's not just
any old pawn as well those two connected
black pass pawns on the queen side are
simply going to roll down the board
unless you have something now wow Wesley
with speed and accuracy goes Pawn
hunting it looks like he's calculated
this line to the end nag in big trouble
and we've got our crew joining us from
Toronto Danny NC's got to be feeling the
heat right now things have gone very
wrong for
him yeah we were all debating uh about
whether we would see a repeat of the day
before when Wesley so won the first game
but Notre came storming back when he had
his first chance at the white pieces but
it doesn't look like that's what we're
going to see and instead if Wesley wins
this game are we already planning on a
very long day of chess if we want to
remind the fans he would need to win
this set then they would move to a two
game mini match and then we would get
Armageddon if they're still tied after
that so for fans who wanted a lot of
Chess today we might be we might be
looking at
that if Wesley so gets a two-point lead
in this match especially when you're
playing against a guy like Wesley I
think you can give up pretty much all
practical hopes of making a comeback in
a match you'd have to win two games on
demand yeah I mean I don't know that all
practical hope would be the case and he
is he is Young right and what is this
what is the saying too young to know
better right I think that Notre Beck
plays one game at a time and I wouldn't
bet against him winning two but yes I
mean you only need two and a half points
to win the set of four so at this point
we're looking at two pass pawns on the
queen side I'm listening to I can tell
when Robert's voice is to him um and I
can tell he's getting nervous right now
sorry what am I getting nervous about
Denny I just had one question for you on
a serious note if you're Nery backck and
you lose this game you're down nothing
really you're likely to lose this second
set do you almost make a quick draw to
conserve your energy for the reset or do
you continue fighting it out because we
know noty backck he never wants to make
a quick draw what would you advise him
if you were his
coach and I knew you weren't getting
nervous I just wanted to hear your voice
for so sorry for for uh for the call out
um you took the bait though now we're
having a conversation cuz I miss you um
I don't know that nottock would ever
think like that Robert I think he's
going to play one game at a time and I
think that's what you should do right
because it's still chess no matter what
at the end of the day um I think Magnus
Carlson has led this generation with
that mindset where we've seen him push
for wins when he only needed a draw
right or complete you don't complete
epic comebacks by not winning one game
at a time right so I don't I don't think
that'll be the case I think he'll be
focused on the next game and um and deal
with what comes if I had to guess yeah
and Danny at the start of the show you
mentioned that Wesley's been in a good
mood we saw his interview as well
earlier and despite the loss in set one
it looks like his spirits are high he's
enjoying himself in Toronto have you
been feeling that as well that despite
what happened in set one Wesley's
feeling
good I I think the spirits have been
high for everybody I almost I almost
feel bad because the conversation that
happened out in the lounge after after
Notre Beck lost the first game was all
of us debating on what his nickname
should be I said this is really serious
work because you're going to be
dominating chess for a very long time
what is your nickname we got to figure
this out and um that was literally what
we all engaged in I'll keep it hidden as
far as where we're landing on that so
the fans can await with baited breath
but uh no I mean honestly everyone's
having a good time uh players are
hanging out I think it actually helps
their mindset to really feel relaxed and
uh and uh casual um but uh yeah I we'll
see we'll see how not's feeling if he
loses this game he might he might not
engage with us on uh on the the content
that we're doing for uncovered for those
who haven't checked out Fabiano and
Christian trill's podcast and the things
he's doing here it's actually pretty
cool stuff so check out shout out to
Christian's YouTube channel sorry I
don't even know what is off the top of
my head the cqu podcast go check it out
and Danny I want to pitch in my idea for
the nickname it should be no dear
comeback and because I think he will
come back later but uh on a serious note
what about the other matchup between
Magnus Carson and Fabiano Carana which
is much more KY uh what do you make of
that has it altered your predictions uh
in any
way no I mean I well I guess my overall
match prediction was that we will have a
Magnus Carl and a Magnus Carlson playing
in the final um I think he's the
favorite I although I did talk to Fabby
I was like man get us Armageddon today
let's go so rooting for him to get us
all the chess he can um you know this
position actually looks pretty tame
although we did just see Fabby play F4
that's new since the last time I looked
and the the first thing that jumps out
to me is that Magnus is also down
significantly on the clock so okay maybe
maybe this is the start of fobby press
pressing and you know you have to you
have to get aggressive against Magnus
Right Wesley sacked a piece against
Magnus that's that's how you beat him
right you got you got to uh swing at the
king and don't miss so I think putting
pressure on Magnus with white look at
this I'm liking it you see the advantage
growing here and Magnus down on time
Danny you get a wood Harris video and
suddenly you're just going to be coing
the wire the whole time but uh you know
you just said that he has to come after
Magnus and what would you make of Fab's
play yesterday not just what would you
make did you speak to him I know he lost
set one but how was he feeling
considering he beat Magnus two games in
a
row yeah I mean I I think we can say
this now there was um day two of this
event Fabby was actually feeling pretty
under the weather and if you remember
that was a day that he did not play well
he started out 2-0 and then went 0 and2
on day two with around Robin didn't want
to talk about that especially if Fabby
didn't recover but he said he's feeling
much better now he was sipping some tea
and he seemed in good spirits and I
think that from a from an athletes
mindset right you're always focusing on
a narrative that can get you to perform
at your best and I think Fabby knows he
lost but he lost to Magnus Carlson who
is known for doing things like that but
objectively did Fabiano play just as
good a chess if not better chess than
Magnus in a lot of the positions right I
mean it was Topsy Turvy fobby kind of
beat himself too so so yeah I think I
think he did play well and look at this
now I mean he just actually as I'm
talking about the mindset I don't think
it's going to matter I mean I think he's
just about to blow Magnus off the board
is Knight F five coming how do you stop
this Danny Fabby is about to blow Magnus
off the board and it looks like Wesley
is about to blow nck off the board what
crazy crazy action going on we're going
to Deep dive into this and check in with
you uh really soon but guys take this
away over the last couple of
moves beep has hit the fan sorry yeah a
lot has gone down just in the last few
moments Magnus Carson has lost control
uh I don't want to say blunder because
it's been a series of small inaccuracies
from Magnus Carson but he's allowed
White's Rook to penetrate to infiltrate
to the seventh rank on the left board on
your screens right now look at that
white Rook it's got the black king in
its sights it's got the black queen in
its sights the bishop is pinned Knight
and F5 as Danny mentioned is just Lights
Out it's Unstoppable pretty much
meanwhile On The Other Board Wesley so's
given up his Queen what has he got in
return for it he's got a rook bishop and
two pawns and it's the power of those
two pawns but I'm going to say that
actually the Wesley so board is far from
decided for now because a queen is the
queen White's Queen is active and uh
there we see the evaluation bar rising
up slightly Abdus stor not not dead yet
but but Magnus I think he's busted still
some life for Nock on the right hand
screen although um Wesley is in the
driver seat but I think Magnus is busted
because he had to break the pin towards
his Queen now that allows the White
Queen to slide into the E6 square and
those light squares in front of the
blacking are and all three white pieces
are attacking and black I don't think is
going to be able to fend it off yeah we
talk about it all the time quen and
Knight combo the the most devastating
attacking Duo out there but he has a
rook as well and Queen Knight Rook
Black's King is be not going to
survive I've never seen Magnus get
knocked out this kind of smoothly
Fabiano hasn't even done anything too
special he pushed a b to F4 at the right
moment broke open lines and Magnus has
collapsed pretty much he just needs to
put the finishing touches on but six
minutes for Fabby one for Magnus yeah
just a few minutes ago just a few
moments ago just a few moves ago it
looked like everything was fine for
Magnus Carlson and then suddenly the
position just explodes fa's winning dud
I'd love to see what happened where did
Magnus go wrong and it looks like the
moves are coming in really quickly
Magnus with about a minute minute on the
clock so perhaps you'd show show us
later what really happened there because
I I don't know what this turnaround is
about how did he get here which just
seems easy now I mean that Queen just
slid in The Bishop's under attack if the
bishop slides back to defend the king uh
then the Knight just hops in so all
three of Whit's pieces are going to go
for the black king I don't know how
could possibly survive yeah you need a
miracle now there's just zero
counterplay against whites King however
whites King in the kowana game has a
beautiful hiding spot a beautiful Safe
Haven on H2 and uh normally in these
positions you will not be able to defend
passively here there's no active defense
either look at magnus's pieces how sad
is this the black Bishop black queen
black Rook all on their uh back rank two
of them on their starting squares and
white night is going to join the party
this one looks almost over there's
already some really nice checkmating
patterns in the air it's looking so
strong once that Knight lands on H5 or
F5 the only thing that I think you need
to watch out from White could be that
not allowing Black's Rook to that check
on C1 and perhaps Black's Queen jumping
into an attack from the G file are those
resource resources available to Black in
these positions they are and that's why
I'm advocating on the left hand side of
our screens everyone that Fabiano's
Knight goes to the right hand side of
the board instead of hopping to F5 you
go to H5 so you can deliver a vicious
check on the F6 square and get the black
king in a man it I actually think Knight
F5 which is maybe the more natural move
if you playing on seconds you go towards
the center but I think that's wrong
because it doesn't afford the Knight a
check on the next turn I just want to
point out that Wesley so I mean he's
doing everything correctly he has those
Bishop rook and two pawns and for now
nybeck is stopping them but I think if
he as soon as he gets his Rook behind
the a pawn he can just throw that pawn
forward close his eyes and get a new
Queen yeah and that bishop and C3 it is
such a strong piece controlling that A1
Square once that a pawn starts moving
forward there's nothing that's going to
stop it and I think we're going to see
that happen Wesley does it at the cost
of a pawn but this Pawn's going to turn
into a queen yeah and he's trying to
fight Abdu satov he's going to try and
blockade blacks past Pawn on that right
board with his own Queen but Queens are
the worst blockaders in chess Knights
are the best blockaders Queens are the
worst Queens are simply uh just too
powerful too valuable you're essentially
wasting the best piece with white for
just a black porn and eventually the
queen will be get booted out of A2
anyway so Wesley he's just made it look
simple I've got to say Wesley at his
best makes chess look easy if what was
to put that Queen on A2 you simply Slide
the other Rook to the B file and get it
down to the second rank kicking that
Queen out of that defensive Square Rook
B8 Rook B2 and it's happening it's
Unstoppable and also Nock is down to his
final 15 seconds Rook B2 Pawn A2 it's
just game over it's so simple as you
said I mean Wesley makes it look simple
but n helped him out by playing very
ambitious in moment where he should have
signed the peace treaty and I'm really I
think it's very in and this one ends
Wesley so resigns and hbec Strikes sorry
I'm going to take that back Wesley
strikes again with the black pieces and
that is a two20 win for Wesley so he's
striking back in the match and looks
like he's about to take set to two games
for nbec to he has to win both to take
it to Armageddon and this one it looks
like Fab's ready to strike back a very
critical moment and I was just about to
say before that game ended that Fabby he
makes the wrong knight jump that he
slowed down and now the queen comes to
G5 and this was the idea that we were
advocating for Wow and suddenly black is
alive there's some counterplay white is
still doing well but big big threat in
the position black wants to drop a queen
into F4 with a check he Retreats his
Knight Fabiano he's setting a trap of
his own this Knight is poisoned
Untouchable if black plays Queen takes
Knight right now White's Queen slides
back to the F5 check F5 square with
check and black gets checkmated next
turn Rook takes Bishop will come with a
deadly blow wow this is really crazy
this is what Fabian is relying on but
it's not the best maybe black can hold
on he opened up two things at the same
time the F5 Square for his queen as you
were saying with check also The Rook now
covers that F4 Square so the bishop
jumps out for Magnus Carlson he's still
in this game if that Bishop can wrap
around because there are no checks
against the black king unless you want
to trade Queens which I don't think you
do that black Bishop is about to wrap
around and go harass the white king oh
12 seconds for Magnus though Fabiano
it's as if he's trying to be too clever
he's trying to find some really
sophisticated way to knock out his
opponent when he could have just done it
Brute Force One knight jump the other
direction and probably it would have
been Checkmate within three or four
moves but uh now Magnus is alive yeah
and he took a good three minute think
for that one and it just felt as if fa's
going to find the right way forward and
the big difference was that the knight
from H5 could have arrived on a check on
that F6 Square which probably would have
wrapped up the game by now but again now
Fabby with the advantage but he has to
to find it all over again Magnus has got
a brutal idea of bringing the bishop
onto an attack a check on F4 would
actually be game over for
Fabby yeah I think he has to act quickly
here Fabiano the White Knight is just on
a bit of an odd Square he's done a
little dance around the board he should
have just been uh using his inner vision
and trying to plant it on the F6 Square
its ideal post and now it does drop back
but allows the black queen to offer a
queen trade and I said no Defenders
around the black king suddenly Black's
Queen is doing a great job of holding
the squares he's going to trade he's
going to liquidate right now because
after the queen he can take that Central
Pawn with his Knight with check while
protecting his Rook so it may not be
easy to convert that Advantage
especially with the white king being a
bit vulnerable in that B2 Pawn when
their pawns on both sides of the board
Bishops usually are better than Knights
but Fabby he can steal a pawn arm
looking at his face though he doesn't
look that happy with his decision and I
wonder if it's because he missed the
bishop move because his retreating
Knight to H4 he played it really quickly
and if you just think about it in the
last three moves that white knight from
from G3 has just landed on F3 instead of
delivering Checkmate it's become a
defensive piece now Fab's best chance is
to go into an end game with an extra
Pawn but he'll have to show some good
technique when in fact he could be
checkmating Magnus right now yeah that's
the thing he knows he would have had an
in a feeling he had three attacking
pieces he knows he could have got close
to Checkmate now an end game against the
world's best ever end game player yes he
might have an extra Pawn but it's not a
stable extra Pawn Black's Rook is so
active Black's Bishop is active White's
B2 Pawn over there on the queen side
might well drop off in the near future
and rook and Bishop do do uh they do
kind of a great job against rook and
Knight in general so uh I think it's
momentum black right now and look at the
clock times from six extra minutes it's
now almost level I was about to say that
before Magnus was playing bullet while
Fabby was playing Blitz now we're about
to be in a Time scramble uh Fabby he
needs to be careful here he should take
that Queen take the pawn he5 and try to
work that endgame magic because he's
really spending so much time at this
stage he's about to hit 30 seconds
and he needs to make a decision fast and
when Queens are off the board your
decisions can be more intuitive but if
he decides to keep the Queens on the
board he'll have to rely a bit more on
calculation and he doesn't have time for
that he finally takes a decision he
should have taken in seconds grabs that
pawn on E5 all right Fabby Blitz out the
move now yeah there's a big threat
Black's Bishop is actually trying to
slide back to D6 the white king White
Knight are on the same dark Square
diagonal so he has to stop it he does
brilliant move there from Fabiano
caruana but again he's look a bit slow
with his decisions when it's prettyy
much forced moves and Magnus creating
counterplay wh's B2 porn is weak is
going to drop off it might become a race
and I see the evalar give white a big
Advantage but I think from a practical
perspective it's not clear to the
players it's going to be a race between
fabby's e Center pawn and magnus's B
Pawn uh down the board he doesn't grab
it immediately comes back with the
bishop threatening a big check on F4
which would have picked up the Knight
and now he's going to grab the pawn so
Bishop was uh you know in the rook's
line of sight so oh gives a check first
but now the white king can just step I
think forward at any moment here he's
going into the center so as long as
Fabby doesn't walk into any kind of
Bishop F two check which would win The
Rook he does have these two Pawns in the
center so move your Rook out the way
start throwing your pawns forward now
it's level material white has two
connected pass Pawns in the center but
they take a while to mobilize one of
them's running up the board now but
Black's B Pawn looks like the quickest
of all and uh okay the white Rook stops
IT advancing for now but the bishop
drops back this one is anyone game yes
the evaluation Bar says winning for
white but Magnus he's saved a far worse
position this feels like the best he's
had in a while but it is even material
if we just count the pawns but white has
two unopposed pass Pawns in the center
and look at the Evo bar it's Skyhigh how
do you actually stop these pawns he
brings a king out of the pin the Knight
now is free to move and he pushed E5 and
now both of the pawns they're rumbling
down the board one of them is going to
become a queen for John in this match
Fabby has to finish this job he is so
close to a game win which will put put
him in a great situation to make a
comeback in set two and he blunders with
the most natural looking check on H4 wow
now black can give a couple of checks
from behind and the white E Pawn was
actually dropping while Magnus even
gives a check with the pawn stronger
perhaps he gives another check and white
pawns are collapsing Fabiano has he
blown the win oh my gosh Fabby with the
Knight moves it's just all gone wrong
and now Magnus grabs the pawn on E5
White's King can take it but Black's
Rook takes the Knight instead he's in to
Queen Magnus comes back with the bishop
defending the d8 square and for Fabiano
he needs to be careful not to lose this
game at this stage if somehow he drops
that D Pawn that would be a disaster and
Magnus he's pressing for some winning
chances of his own he's pushing his
pawns up the board this is so
reminiscent of their game one Fabby with
the white pieces up a queen lost in the
end with the black pieces with this one
as well he was winning throughout and
now it's him who's fighting for a draw
yeah white is fighting for his life but
white does have a threat white is
threatening a rook check on on B5 and
then to slide The Rook across to D5 to
block the black Rook magnus's King
Dodges Fabiano living on the edge here
and okay black sacrifices a rook for the
pawn can White's Rook stop the black
pawns this should now be a draw I think
but barely because Magnus is playing for
it yeah mag is playing for a win but
white has a check at some moment so it
looks like the black pawns are
unstoppable you push the H off the board
but he gives that check right now so the
black king it can go to H2 it's shielded
by its own Pawn but the PIN along the
second Rank and if you immediately if
you go King H1 Rook check and promote
the white king is just in time to scoop
up that final black pawn it looks like
it will be the case but Magnus makes
favy sweat he doesn't go for the direct
draw line as Robert was pointing out
pushes the pawn but now white king is in
time to pick up the last remaining pawn
and a king versus King what a fight even
Fabby can't believe it both players with
a smile on their face that was an up and
down battle and Magnus survives against
Fabby the max stays level
wow their heart rates must be Skyhigh
right now Fabiano feeling frustrated
disappointed for most of the G uh the
game he was dictating things we saw a
bit of a raised eyebrow from him there
Magnus he might not be showing it but he
is relieved and there was a smile but
it's like that Meme with the guy in the
corner and he's smiling on the outside
but it's a mask inside he's crying
Fabiano caran has had so many chances in
yesterday's match and today against
Magnus Carlson but as Fabiano himself
said unless you put Magnus away he will
fight to The Bitter End and he just
Salvage a half point and this is the
fight to get to the finals it is the
final day of the semi-finals the players
need to make it to set three and it
means that wesle so has to win his match
meanwhile Fabiano Carana has to strike
against Magnus cson to take it to that
final set it's going to be a tough one
what matches we've seen thus far Wesley
so he's become flexo once again today
he's back but for Fabiano Carana he
needs to somehow put Magnus Carlson away
when he's ahead that's a completely
winning position he wins that against
anybody else in the world but Magnus
Carlson isn't anybody else he's the
number one player and he has been for
over a decade Wesley so with a two to0
lead in his match against nag it looks
like that one is most likely headed to
the set three but David Fabby was so
close to getting that win and it all
came down to finding the right night
move exactly and I'm going to highlight
that one moment Tanya it was all about
one move it was a golden opportunity but
Fabiano he went wrong it was a coin flip
he flipped and uh he landed the Knight
on the wrong Square it was here he could
have knocked Magnus out on the spot
White's Rook supremely strong on F7
White's Queen supremely strong on the E6
Square it's just improving the remaining
piece bringing it to join the attack he
actually leapt towards the center which
90% of the time is the right idea a
knight and F5 normally does thrive but
here he needed to go towards the rim the
idea is that this is the quickest route
towards the black king this check is
potentially deadly if for example black
tries to preemptively dodge the check
then white can renew the threat by
moving the queen putting pressure on
this black Bishop pinning Black's pieces
to the uh Bishop's defense and Knight F6
is pretty much Unstoppable next turn for
example no matter what black does say
makes a move Knight into F6 threatens
Checkmate you cannot take this Knight
because of this uh kiss of death and
therefore you have to sacrifice The
Black Queen this would have been winning
for Fabiano it's so sad because it's
been like to say a knife on F5
unfortunately that choice may have been
a dagger to Fab's chances because Magnus
Carlson was able to survive it's one to
one Magnus gets white once again and
Fabby he's going to be kicking himself
wow get those puzzle rush in it's all
about tactics and Wesley so was also so
sharp getting his tactics in for that
win against nbec Wesley so once he got
an opportunity he leapt on it he was
decisive he was brilliant with his
calculation and he even sacrificed his
Queen and and it was here that nbec Abdu
satoro lost control maybe reeling from
the tactics that had already occurred he
did not find the safe move the safe idea
of first giving a check and then simply
capturing this black Bishop if he' taken
the bishop off the board we would have
been left with a position of opposite
color Bishops and most likely the game
would eventually have fizzled out
towards a draw white should be
relatively safe here instead however he
got ambitious Abdus satov he played a
tricky move Rook a to D1 but Wesley
caught his bluff who cares if the black
queen might eventually fall black wins
too much material in the meantime Wesley
grabbed a pawn and after this tricky
move Bishop to B4 he simply said give me
he took another bishop and yes there was
a Check Yes the black queen fell to the
white Rook but if we do a quick count at
the very end here black has too much
material it's about these pawns
especially but the rook and Bishop guide
them towards their end goal he
eventually got the pawn down to A2 and
was about to promote when he won the
game it's the unfortunate nature of
match play where you feel like you have
to play for a win but chess is an
objective game not a subjective one we
don't play for results nck if it the
start of event he probably would have
just peacefully made the draw
unfortunately he was going for gold and
he's the one who
lost but we know nbec can get the gold
in we saw that happen at the Olympiad as
well well he's got two games to strike
back and now it will be all about his
mindset is he just thinking about
conserving energy going in for that set
three or does he want to fight this one
out till the very end n's got some big
questions to answer and we've got some
uh big surprise prices for you with a
33% off on our very cool displates you
can use the code chess for that discount
on display.com chess every move matters
fundamental chess calculation skills I
mean this stuff is exactly what this
round was but getting that calculation
in and the players did make every move
matter but there is a big game coming up
Fabby almost got the job done in game
two in a winning position Magnus Carlson
how do you beat this guy we will be back
soon subscribers stay with us there is
cool content coming just for
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
[Applause]
we are in Toronto for the CCT finals
here with Fabiano Carana on fire these
days and you had a great run in the CCT
2023 as well how will you describe your
journey through the season poby uh I was
really motivated from the beginning so I
played all the events I think I was one
of the few players to play all the
qualifying events and it was a bit up
and down for me some disappointments but
overall a lot of really close ones I
think they were all close I don't know
if there were any um any uh you know
wash overs one way or the other and and
some disappointing ones because the when
you lose that it's really close that
also is is a bit uh painful now we are
here with the top eight players in
Toronto what makes you excited about
being here now oh I'm excited for the
format it's going to be really um I
think unusual I don't think I've played
in a format like this and also I think
it's going to be a very close fight yeah
it's going to be very exciting what are
the fans in for this week it's it's
going to be exciting that's all I can
say um there there will be a lot of
tough fights and I hope that I'll be
able to um to keep the form that I've
I've been having recently but uh I'm
yeah I'm a bit nervous it's going to be
really tough and also excited can we get
you to describe your playing style I
don't know if I'm the right person to do
that I think probably someone else would
be better I was sort of known at some
point for my
calculation um so I I uh generally been
a good at very good at calculating like
because I I'm I'm sort of a
perfectionist in some way that I I
always want to to calculate to the end
and sometimes after that my um I I Veer
away from my initial assumption about
the position which was more correct so
I've noticed that at times that uh my
instinct is actually better than what I
achieve after I start to calculate
things what what would it mean to you
fby to win the Champions chest tour 2023
yeah actually that that would be amazing
I mean it would really Crown off the
year for me yeah for me this is like a
rapid and Blitz World Championship I
know that we'll we'll have that later
this month as well but uh this has
really all the all the best players or
nearly all the best players in the world
including Magnus and Hikaru and yeah
Maxim and Ali Reza and so it's it's such
a highlevel event that winning it is is
such a Prestige awesome well we hope you
have a great time in Toronto best of
luck back
[Music]
here
Fast and Furious chest action continues
after the Champions Chester finals it
will be the feated world rapid and Blitz
where Magnus Carlson will will try and
defend his Blitz and rabbit world
championship titles it starts on 26th
December mark your calendars and Robert
you will be calling out the action it's
going to be the Dream Team you and Peter
Leo uh on the world rapid and Blitz what
are you most excited about it's such a
fun tournament the action never stops in
the Chess World so it go from here to
the world rapping and Blitz I'll be have
the call with the legendary Peter Leo
who himself almost won a world
championship title against Vladimir
chromic so I'm super excited
fastpac play and so many worthy
contenders I don't even know who's going
to win well three out of the four semi
finalists are going to be there Magnus
Carlson nber Abdus satro Fabiana Karana
amongst others the world's very best so
that's one that we're really excited
about and one player wesle so he may not
be playing at the world rapid and Blitz
but watch us he is bringing to the board
today as he takes the two and 0 lead and
kayak caught up with
Wesley Wesley l so has just come out
swinging today up two Z now in this
match how are you feeling well was very
happy because yesterday he was playing
like a total computer just like perfect
chess like he didn't give me a chance so
now at least I got some chances like uh
I thought the first game was very good
he probably made like one or two
mistakes in the opening but I was very
pleased with how it went and the second
game he just blundered Bishop takes A3
which is nice so
good to know that not back and bler well
how have you mentally been able to come
here and play play like you're doing
today after losing the match
yesterday well I'm I'm I'm good you know
I'm fine I mean
I'm you know I'm a Christian so I let
God uh I know let his will be done in
all things you know it's a job you know
I I love playing chess I'm not the best
of it I had some hopes in the past but
uh you know I love showing up giving my
best and
just um putting him some work every day
and uh you know I don't really I mean I
really appreciate that they have a large
price fund here so I'd like to take the
opportunity to take the sponsors which
many especially the shinberg family and
also Puma like okay many others too but
I really enjoy the the shoes and the
clothes that I got from Puma so I'm it's
much appr app it yeah looking very cool
um game three here you're only going to
need a draw to take it to a third set so
what will be your plan for that game uh
well to look for a drawish
line but the match isn't over until it's
over uh if I can if the match continues
like the way I'm playing and then the
way he's playing then I think I'll win
very easily but if it's not guaranteed
he could suddenly play like a machine
again so I have to be on my full forth
um I hear you keep saying that that he's
playing like machine playing perfect you
know um what everyone is talking about
in chess these days um is is that what
you are insinuating no no no not I'm not
insinuating that I just just want to
check yeah no it's not not not like that
it's just I'm actually praising him
because I know how great a player he is
like not making any cheating allegations
I'm just saying he's a really really
good player like I'm very confident with
the security checks here like there's so
much Security checks here like this is
the strictest tournament I've ever
played in they check every single pocket
uh it's just I've seen how nybeck plays
when he's in great form like the the the
match that he played in the or the games
that he played in the Olympiad also at
at Tata steel were really
impressive so uh it's uh it's it's
nothing like that he hasn't reached his
full potential yet and uh you know he's
a he's a great player but hopefully I'll
win today so appreciate you saying that
Wesley and and finally okay something
more fun so this board shows Magnus
Carlson's top three goals for the CCT
this season one of his goals was to win
a game with 1 B3 he hasn't been able to
so far this season but you have won a
game with 1 B3 and actually I hear
that's only the second time in your
rapid career that you play 1 B3 when the
first time something with leavon ronian
could it be CCT 2021 season oh
interesting yeah but how cool is that to
win a game with 1 V3 yeah no I've been
practicing a lot nice yeah like I know
adiban made the course on chess bable
well I actually didn't see it but I've
been analyzing some one B3 like I played
a lot in title Tuesdays especially first
from be3 also I played in some Blitz
Games Berlin and then some rapid games
in the Ilia levitov tournament in
Amsterdam so I've been practicing it a
lot I didn't think it would work I just
wanted to you know e before hasn't been
working well at all like I don't want to
I don't want to lose with you know with
white so I decided to play something
else and also in the second game like I
don't usually play the semi SL I just
thought I'd play some new opening and it
seems to be working well um if I had a
bigger repair tour like Magnus maybe I
could play something different every
game but we'll see fantastic well
congrats on your performance so far
today and good luck in game three yeah a
lot of games to go yeah thank you for
joining us Wesley so he won a game today
with 1 B3
amazing that was quite an amazing finish
after the cowboy opening and indeed we
do have a lot of Chess to go and
potential set three potential
armageddon's coming up as the players
are fighting the semi-finals battle on
this board only one of them will survive
to move on to the finals and for Fabiano
Kayana he was so close to getting that
comeback victory in game two and now
it's is back to the black pieces how
much of this will be about getting out
of the opening without any trouble well
uh that's always step one in any opening
especially when you have black you just
want to survive you just want to ensure
that you reach a healthy position step
one you equalize and then you start to
outplay the opponent later but uh
meanwhile we'll try to get those moves
on our uh electronic board very shortly
I don't think it's 1 B3 I'm just looking
from the side angle of the board here on
the camera but uh
okay we want those moves as the players
they're really rattling them out now on
the board and here we go it is wow the
Berlin of 1 D4 as they call it Robert
that's a really good way of putting it
and Magnus himself has been known to
compare openings to one another if they
may have a mirror image and we see that
the Knight jumps into E5 in this game
and I thought that Knight usually has to
the G5 square that when the bishop the
light School Bishop slides out here You'
be able to capture it so I think that
Magnus is the first person to deviate
from uh the main line the main
continuation here but is he going for
some aggressive intentions with a
queenside castle with check the black
king after all has moved that last
developing move by Magnus definitely
signals that he wants to put that King
on the left side of the board bring that
Rook out with a check on that black king
on d8 meanwhile Fab still has to finish
his own development the Bishop from f8
the knight from B8 needs to come into
the game uh that what Knight on the
center of the board would be the TA for
me if I was playing black and I would
start thinking about ways of trying to
trade it off with either Knight coming
on to C6 or to D7 at some point and
Fabby goes into a think uh so he's the
one taken by surprise here yeah I feel
we need to just forget the moves for now
we just need to talk about the
psychology this is one of the most
topical openings in chess seemingly
everyone pretty much plays this opening
these days and Magnus forces Fabiana to
think this early brand new move whether
it's good or not is another question
Advantage Magnus in the Mind Games
Advantage Magnus and it feels like uh
objectively whatever it might be it's
worked for now and can nbec make his
moves work against Wesley's King Pawn
opening and he starts with
E5 no more B3 I'm disappointed I wanted
to see Wesley continue with that
strategy but here we see the scotch game
another rare guest at the top level a
scotch is uh basically a trade of Pawns
in the center this early on and not Toc
bit of hesitation there but he gave a
check with his Bishop dropped it back
giving white a free move essentially but
that free move is White having a Pawn on
C3 blocking a nice development Square
for a knight so uh I'm not sure exactly
what Wesley so had in mind in the main
lines of the scotch nck is trying to
choose a less explored territory here
smart decision from nck because those
main lines of the scotch if you look
through the top players in their history
against one another very often you'll
see half half they draw all the time in
that variation it's well studied Bishop
B4 check it looked like a mistake
because you allow white to push a pawn
the bishop has to move a second time in
a row but it takes away that Square from
the night as David was saying and that
does not allow Wesley to go forward with
his typical development so Wesley likely
will develop his dark Square Bishop to
protect the Central Square but black now
has a chance to muddy the waters because
Wesley's not in familiar territory he's
the one thinking first and David you
spoke about psychology in the Magnus
Fabby matchup and uh the opening
approach there and how that would affect
Fabby what about in this one now nbec is
trailing o to2 he's down by two points
he has to win this game on demand he has
to win the next game on demand what is
going on in his mind knowing that his
shot against perhaps the hardest player
to beat is this essentially over I'm not
sure I think psych psychology is one of
nock's strong points in general he just
seems uh unfaced unbothered undaunted I
can't even remember the the qu right now
but uh he is the Iceman nerves of Steel
NC Abdu satov and I already feel like
he's tricked Wesley in this opening
Wesley chose the scotch and black has
three or four main variations there
nybeck says no none of that for you you
cannot rely on your homework your
opening preparation I'm going to play a
rare variation and as far as I know this
night move is a bit dodgy I've played
the scotch my entire life as well with
white and this last move has a bit of
bad reputation for Wesley so it feels
like nbec has Sur his opponent and might
be able to profit we see the pawn push
it's a pawn sacrifice a pawn given up
with check this is brilliant from the
USC youngster Pawn sacrifice not my
favorite movie but a great idea in this
position because he is giving up this
Pawn on G7 with Czech mind you the king
will have to step to the side but white
isn't spending so much time with just
one piece you just develop interest supp
to get your king to safety and castle
and when we'll dive into the details
that pawn I don't think it's really
worth it for all the trouble that you
are going to face afterwards black gets
such a rapid initiative with the queen
jumping out the Knight developing and I
feel like there's going to be too much
pressure against the white king so easy
to feel that when you're playing against
a player like Wesley you're down two
games in a match how do you make a
comeback but it looks like NC already
creating a bit of chaos on the board
exactly what he needs to do with the
black pieces and if nbec is able to get
this game win I know it's really early
to talk about any score but at least
he's been able to create a chaotic
position right now asking Wesley
questions if this he gets in the bag
then we've got a proper match on our
hands anything can happen in game four
and what n derck does best is when he
has a lead on the clock he uses that as
the 17th piece our buddy James kenty
loved to say the clock is the 17th piece
and he did it against Hikaru Nakamura it
looked like Hikaru was stabilizing was
finding the way out but he didn't have
enough time and he had to play some
moves quickly when thought was required
so I think that nybeck with a about
two-minute lead coming up on the clock
with a better position more development
already I love his chances right now in
game three Wesley so has to be so
careful right now and he's also been the
victim of the death stare I keep seeing
nock's eyes just kind of stare off
imagine Superman with his laser vision
there just peering deep into the
opponent's Soul at this point and uh nck
dream start and Wesley takes the bait is
this Pawn poisoned or not Wesley's a
pawn up but yes the black king has had
to move that's irrelevant it's all about
the White Knight now stuck on the edge
of the board The Black Queen comes out
threatening Checkmate on the F2 Square
Wesley so is in huge huge trouble unless
he defends accurately and he's already
living life on the edge the Knight makes
yet another move 1 2 3 4 5 six six Night
Moves In the first nine turns for white
this is crazy look at the black pieces
pouring out this is trouble for white
this is like an actually good Stafford
Gambit so Eric Rosen yeah don't play the
Stafford Gambit but play this this is a
dream come true look at all your pieces
developed that Knight on F6 is about to
come out to G4 with more of an attack so
Wesley plays his Bishop out to E2 and
now the pawn on e4 can be captured and
once that pawn is gone it's material
equality that Rook on h8 it could slide
one square over on any turn just to put
pressure against the white kingside if
you think you're casting there to safety
not so fast so I think that nordeck he
can restore material equality and they
can continue his initiative from there
and look at that focus of nck Wesley he
continues to play fast though the last
few moves Knight H5 Knight G3 Bishop G2
Bishop B2 made really quickly is Wesley
do you think he knows what he's doing or
it's that okay I'm in trouble out of the
opening at least I need to just play
Fast to put the psychological pressure
on yeah I think Wesley's just using all
of his experience to kind of bluff his
way through here just to survive and
Wesley is one of the best players in the
world when it comes to defense when it
comes to just stabilizing positions
manageable kind of control type position
so he won't get checkmated at least not
yet but uh he is having to give back his
extra Pawn I'm just counting the pieces
I mean it's just so many active pieces
for black I think he's actually done
everything wrong on the board Wes liso
but the fact that he's actually survived
quite quickly he's only one minute down
uh despite being hit in the opening by
this surprise uh it means that he's got
good prospects if he can survive and
whether the original storm yeah I'm
looking at this position and the idea
that you mentioned right you equalize
the m you pick up that pawn on e4 but
with those trades of Knight does that
also ease the pressure of Wesley a
little bit can he go shot Castle get his
King to safety or also look at a move
like Bishop F3 as a defensive resource
the knight from B1 jumping on to D2
developing with Tempo and is this the
reason why nbec has slowed down not
immediately capturing on e4 trying to
figure out another way to keep more
tension on the board yeah he doesn't
have to take this Pawn he can instead be
down a pawn and he does just that he
brings another piece forward he did not
have to just say let let's let my
opponent castle and as you said t Bishop
to F3 I think there would have been a
second wave but why not keep the first
wave going there's no rush to capture
this pawn and if White Castles now oh
goodness the knight's coming to G4 and
you could take it once but a second
Knight replaces the first and then you
can play H3 the only way to stop
checkman this is we saw something just
like this yesterday I don't remember
which game it was David but taking on F2
Queen takes G3 to follow black is
winning material and just winning the
game Deja Vu Robert you said that
sentence basically about another game
you're right the exact same Motif um I'm
trying to recall as well which one that
was but either way it's a decisive
attack for black this is going to be
Checkmate and a material material gain
the black Rook is going to join the
party as well this one is over so do not
Castle you're only worsening your King's
prospect on the king side right now but
if you don't Castle what else I'm
already kind of seeing this idea being
powerful in a bunch of variations if for
example you try to bring your knight to
the rescue again Knight G4 collapse on
the F2 Square it's already really really
kind of critical for Wesley so one or
two moves and he it could be lights out
he could be knocked out on the spot and
the only way that you could say oh let
me take away the G4 playing H3 but then
Bishop takes F2 hits you where it hurts
you take and Knight takes E4 now two
pawns to the good I'm getting my
sacrifice piece just right back your
king is going to be checkmated I don't
actually know what Wesley should do here
I see the Eva bar still in the middle
but the player are probably looking this
like white might just already lose a
miniature and notak made a similar
mistake against Hikaru actually I
remember that first game they played
where nck allowed attack on F2 and he
couldn't safely defend it I really like
this idea by nck of going Knight E5
keeping the tension a big threat on the
board you said you need to stop that G4
Square take it under control H3 was a
suggestion is F3 also on the cards right
now to try to make sure that black other
at least doesn't get in the Knight to G4
and I see the albar luckily doesn't
react though I hit making this move
simply activating that black bishop and
making it a Monster yeah now you can
never ever Castle King side uh that
square is protected the black Rook could
add itself uh to the party the Black
Knight can come to put pressure under
the White Knight that's suddenly self-
pinned along this diagonal I mean yes
this might survive but it still looks
scary F3 never play F3 as they say it
just uh I think this would be a last
resort for Wesley so if he plays it he
won't be happy about it and it will cost
him a bunch of time uh in the meantime
and yeah I don't envy him at all it's
such a tough choice right now if he
doesn't play it it might cost him the
game I mean Knight G4 if that Knight
lands on G4 I'm not finding a way to
actually defend the F2 Pawn I would just
resign I think F3 yeah and maybe you get
away with it what is the idea though
after Rook to G8 threatening this Knight
I think you might be forced to run with
the white king and uh this is just too
big a threat the Knight is attacked due
to a pin on the H file only move here as
far as I can see King D2 Run for the
Hills hide on C2 but how tough is this
first of all to just imagine how tough
is it to come up with this creative
concept of running with the King and uh
how happy are you about it even if you
do see it a beautiful line though that
the king can actually run out of the
center towards the queen side Black's
forces are concentrated over on the king
side that's a lovely line here if Wesley
plays this he certainly deserves to win
this second set it's not going to be
easy playing F3 opening up a diagonal
for that dark squore Bishop it looks too
dangerous and I'm looking at the clock
as well the attack will rage on and nck
I said it before I'll say it again he
punishes people when they're nervous
when they're down on time and when he
has the initiative so this is the exact
type of play that nordc wanted and F3 on
the board Wesley so he's bang in form in
Toronto and will we see that King march
the white king running to D2 to C2 next
he's pretty much obliged to he's
committed to it right now black has four
attacking pieces maybe a fifth with a
black Brook joining but white king will
hide in plain sight yeah and you could
tell Wesley hated making that move he
played F3 and just shakes his head once
again head in hands and it looks like
Wesley is in big trouble and uh also not
just in the position all the and on the
clock as well he's going to be needing a
little bit of uh chilling out to do
right now so good news for him that
we've got a Loi collaboration and I'm
sure he's been listening to some of the
LOI Girl music and you can check out all
the cool tunes that you've been
listening to at the start part of the
stream at the end of the stream when you
decide to play some chess uh it's a
great playlist a great tracks to play on
on your favorite platforms YouTube
Spotify and
SoundCloud Robert do you have a favorite
Loi gold track oh putting me on the spot
uh maybe sandpaper oo yeah I've actually
heard that one and uh definitely check
out the tunes and talking of sandpaper
it looks like nbec is quickly removing
all of Wesley's defenses here Rook G8 I
love it Rook takes Knight it's a move
that David you pointed out putting more
pressure getting another piece into the
attack Robin I'm just thinking how you
know sandpaper I could listen to that
but this this uh position feels like
sand paper honestly where it's going to
be rough Wesley's going to have to run
away if if he plays King to D2 here it
just shows the type of form he's capable
of he's lost his match in this seventh
match of the round Robins to five minut
Carana he lost the yesterday to nck who
he said was playing all the best moves
and that was meant as a compliment I do
actually want to talk about just that
very briefly historically when you say
someone's playing like a machine it was
meant as a compliment now it's taken to
meet something else I know met Wesley
meant well when he said that about noer
back and King King D2 how is he playing
like this this is
incredible how does he find these
defensive resources I think he had to in
that position out of necessity otherwise
he just had to resign black was
threatening Rook takes Knight so the
idea behind this is actually for the
White Queen to protect her rook in the
corner uh on H1 and now Black's Rook
cannot take the white Knights now black
needs to find another uh way of attack
another route in but yeah the creativity
behind finding F3 first all then King D2
almost superhuman but the attack rages
on for narbeck there's a king and a
queen in line I want to get rid of the
pieces that still remain on the defile I
would play D5 throw that pawn forward
open up another file I'm still worried
about Wesley's King he'll probably move
his King on over to C2 but files
diagonals lines are all going to open up
and the queen side for white is
completely undeveloped The Rook the
Knight and the bishop on their starting
squares I just can't imagine a better
looking position for blacking at the Evo
bar is completely unimpressed it's right
there in the center not a back player
abrasive like the Sandpaper as you said
Robert but David you know you said that
it is out of necessity that you find
these resources but I I I just feel 99%
of us it would be still so hard to make
this move King D2 on the board I see
your threat Rook takes n it would at
least take minutes to find it but Wesley
played F3 you only play F3 if you have
seen the idea of marching up the board
with your king yeah exactly and this is
when the top players they're backed into
a corner uh they find the best moves if
you give them a narrow path to survival
or Narrow Path towards winning a game
99% of the time they do uh find those
critical ideas even if they look
counterintuitive he's sandpapering over
the cracks here with h this last move
but he's surviving he's still alive for
now he is uh alive and surviving a very
difficult opening and some more critical
decisions are coming up for Wesley so
and at this critical moment we've got
Danny joining us from Toronto Danny were
you having foral about this madness that
we're seeing on the board and wanted to
jump in on the
analysis yeah well I was listening to to
you guys break down this game between
Wesley so and Notre Beck abaturov and I
wanted to give a little bit of the
opening breakdown or at least give some
pause or question as to why Wesley maybe
chose the line that he did David if you
bring up the analysis board Wesley
actually chose a line that is a little
dubious to begin with when you start
with this Knight F5 move instead of
Bishop to E3 uh as someone who plays
this opening and admits that the scotch
can at times struggle I'm surprised that
Robert hasn't already made fun of me for
that um for Wesley to play this line not
that often in his career and then to go
95 Notre Beck to his credit was ready
because the main move here is G6 which
then white can transpose with this move
Bishop to E3 which is actually probably
what Wesley was hoping for and the idea
is you can't take the Knight on F5
without the bishop on C5 falling which
means that black will trade on E3 white
will recapture with the Knight
retreating and in this position white
actually has a very comfortable position
that's the line that white usually hopes
for if we're talking about a line that
can give white a draw and if you back up
a couple moves that line is normally
reached with white playing the move
Bishop to E3 instead of Knight to F5 and
this is probably what I I I guess I'm
saying now in hindsight Wesley should
have done if he didn't want to give
Notre Beck a whole bunch of fighting
chances but after night F5 shout out to
the kid who somehow guessed the uh the
opening maybe that that Wesley might
play he was ready to play the D6 line
which again isn't the most popular but
actually is the engine's favorite line
these days and this variation we're now
seeing play out on the board is actually
perfect for black to get exactly what
you need in a must-win situation right
Notre backck has to win this game or
he's or it's uh already moving on to the
next round of tiebreakers so anyway just
interesting anecdotes I wanted to give
because rarely is there an opening on
the board I guess that I have some
knowledge or insight about uh
self-deprecating International Master
over here and just wanted to just wanted
to say that and again I'm a little
puzzled as to why Wesley chose this line
especially if he wasn't prepared in it I
guess is my my point yeah it was good to
mention actually Danny that I remember
you being here in Oslo with us a few
months ago and this Scotch came onto the
board so uh yeah we got the expert with
us just at the right time thank
you Danny coming in with the updates
there and uh we really needed that
because this opening I think for many of
us is such a new Fresh position that we
have in front of us it really breaks
down what happened in those first couple
of moves Wesley meanwhile has managed to
sidestep with the king so opening up
that Bishop loating a square for his own
Knight to jump into but he's delaying
development further he pushes the pawn
on B4 hitting that Bishop it really
looks like only nck is playing like he's
been uh taught to play chess because
white is not developing any of his
pieces finally we see the dark Bishop go
out and as soon as he gets that Bishop
out you see the eval bar plummet it's
amazing position for black we knew that
but there must be something concrete
here I think it's uh what you were
alluding to earlier Robert just blow
open the center Pawn to D5 explode the
center White's King still a Target
White's still behind in development but
uh we'll check back in as Abdu satov
tries to build uh that second wave of
the attack yeah he's managed to get all
his pieces out but let's not forget that
Abdu satov has sacrificed upon Pawn so
it is all about getting to White King
opening up those files he can't play
slow here give white a couple of moves
give him time gave Wesley time to take
out the Knight develop it to D2 develop
it to B3 and white will be up upon so
Wesley momentum is key right now and he
needs to make those decisions fast
forcing Wesley to take difficult
decisions with less time on the clock
but the move seems very straightforward
for not pushing your Pawn in the center
your Rook typically wins a St down with
the Enemy Queen and trying to open up
more files and lines towards the white
king the one bit of good news for Wesley
is that the Rook on d8 is not protected
for the moment but that doesn't matter
on N debeck he holds nothing back he
strikes with D5 he might strike and win
game three and then suddenly this set
isn't over now we've got a match on our
hands if nbec Abdus satro gets the job
done in this one and so far with the
black pieces he's done everything right
we will check in with this as Wesley has
a think meanwhile there's a very
different Dynamic on our other
semi-finals matchup we see an end game
where white has a bishop there Black's
Pawn structure a little bit loose we see
three Pawn Islands for black two for
white in general having the bishop a in
an open position you feel it's better
but to me the lack of development in
white pieces would compensate for that
I'm just hating that pin on that Knight
on F6 yeah black needs to break the pin
that's the most urgent factor in this
position look at Fabiano his body
language right now it looks urgent in
itself and it looks like he knows this a
critical moment he needs to get rid of
White's Dart squared Bishop you need to
kick it away simply Black's Knight on E6
can cannot take it there's a pin on the
E file there's a pin on the diagonal and
therefore move one of the Rooks across
or use a pawn use the black H6 Pawn to
kick away White's piece and if we do see
a bishop for Knight trade if white
starts squ Bishop has to trade off on F6
Fabby will breathe a sigh of relief he
needs to act quickly though I'm looking
at the clock I'm looking at the position
it's definitely momentum white right now
it is and I'm with you that you have to
get rid of the Dark Sword bishop and
even after that still better for white
because the healthier Pawn structure
that Tanya mentions the opposite color
Bishops when there no other pieces
remaining offense going to be a draw
even if one side has an extra Pawn but
with Rooks and a knight on the board as
well we could see an attack especially
if that black king is drawn out to the
F6 Square so Advantage Magnus on the
clock Advantage Magnus on the
board it's going to be an endgame grind
will Magnus Magnus his way through this
one even if the bishop a are gone as uh
Robert you're pointing out and David you
as well that white will be able to get
that second Rook into the attack from
the f file really quickly once black
king is pulled forward after the trade
so this end game it might look level for
now the evalar says its level but it
does have more poison than what meets
the eye it does certainly Fabiano did
not make the decision we were talking
about now on the left Board of our
screens he moves the black Rook across
instead but this only encourages Whit
King to park itself on a much safer
square and I'm assuming that Magnus
Carlson on that left board will Shuffle
the king closer to the corner White's
King will step to B1 and then it's the
quick comparison White's King safer than
Black's King White's pieces more active
than Black's pieces Advantage Magnus
Carlson and uh in the meant time on the
left Board of our screens Abdu sattorov
throws another porn into the mix all of
Black's pieces at work in that board
White's King White's pieces they look
like easy targets it's still Wesley so
in big deep trouble and Wesley was able
to win not's Queen me sacrificed his own
Queen nck took Wesley's Queen in an
earlier game here it looks like
something similar could happen that if
on the right hand side of our screen
Wesley takes this Pawn on C5 which he
just does look at n UBC he's not taking
that pawn back he's taking the other
Pawn the center but this isn't an
imitation of game two unlike that one
Wesley's King is in trouble so it's a
similar peace Dynamic but it's not
peaceful because White's King is unsafe
yeah really interesting that queen
versus rook and a minor piece we see a
similar thing and now nbec has made a
move which the bar disapproves it's the
most natural looking move to me does
this give Wesley the opportunity to
capture that A7 Pawn which you can
easily forget about I think he's relying
on a trick here Abdu satov but he's
missed a trick of his own if Pawn takes
Pawn if White's Pawn captures on A7 on
that right board Black's Queen can slide
the whole way across the board to A4 and
deliver a check Black's Queen will check
the white king and actually save the day
the a file is covered but white can
prevent that by first playing Rook to D4
Rook White's Rook sliding up to the
center here and now in this position the
fact that Wesley has paused means he's
likely to see this and once the black
queen is kicked away from the fourth
rank then Pawn takes Pawn white is about
to make a new Queen Abdu satov has lost
control this is a critical moment if
Wesley so finds Rook to D4 blocking out
shutting out that Queen on the Queen's
King side and he does find it Wesley so
is missing nothing today great find from
Wesley and a horrible oversight from
Notre it happens to all of us but look
at how much time Notre has left on his
clock I've talked about how he punishes
his opponent by keeping control on the
clock he played too quickly there and
now Wesley has a fighting chance and
maybe not just a chance he might be
better I actually might prefer the white
side if I can take that pawn on A7 the
next turn that's an annoying pass Pawn
that blacks have to deal with and
Black's King itself is not safe and
black will have to move up with the King
to stop that pawn from promoting to A8
once the queen moves back white captures
the A7 more Pawn black will have to stop
it from promoting to a queen which will
give Wesley time to capture the F3 Pawn
yeah Abdus satov this is his bigger
strength but maybe also once more
weakness in his game he relies on
calculation he backs everything up
concretely he always wants to play the
most active ambitious moves he didn't
need to though he'd already pocketed
Wesley's Queen he could have just simply
captured that white Pawn off the board
the white Pawn that now sits on B6
that's about to go closer to promotion
he could have taken it two moves ago we
would be arguing about the same position
but with black in full control instead
we're talking about Wesley about to make
a new Queen about to promote just as he
did in the previous game and a material
breakdown white has a rook white has a
bishop and White's about to have the
strongest Pawn on the board yes black
has a queen but that's not the most
important factor anymore Abdu satov
inside he's going to be kicking himself
and Black's King will not be safer than
whites in the right hand side of the
board Wesley's King has been running now
it's hidden it has some shelter the
black king will not receive so many
pieces in front of it because you've
already traded off many and on the left
hand side of our screen we just saw a
trade where Fabiano he gives up his
Bishop for a knight so it's an advantage
for Magnus healthier Pawn structure on
the left hand side of our screens here
where black has those three Pawn Islands
isolated pawns and the f&h files and the
light score Bishop that can start poking
at him I've seen Magnus win countless
positions with small strategic Advantage
better Pawn structure better minor piece
Magnus in control it's what we would
call a two result game really flashy
move here Magnus on the left board
moving his Rook up swinging it across
the Rook is Untouchable because Black's
Knight in the center is pinned Magnus
he's having all the fun if Fabby defends
well it's going to be a draw but almost
zero chance of black winning that one
and with that a rook lift what Magnus
wants to do is try and provoke more
weaknesses on the queen Side by sliding
it all the way across Fabby preempts it
makes the move B6 meanwhile nck still in
the think it's clear that Rook D4 was
missed by him yeah not a doubt abdor
took a long think there the black queen
has moved away the only black queen
remaining on either board right now and
Wesley is is about to establish a
monster porn look at that white a porn
now the new a porn about to promote
about to land a touchdown black king has
to move but the problem is no matter
where the black king moves on the right
hand side board that the king is walking
into a dark Square diagonal that the
bishop on B2 it's been a bad piece all
game but it is going to have its fun
because if you go to G7 we have a full
diagonal from that Bishop on B2 all the
way to a King on G7 but no he gives a
check and the evaluation bar is going up
up and away why can't white just move
the bishop and block that check oh maybe
the answer is you can move the bishop
even if you sidestep the king I'm not
sure what Abdu sator of is aiming for
with this check Wesley so doesn't have
too much time under two minutes but he
has for the first time in this game a
superior
position I mean I'm just thinking about
what you said Abdu satra what does he
have in mind if the bishop does move
forward he's threatening to Queen on the
next move he's attacking Black's Queen
on the other side of the board the only
trick you can set up is of discover
checks by grabbing that Bishop with your
own Knight and relying on the tactics
that when white promotes and I think
we're going to see this play out Knight
takes Bishop white promotes the queen
move up with your king attack the White
Queen and you're threatening discover
checks Wow abor might have tricked
Wesley so lured him in with the bait
white has made a new Queen so I said
there was only one Queen remaining on
either board suddenly white has a queen
and that right board but the queen is
attacked in the corner on A8 by Black's
rook and the threat of uh this discovery
against White's Kings could be terminal
Wesley's new Queen drops back walking
into the firing line here something is
lining up look at that white king it's
about to be checked left right and
center but Wesley is he surviving big
question Wesley on the right hand side
is up a rook at the moment but that
Knight can actually deliver a check on
F2 and then it the queen hits the king
the Knight hits The Rook on H1 so I'm
just trying to keep count of all the
pieces on the right hand side and quick
note on the left hand side as Magnus
just made his move Fabiano is defending
this perfectly every square that Magnus
puts pressure on Fabiano has it covered
the H5 Pawn is defended the E6 Knight is
defended so Fabiano is doing everything
correctly on the left hand side and he
still has a minute on his clock but
Magnus is going to continue try to
squeeze water out of stone there with
the bishop versus knight complex pawns
on both sides of the board he's going to
play this on Fabby down to a minute he
needs to keep those defenses up can nbec
find the big check here and he de to go
with Knight F2 uh attacking that Rook
first question where are you moving with
your king you got to slide to the right
or you got to slide back and he slides
back to C1 a safe square and White's
Rook disappears in the corner I've got
to say all the drama is happening on the
board between Wes liso and Abdu sator
it's one of the craziest games you'll
ever see new pawns promoting halfway
through a game Rooks disappearing in the
corner we do a material count we see
suddenly it is almost level white is up
a porn after all of that mess but the
attack continu news against the white
king potentially and the black king is
really not that safe either because if
you could imagine the C3 Pawn on the
right hand side of your screen if that
was thrown off the board that Bishop on
B2 it's just lurking back there and
there could be threats but I think that
notbe can just take this Knight on G3
the pawn will recapture the queen can
take that pawn it's becoming messy the
material will be even but I like n
Beck's clock the most who no that was a
that was a dgt error there's no way
Wesley would push a pawn instead of
recapturing that sometimes happens look
that b alive I love that last move by
Wesley he pushes the SE pawn it doesn't
aim at queening or moving forward but
it's all to activate that Bishop on B2
which to me is a very scary piece I
don't care what the evalar says that
Bishop on B2 eyeing that black king on
G7 I'd be worried in this position yeah
Wesley forgot to play B3 on move one
fing King his Dart Square Bishop but
finally now on move 28 he's activated
that Beast that monster that Archer uh
that sniper from afar that white Dart
Square Bishop is the most valuable piece
right now but it's all about the checks
it's all about the mutual attacks and
Black's King steps forward hiding out in
the open on a light square and Wesley
drops back with his Rook whose King is
weaker it's so difficult to tell the
players are now down under the
two-minute mark this one is chaos it's
going in any direction what a move from
Noir abatar King up to G6 I was not at
all looking at that I think he can just
steal this Pawn on F3 and then he can
always block a check on the G5 with his
Knight so I believe that notbe can he
can take the pawn F3 get a bit closer to
the white king and what a brave decision
by him he gives a check instead did we
see him move that was Magnus Carlson I
think he's still thinking about it I was
thinking give a check and get the Queens
off the board your king is on G6 if NC
Abdu satov he can grab a pawn he can
give a check he chooses a third option
he doesn't care his king is up in the
open he's going for the C Pawn Wesley
rightly sidesteps any checks on the sea
line moves away and nck goes Pawn
hunting no Queen trades he's a porn up
nck here adds black both games are
equally weak right now but black also
has two pass pawns on that board Abdus
satoro I think he's a big favorite the
black H Pawn will just start running
meanwhile the Magnus Carson versus
Fabiano Carana board still Level still
Magnus trying to probe away for
weaknesses still looking to dominate the
Black Knight with the white Bishop but
wow W so let's focus on this one on the
right because that's where the money
matches oh my goodness Queen G7 check is
a thre that Knight cannot capture the
queen that's why Wesley slid his King to
the corner so the black queen can't
deliver a useful check and I think that
for n he's to bring his Rook back he
does just that that H Pawn is really
dangerous it was a one check threat that
has been stopped n's about to run that
pawn up the board and this is White's
moment to try to perhaps get more pieces
into the attack that Knight on A3 only
if it lands on the king side it will
give Wesley the chances that he needs
and he starts with his journey Knight B5
heading to the center of the board with
Knight D4 coming in wow the computer the
evaluation barom might say that black is
better Abdu sator of has the advantage
but in Practical terms the white king
suddenly safe in the corner and Wesley I
think he's got great chances of turning
around both players around the 42 Mark
and uh now big threat against White's
Rook he gives a check first Wesley so
the bishop can block it Brave check
there forcing the White Queen into the
corner and meanwhile On The Other Board
the evaluation bar shoots up Magnus
Carlson is he winning can Magnus trade
off the Rooks he's won a pawn Magnus
Carson karan's defenses are cracking
yeah the Rooks are gone and that's an
extra pawn it can run up the board so
while all attention was on Nordy Beck's
board suddenly Magnus Carlson steals a
pawn and I think he's going to win game
three just do not play Magnus Carlson in
end games it is bad news and he does it
he creates his magic but let's focus on
the right side of the board right now
Rook to E8 Queen E4 putting that Queen
back on H1 by Wesley so to me that was a
really surprising call well Danny knows
all about that playing the scotch and
then you're getting your queen stuck on
H1 so Danny there's your shout out but
right now Nord dearbeck deserves a huge
shout out the way he's been playing and
Wesley's down under 10 seconds seconds
absolute chaos is the black king going
to March up further on the board but you
have to stay connected to that H5 Pawn
what is notc thinking about is he going
to capture the bishop on B2 wow he does
it and Checkmate within two moves is
threatened Abdu satov going for the
white king now Wesley keeping things
alive with a nasty move what a sick move
from Wesley on the right hand side that
Rook looks like it's free but if you
take that Rook Knight back to H4 with
check we're seeing a repetition I don't
think n has better Wesley so what a find
Rook to G2 that has to be the move of
the day but right now 3 seconds and he
captures the Knight nck is going for it
he doesn't repeat because that's not an
option on the table wow nck a draw and a
loss is the same thing so he keeps the
game alive he doesn't repeat but now
it's a material imbalance White has a
rook meanwhile okay Magnus does take the
win in his Game Pass Pawn running
through but Wesley has a rook for
Black's Knight and two pawns that one
anything could still happen our
remaining game and look at that not
throws his Pawn even further please take
my Pawn your Rook is hanging on Jordan
Wes it down under 5 seconds he slides
his Rook to help defend his Queen but
those pawns are looking awfully scary o
and another check the white king
advancing I've never seen two kings do
more exercise more work than they have
in this game still black on the attack
and his King advances as well and the
pawns keep rolling down the board n back
with the determination is going for it
he does give a check is he going to pick
up the C4 Pawn as well well it stays
defended with the King moving back nbec
has to find a way to start pushing those
pawns look how visibly nervous both
players are on the camera both shaking
back and forth Wesley fiddling with
pieces Queen's off the board it's a race
it's a pawn race those black pawns are
really quick but look how quickly Wes is
going after the B7 Pawn if he can grab
that he's a passer of his own and nck
said he believes Wesley shaky in time
trouble and there it goes and blunder
white king going back White's Rook
taking a pawn but Black's pawns are too
strong black can push the E Pawn perhaps
right now black can give a check with
the Knight first he's running through
he's promoting he's going to make a new
Queen not a back on the brink of victory
in this one but he's got only 5 Seconds
to make it happen and now he can promote
can he go E1 Pi up The Rook he he can
and but he's worried the the white Pawn
will also go and promote so keeps the
Knight on E5 to cover that C6 Square I
think that was a great Try by nordbeck
here and Wesley was stuck Wesley had no
good moves the white Pawn kept under
lock and key and oh some drama there
touching a PA abaturov but he drops his
KN back is he going to be able to break
through the white Rook white Rook is
holding two pawns simultaneously and N
making moves with just a second on the
clock gains some time a gives a check
now but if he goes back that could be a
third time repetition but if he goes
Knight F3 Knight G1 he gets to Queen
with check so the white Pawn STS forward
twice but black Queen's first with check
and here it comes he's found it he's
found the winning idea knows it yeah
frustration from Wesley so and
resignation from Wesley so what a
fantastic game I've never seen anything
like that n be up doat scores a win with
the black pieces and he can't believe it
we can't believe it what a
game what a game the players discussing
this is nice to
see there really are no words but
somehow these players are talking about
the game yeah I think they're analyzing
so many critical
moments and we can see them pointing at
the board and they have got a round to
play I think they're discussing the end
game the final stages could white have
saved the
game and it looks like NC found some way
to actually convince Wesley of his
Advantage there and they've got a fourth
game coming up and we have got a match
on our hands oh my goodness no dearbeck
Abdus he brought the heat Wesley was so
close to surviving found a brilliant
tactic by stepping his Rook up but just
what a game from no dear up du satar up
unreal The Chosen One Strikes Back
taking the match to the fourth game and
na has to do it again to go into
Armageddon meanwhile Magnus Carlson as
well bounces straight back after that
lost to Fabiano Carana in classic Magnus
style yeah Magnus grinding away we
didn't pay that game as much love as we
would like to have done but Magnus
essentially doing Magnus things it was
equal for most of it but in the end just
broke down eroded uh karan's defenses
yeah it was all lies on nbec Abdus satov
it just
unbelievable stuff unbelievable tactics
a complete roller coaster David yeah a
roller coaster one of the most uh just
up and down crazy most fun Wild Games
you'll ever see in chess and it was
those two fantastic Warriors Wesley so
nck Abdu satoro I Want To Praise Black's
decision just in the next couple of
moves here nck in a must-win situation
decided not to retreat and take this
white knight maybe the most uh kind of
rational decision right now instead he
went for chaos Rook takes Bishop
threatening to take this Pawn followed
by a swift Checkmate on the white king
and Wesley found a crazy defensive move
deciding to block on the second rank
control the black queen because this
Rook is poisoned if you ever take it you
walk into a nasty shock the night Fork
on the king and queen nck here he took a
pawn with check he gave another check
with the black rook and ultimately he
decided okay I have to gamble after
another check he took the White Knight
we saw a crazy material imbalance and
later down the line nobec was rewarded
for his courage in playing on the Black
Knight and pawns combined turned out to
be superior to White's Rook just
unbelievable we've been talking about
ncks Steely stairs but that looked like
nerves of steals to allow white to keep
that Knight and queen with the King out
in the open I'm just thinking about the
chest that we witnessed on that game but
meanwhile Magnus just outclassing Fabby
in that end game yeah there were too
many weakness unfortunately for fabibi
on a Carana he had split pawns his
opponent had a bishop staring in both
directions and Fabby was doing so well
covering all of his bases but without
time on the clock it's hard to cover the
left and right hand side of your boards
and Magnus he was relentless he was able
to First grab a pawn then a second and
then the
game and he did just that and with that
he levels the score which means Fabby
has to now do it all over again to take
it to set three Fabby needs to win the
final rapid game he does it's going to
be difficult to come back from that but
if we just dive into the specifics of
that game that we just saw Magnus
Carlson he did his vintage stuff there's
a Pawn on B5 that's under attack there's
a Pawn on H5 that's under attack the
Knight can't go in both directions it's
not a bishop if that Knight were a
bishop then it could actually defend
both of the pawns unfortunately the
Knight has to choose where to defend if
it defends the queen side then The Rook
slides right back over across the board
to H4 it picks up the H5 Pawn that's
what happened and Magnus first won the
H5 pawn and unfortunately for fabbi he
was not able to recover this is beyond
hope at this stage classic Magnus
Carlson Going Back to Basics this is how
he kind of rose up uh within the chest
scene originally just grinding down his
opponents tiring them out in almost
level positions and unfortunately for
Fabiano there's not much you can do
against the best player of all time in
these types of positions yeah sometimes
I look at Magnus and just wonder how
does he play chess so well in these end
games that many of us would just agree
to a draw or bail out of he really gets
the job done just literally squeezes
water out of stone I don't know how the
guy does it but he does it time and time
again and we've got a big four game
coming up and both Fabiano Carana and
nbec Abdu satov have to win on demand to
take it into the Armageddon and there
there's big chest coming up and there
are big things coming up for our
subscribers nonsubscribers subscribe
what are you waiting
[Music]
for I'm here with well two of my
favorite people in the whole world this
is Baby Max attending his first ever
chess tournament and this is my C known
as fun Master Mike who actually taught
me a little bit of Chess we met nine
years ago at the sinkfield cup my first
ever chess tournament it's so good to
see you again Mike you too I know I had
to do some handholding at that
tournament but I think you've gone on to
be the real Pro so now you're kind of
showing me around and thank you for
putting me in company with your son I
don't think I'm quite equal to him but
uh I'm glad to see the Next Generation
yeah look at that he's very interested
in in looking at you as well oh yeah
that's a microphone Max and well so
going back memory line uh sinkfield Cup
2014 it was such a cool experience uh
obviously Fabiano Carana went seven in a
row that's very memorable but for me
also you gave me my first chess site you
taught me so much chess that was an
amazing experience for me Mike uh yeah
that's back when having Magnus on my
home soil in America was like a huge
thing um I have to also say I made one
of my biggest blunders of my
professional career at that tournament
really yeah Fabiano had won seven games
in a row and was about to be white
against Magnus in game eight and while
interviewing Magnus in my brain I wanted
to ask Magnus if he felt like maybe an
underdog he was playing a guy who was 7
and0 but I think I accidentally called
Magnus an underdog that did not go well
we've patched up our relationship we all
make
mistakes yeah I also did my first
interviews with with Magnus back then he
didn't like uh Fabby winning seven in a
row there are you peeking at the camera
yes and well now Mike you're known as
fun Master Mike it's all about teaching
kids chess for you right now yeah I've
kind of moved on from the chess
journalism world and mostly retired that
except for a couple of gigs uh I'm now
mostly the the face and the content
creator and the bis Dev guy for chess
kid in fact I see a potential marketing
opportunity here can we get Max his own
little peska that's for you Baby Max oh
no that's not squeezable this is much
more fun do you have grasping yet now I
know you're teething I have no frozen
waffles but I do have this yeah oh it's
Uncle Fun Uncle Fun Master oh look at
that and I can also kind he's kind of a
little bit more interested in the
microphone maybe he's going to walk in
my yeah exactly we go hold no no no Max
you're going to be a chess player don't
take mom's job she's very good at it but
that's very kind Mike thank you we going
to have a peska to be biting on and Mike
you have to tell us a little bit about
what's happening with chess kids uh
these days yeah so we've got a big
Festival coming up February 16th to the
19th 2024 Charlotte North Carolina our
first I got to talk to that our first
effort in real life tournament we're
going to have KY we're going to have
Gotham chess we're going to have Danny
me Jen shahadi da nitki if I forgot
anybody because we've invited so many
people so it's going to be a chess event
unlike any other there's going to be a
main competition we're going to have Jen
Shahi hula hooping we're gonna have
Danny wrench doing a puzzle B against
Jen shahadi kids are literally going to
be able to throw a pie in my face it is
going to be fun Festival family
entertainment how can we get tickets for
this awesome event actually you can just
go on to chesskid.com and there's all
kinds of articles about how you sign up
for it also just go search for chess kid
national festival we've done our job on
the Googles and you're going to find us
uh tickets are limited uh but it's going
to be uh I hopefully a groundbreaking
historic event wow sounds amazing Max
are you
going maybe a little too soon next year
we will be there definitely Mike thank
you so much and everyone go check out
the the chess kid Festival it doesn't
look like much but neither would the
Sicilian Defense to the untrained eye
this is a performance enhancer you don't
see it how about now manage your air
quality sharpen your performance change
the game with air things a new opening
for your wall is here capture new major
pieces on unique metal posters from
displate now with the official
collection from chess.com Mount them in
seconds with a toolfree magnet kit and
swap them whenever you like make your
move get an exclusive discount on all
metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
and we are celebrating the holiday
season it's time to get smart and you
get a very very cool 20% off until
December 31st for the chess kid gold
uh go to the website go.es
kit.com ck20 it's all up in front of you
use the code use the command ck20 in
chat for all the details and you get a
20% off and that's not all we're
celebrating we're also helping you
decorate your walls with these very very
fun posters that we've got and there are
so many of them on display.com chess you
get a 33% off with the code chess and
you got three in the studio which ones
uh which one's your favorite Robert you
know I I want to get a Coe display is
there a calculation over everything
display with James KY just flexing out
there I would get that in heartbeat
right now it's the Champions chest or
Finals over everything is we got a big
game four coming up David I also know
there's a grind like a grandm displate
there is go out get it everyone you get
my face on your walls what more could
you want uh I must admit as well I
haven't yet shopped for my friends or my
family for Christmas so I know what I'm
taking home later after the show
oh yeah well you can get yours on
display.com so check it out and right
now we're going to check in with Magnus
Carlson who's taken the lead in his set
two against
Fabby Magnus Carlson is getting very
close to the final now and minus did you
feel confident throughout this
game not really uh I felt good about the
opening it felt that I had a slight but
St stable Advantage but I think he
managed to activate his pieces and then
for a moment uh for a while I was just
moving around but I was hoping that um
his expansion on the queen side would
only lead to weaknesses for for him so I
was sort of trying to provoke that a
little bit at some point and then yeah
eventually um eventually I managed to um
to win one of his pawns um even after
that it was not easy at all um but um
yeah managed to pull through how are you
feeling about the way you're playing
today actually not too bad um yeah even
the even the last game where I was
completely outplayed I didn't I didn't
feel that bad in general I just he just
played well I think and this game yeah
was nothing special but I think it was
okay and a game for now to secure your
spot in the final so what can we expect
from that one well it's an armor get in
game where I have 15 minutes and incr so
that's um that's something um good you
expect this to go to armaga no I'm
saying that this is an Armageddon game
where I have 15 minutes cuz I just need
a draw but um you know we'll we'll see I
haven't managed to be so solid so far so
I'm sure it won't be easy good luck in
the next one armag thank you thank you
Magnus that's uh back to you guys thanks
Ka it won't be easy but that end game
Magnus did make that look easy and he
takes the lead and his match which means
that Fabby with the the black pieces
like an armagen which why do has to win
on demand uh as Magnus said he gets
white he needs to just he needs just a
draw it's all jumbled up right now but
for Fabby and nbec nothing's jumbled up
only one score suffices and that's a win
they have to win nck did just do that
and it's tougher for Fabiano because
nbe's feeling it he just played a great
game but for Fabby you feel like you
just collapsed you were holding on for
dear life for so long but when you're
playing Magnus Carlson so long isn't
good enough it has to be forever yeah
it's different mindsets for the two
players now in must-win situations Abdu
satov he's on the back of that great
great Victory he knows he has another
life he won the first match yesterday
even if he loses this next one who cares
more chess today but for Fabiano this
could be the last game of his tournament
it's all or nothing he has to burn his
Bridges he has to go all in against
Magnus F Faby starts with white and that
gives him some hope to try to get those
positions out of the opening what are
you expecting what kind of an approach
is he going to go solid wait for Magnus
to make those decisions or will he go
all out from the start whatever he did
in game two do that again because he had
a winning position against Magnus
Carlson he couldn't convert and I think
that's been the theme of his match
yesterday set one and today inste two
he's had winning positions he's
outplayed Magnus but Magnus will not
back down he will fight on forever and
he will not lose unless you punish him
and beat him and Donnie there with the
Wesley and a little mascot uh Wesley he
lost game three he needs a draw to take
the match for not back with what he
starts he's got so many positives from
the way he just took down Wesley so in
that last game not back if he wins it
goes into the Armageddon in just a few
moments we will have the first move it's
really cool to see the players in such a
good move right before the start of a
critical game yeah maybe trying to get
some inspiration from mittens there
Wesley so uh from the mittens uh kind of
toy but a mittens plushy I think it was
a mittens plushy I was going to say
plushy but I've never literally never
said that word before in my life so I
didn't want the first time s natural
thank you
Robert and you can get your mittens
flushy but for now let's get into the
chess as we've got one D4 on the board
one D4 on the board and will we see a
repeat of a game from earlier today
wesle so mixes it up he pushes a pawn to
A6 earlier two games ago we saw him put
a Pawn on E6 and despite winning that
battle that game uh Wesley so is the
first to surprise his opponent white
takes some space and if I'm not mistaken
this is called like the chameleon
variation because you're not exactly
making it known what your plans are
gakamsky has played this from the black
side for many many years with great
success it's a situation where white
expands on the queen side you see those
Pawn on C5 carved out some good dark
squares on that side of the board but
black will eventually try to strike back
either in the center with an E5 push you
want to break a pawn chain you don't
want to allow someone to connect four
without fighting back so I think that
Wesley can strike with B6 or with E5
depending on the moment he understands
the nature of these positions yeah and
things are getting hot out there in
Toronto especially hot right now for
Abdu satov and kowana and uh is it
getting warmer I see two red rings there
on the air things devices the air
quality uh getting uh really dramatic
for the players meanwhile on the board
Wesley he's well prepared he's fast he's
Furious he's uh probably Furious about
that loss last game that defeat and he's
now hunting down White's Dart squared
Bishop the bishop on F4 will be traded
off within the next few moves and to me
it looks like opening success Wesley
so uh for Wesley he does get that Bishop
early on if white was to move it to that
square one step towards the right will
we see a kingside expansion by Wesley in
that case putting that Rook Pawn 86 G5
in early on we definitely will because
in a closed position it's not the worst
thing in the world to advance pawns
where your king may eventually end up
the King still is in the center thus far
so it's not like you are forced to
Castle to the king side but for nura KES
doesn't mind if that Knight captures his
Bishop because white will have a true
clamp in the center one of the pawn
breaks I mentioned was E7 E5 if there's
a pawn F4 and D4 good luck to you you're
not breaking through there it's going to
be a strategic battle in the opening in
this one while nbec thinks about what to
do with that Bishop situation let's
check in with our final fourth game
between the world number one and the
world number two Fabiano Karana needs to
strike in this game otherwise it will be
he will be knocked out of the Champions
chest off final and we see a repeat of
what we saw between these two earlier
yeah going back to his Italian Roots
Fabiano kowana he's playing the Italian
game and uh we saw this position as uh
Robert mentioned he's pretty much
sticking to what was almost a winning
recipe on the Brink a victory in the
second game of of today and again
pushing his Pawn forward gaining space
on the queen side it's onus on Magnus
pressure on Magnus to switch things up
uh because it went wrong for black very
very quickly and here we see Magnus
still sticking to this tried and trusted
uh kind of idea of trading off Bishops I
really fear for Magnus Carlson unless
he's got something up his sleeve and
this is the moment that Fabby stopped
and he went shot Castle is he going to
switch it up is this when we get a new
move and we're talking about their game
two action we had this identical
position I think fabby's going to play a
new move now well I'm bit a bit
surprised that he goes down the same
exact path and now is the person who's
sitting and thinking because uh
Christian Trilla his good friend maybe
he looked at this and gave him a little
bit of advice but Fabby he's going down
the same path and yet he's not the one
who seemingly prepared so either he's
just trying to recall something or he's
just going to change it up on the Fly
there isn't much time between games to
be fair to the players but Fabby does
not Castle he plays that pawn push to C3
and creating a threat as well on the
board the Queen from D1 if it arrives on
B3 you will put pressure not on one Pawn
on B7 but two pawns the one that has
just been doubled up as well on the
center and Magnus literally doesn't care
he plays B5 anyway an idea we debated in
detail earlier today on pass on or no on
passon um it does look like it's forced
in some positions but here white can
very much maintain the tension if if he
desires but why not just Queen B3 I'm
attacking B5 I'm attacking E6 because
the B5 Pawn mag is saying is a bit
Untouchable because even when you
capture let's say the White Queen grabs
that pawn on B5 the black Rook will
slide one file over hit the queen and
the loose B2 Pawn behind it so this Pawn
can be won by white black will have to
defend the E6 Pawn but in doing so sets
up a rook B8 so the pawn on B5 is
actually protected just tactically
rather than directly and we were
surprised with this move B5 which
happened in game two between these two
not in this exact same position but a
similar one it looks like this is some
kind of a preparation by Magnus that
he's just decided to go into this
opening with this thematic idea of B5
and he's sticking to it what must have
happened is that in the break uh the
players they don't have too long they
have a few minutes here and there Magnus
got on the phone he called up his uh
good friend his second Peter H neelson
what should I do and Peter's saying do
the same thing yes you had a bad
position later but you're uh mistakes
weren't to do with the opening and just
stay loyal stick to what you know don't
burn too much time on the clock and here
we do see the switch up this exact
variation you mentioned with quein to B3
probably in that phone call Magnus
discussed it with a second and uh it's
Fabiano deciding now whether to go and
grab the pawn as uh Robert mentioned
Queen takes B5 White's Queen going up
taking the B5 Pawn would walk into a
skewer on the B file uh blacks Rooks
would switch across switch Focus kick
the White Queen away and who knows who
that profits Fab has to work that out I
think it's a little too direct and I
don't love what we're seeing here from
Fabiano he's going down the same exact
line at the first time you can be
surprised by this B5 now that it's
happened before I'm going to expect it
every time it's available black can play
B5 and what it really was doing is then
Knight on B1 it wants to Dart out to D2
with then up to C4 and saying you're not
even going to get there so Faby brings
this queen out attacks a pawn doesn't
takes it doesn't take excuse me in said
castles is King I feel like Magnus can
simply defend the pawn and he's doing
just a okay
okay and uh we see a decision there with
the kingside castle Magnus on the T we
are going to go to our crew in Toronto
Levy is joining us for more insights
Levy we got a very similar opening as
the one we saw between these two players
in game two Fabby a must-win situation
what do you think about what we're
seeing being played out will Fabby be
able to create his chances in this
one well it's not a matter of will he be
able to I doesn't really have a choice
it's just is he going to go for a long
positional out grind type of game or is
he going to get frustrated at some point
and lash out but the truth is in these
E4 E5 these Ru lashing out could just be
punished right I mean we're looking at
the game right now Magnus applying some
pressure with his Knight there on the
king side I don't know I I I'm no expert
in E4 E5 positions but if you tell me
you have to win this with white it is
looks like a bit of a struggle I don't
know what are we thinking uh we thinking
he's going to try to push D4 is he going
to try to reposition his Queen off of B3
it's nice where it is it's pressuring E6
but it's tough to add pressure I do
believe he's he's brought his Rook so is
the idea Knight F1 guys and then reroute
the Knight to the
center yeah and Levy before we Deep dive
I want to ask you because we were
discussing in the studio what the
players are getting up to between rounds
how are they preparing did you manage uh
do you have any update on that on that
for us uh have you seen the players
between rounds between
games
yeah I've definitely seen them uh
there's only one way in and out which I
suppose is a bit of a fire hazard but we
do see all the players that we we see
them getting fair play scans uh Nock and
Wesley are surprisingly chatty with each
other you know considering they're
playing for something like $50,000
either way that could go if one of them
makes it to the finals or not uh but
Fabiano just sort of comes out he's
always very chill it's actually quite
difficult to read if Fabby won or lost
you only kind of get a sense once he
starts analyzing he's sometimes
discussing games with with Maxim who is
here mvl uh and Magnus just sort of
maybe goes off gets refreshes and come
back and uh comes back but uh I mean
there's a lot on the line here and so
they have to gather themselves very
quickly whether they win or lose but now
we see Magnus is actually playing G5 on
the left side of the screen there so
pause that conversation and how do we
feel about this actually taking the
fight to Fabiano rather than sitting and
waiting I must admit Levy I quite like
it for black the uh Center for now is
not quite open so why not play on the
side you're stronger black has a KN on
H5 semiopen f file um and I will admit
I'll make a confession of my own Levy I
spent a bunch of time this morning
watching one of your YouTube videos
about meeting Magnus in person in the
flesh uh can you tell us about how that
experience was for
you yeah well I haven't had a chance to
uh actually meet uh David Howell In the
Flesh which I mean I mean once I do that
that I might just completely melt so we
got to we got to set that up at some
point David no it was super cool um and
I and I tweeted about it earlier today
or posted on X or however we call that
nowadays um it's uh it's Sublime for me
because you know four years ago I was
just a a chess teacher in New York City
and um okay I don't want to just you
know undermine that profession just the
chess teacher but that was I was
watching these tournaments as a
spectator and a fan and uh that sort of
never goes away uh also much taller than
I thought and if anybody chess boxes
Magnus they are going to have a serious
issue I I I get where all the hype from
and the athleticism uh claims come from
so that that was pretty cool um got a
little bit of a Gucci cologne spell no
I'm just making things up at this point
um back to the chess cuz you know we got
to focus here we've got a hanging Knight
on H5 in the Wesley so game and
meanwhile Magnus put his Knight on the
F4 Square so both these matches are
great I just have to say lot of tension
totally lock position on one side
and on the other side we've got I don't
know we got Magnus coming in with an
attack I guess sorry I was going to say
if you had to pick right now uh which uh
player you prefer on both boards Levy
who would it
be I really like Wesley's position I I
generally don't like being cramped like
the position nerc has because you have
to time a Counterattack and that's not a
skill that I have at all plus you have
to play on the queen side in in Wesley's
game uh if if you're noer back and uh I
I really don't know how I feel like
being under kingside pressure and well
if I apply that same logic to the left
side I would rather play Black obviously
because you have the open f file close
Center good attacking chances what about
you guys yeah Levy I was going to say on
the left hand side of our screen here
Fabiano at least he has an opportunity
to initiate a pawn break and I often say
the side that controls the pawn breaks
is the side with the advantage black has
some Pawn braks of his own for Magnus
Carlson he can push his G Pawn to create
more threats in front of the white king
but I I'm with you that I feel like Nock
that position's too closed for my liking
and Wesley seems to be having all the
fun over there on the king
side oh absolutely actually why don't we
pop over to that game as uh Fabiano has
to make a decision there with magnus's
Rook on F4 we can take a look at uh nck
versus Wesley so that match has
gone uh I mean it's been a crazy back
and forth battle so Nock has just moved
his Knight we see Wesley has a critical
decision to make it's it's a weird
position guys right because Wesley has
to basically not lose this game that's
the reality cuz he's up 2 to one in
today's set so the position however is
demanding violence of the highest order
isn't that a really difficult tight rope
to cross right because you know white is
going to play A4 B5 as we see these
beautiful blue arrows drawn there from
Oslo I am not doing that look at that
the F5 F4 very very tense position who
do we uh who do we favor I know computer
says black but computer's like 800
points higher rated than the highest
human so how are we feeling well uh the
computer normally loves Connect Four I
was going to say but the E4 Pawn
suddenly gets traded off on passant
apparently it's forc but uh e takes F3
I'm not so sure about this one uh for
Wesley so as he clears his throat uh
Rook takes F3 Pawn takes Bishop
takes at least he's broken the head of
the pawn chain oh you couldn't pay me
money you you couldn't pay me money to
take with the pawn but Bishop takes yeah
now a knight is coming to E4 I mean once
again I I'm just saying it's a situation
where Wesley has to not lose but he's
taking the fight to OD I mean someone's
probably going to lose this game and
there's a chance it could be Wesley and
then it's two to2 and then we have to
play an Armageddon for today's set so uh
but anyway I will let the uh I will let
you guys live broadcast and Oslo take it
away great listening to you thanks for
checking in with me thanks uh lby we
will uh we will check in with you again
soon uh and I agree with him that you
know in this game Wesley needs only a
draw but he's going all out there's no
backing down from this position once
you've Advanced those kingside pawns
you've already declared war with G5 F5
on the board there's no way to go solid
or passive in this position and even if
Wesley it's Advantage Wesley at this
particular moment that's also in some
ways good news for nbec because he knows
that the position will open up there
will be opportunities for both players
to go wrong yeah well the power of the
dog was a great movie from Jane camping
I think the power of the night has been
the theme of this match we just saw
notbe abdar win by blocking a rook with
his Knight so he could promote here that
Knight on D7 for black that's going to
hop right into the center Knight F6
Knight E4 you have forward progress
allowed for that Knight he started the
queen E8 you have an open diagonal
because the F Pawn has been pushed so I
feel like White's play A4 B5 this kind
of attack on the queen side it's really
slow and it might not amount to much
whereas black can actually throw pawns
forward as well F4 G4 you have to time
these things correctly but with the
night Maneuvers with these Pawn pushes I
certainly like Black's chances I've got
to agree uh the top players in the world
they like space they like uh having
access to weak squares and that's
exactly what Wesley does right now and
yeah I'm loving your night maneuver
Robert I would take black here every
time and also ahead on the clock as well
uh for nbec it will come down to having
those extra seconds because this
position will get very demanding and
will require a lot of calculation at
some point from both these players
Wesley looking really relaxed and right
now he we've been talking about Wesley
from the start as being this extremely
solid player is uh the hardest to beat
in the circuit doesn't take the fight
but waits for the fight to come to him
when you give him the opportunity he
takes it but this event the Champions
Chester final from the very start we've
been seeing a very different Wesley
we've seen him get aggressive without
being provoked well here I think he was
provoked a little bit because if he sat
passively he understands at this high
level that if you kind of just wait for
your opponent to do something you don't
have a plan of your own so he created
some plans he pushed his Pawns in front
of his King to force White's pieces back
and if he had given nybeck all the time
in the world we would have seen an
avalanche on the queen side that hasn't
even started yet there's not even a
snowball over there and on in the middle
of the board you see all the black's
pieces and the Knights coming to the
king side I really like his position and
you know the position is one where he
kind of had to react and he's reacting
perfectly and quickly that's maybe the
most important element here yeah you can
tell how uncomfortable nck is here just
his clock consumption here his use of
the time it's really uncharacteristic
normally we see NC when he's confident
when he's on form just blitzing out the
moves hustling his opponents on the
clock happy to play kind of uh kind of
not the best move but wanting to play it
quickly and here he's down three and a
half minutes he's retreating his Bishop
back where he came from I think
regretting the decision to take on F3
with this bishop now he wants to park it
on D3 but
either way nbec is suffering if you give
him the chance to turn the board around
and take blackside I think he would
every day of the week so Abdu satarov
right now needing a miracle to uh win
this game he puts the bishop on D3 but
Black's Knights are coming in Black's
pawns are coming forward King side the
right half of the board black is
dominant well swapping colors isn't an
option so n has to try to create
something out of what he's got right now
uh the one the one positive in the
position for white is that there are
still a lot of pieces on the board very
few trades have happened very few things
have been simplified so far and even if
Wesley is in driver seed I'm I'm going
to say this again that this position
when it does explode because Wesley has
expanded the king side I think it does
have potential to go in NC's favor as
well at some point it does and I think
if nck can successfully push his pawns
up the queen side that's how he get
chances he's got no play no activity no
threats until he does just that and we
know he will and that's why Wesley he
just can't sit around all day he's going
to try to improve his pieces uh maybe
he's going to push his H Pawn like David
said maybe he'll just bring his Knight
up to that E4 square that was vacated
when he took on pan but no matter what
he needs to play in the center of the
board here I don't believe in the
queenside pressure that even if you get
A4 and B5 in for white just feels a bit
slow and let's remind everyone if nck
wins this game this match goes into
Armageddon if it ends in a draw or in
Wesley's favor Wesley gets the set and
we will move on to a set three between
these two players and of course uh
there's also Fabby who is fighting to
stay in the Champions Chester final
against Magnus Carlson he needs a win in
his uh in his game and he plays with the
white pieces this is the current
position and at first side you see that
Black's Rook magnus's Rooks have lined
up on the f file and whenever that
happens in these Spanish and these
Italian positions there's always this
sacrifice on F3 that comes into my mind
you're always thinking about Rook takes
nine blow open White's King all of
White's Army is on the queen side very
few defenses uh Magnus right now
preparing for it he goes H5 he's
preparing for a G4 that's coming up I
would say there are big threats on Fabby
right now in this current position big
threats and I just want to point out as
well a small trap that Fabiano did set
at least for Magnus on the last turn he
dropped his kn back looks like a blunder
ooh Free Pawn up for grabs but White's
Queen would have slid back this was a
poison pawn and suddenly Black's Rook
finds itself awkwardly placed If It
Moves if it shifts out the way White
Queen pounces and sneaks in Behind Enemy
ranks this would have been Advantage
white but Magnus Carson yeah H5
motioning down the board push those
pawns and it's because the center is
blocked that he's able to do this Robert
mentioned this earlier when the center's
blocked you can advance on the flanks uh
at will and right now yes there's
tension between the these two pawns but
Fabiano never really wants to release
that tension because even in an end game
black has the advantage black here has
full control weak Pawn to look at
massive pressure down the file F2
hanging Black's Knight coming in this
would be almost over oneway traffic at
least uh so H5 Fabiano has to be really
creative to stem the tide G4 looks so
ominous right now I would quickly be
playing a move like Rook to D2 right now
because I see G4 is coming and if you
play G4 now I swap off pawns then move
my Knight probably back to H2 and that
G4 pawn it does stick out there's not
another Pawn to defend it so I'm not
sure if black can ever take on e4 so
that is something that you have to keep
an eye on but I do believe this gives
white legitimate chances T was asking in
the game between Notre Beck and Wesley
is there some long-term potential for N
I don't see it in that game but here I
do see it for fabbi because that's an
isolated Pawn there's so many tactics up
in the air the black king isn't
perfectly safe either so I think that
with White's position solidifying he
will then be able to turn it around
it's uh really interesting to me that
Fabby is uh almost touching the
two-minute mark because as we've been
pointing out G4 is such a big threat on
the board you can't possibly give up
that F2 Pawn you have to defend it but
are there some tactics is there another
creative way to go into the offense
because if not Rook D2 you play it
really quickly yeah maybe this is just
symptomatic of Fabiano not being
confident not liking his position uh
I've been there so many times in my
career I hate my position even if
sometimes there's a move or one move
that's clearly superior to the rest you
just sit there kind of wallowing a bit
down philosophizing and he has to just
speed up play Rook D2 defend this Pawn
he okay he plays Knight to E3 wow
provoking G4 he's actually going for a
similar idea to you mentioned uh Robert
there Knight to H2 he wants to actually
forfeit this Pawn in return for the G4
G4 Pawn to activate his Knights and
actually I quite like this idea um if in
the current position black ever allows a
pawn capture and and the White Knight to
pounce into D5 suddenly there's actually
access squares so Fabby spent a long
long time in that move maybe too long
but he did in the end find a creative
idea and uh I like the fact that it's
not too submissive either it's not
reacting to Black's threats it's uh
trying to leap forward with his Knights
I prefer his move for sure not just
because he's the person making it
because it's ambitious and he's just
trying to create an imbalance and that
G4 push that we keep talking about white
does lose a pawn very close to his King
but he actually steals a pawn that's
getting close to the King and with lines
opening up with pawns being removed from
the board we may just see this very
variation that with pawns being removed
that means that they're more open lines
more chances to trade some pieces and if
you take this G4 Pawn white has the
outermost pawn and why that's important
as we get fewer pieces on the board
having a distraction a decoy far away
from the other flank that can be very
very useful in an end game yeah really
nice move there creative idea from Fabby
and I think this wasn't on magnus's
radar we were struggling to see it as
well but he's found a creative way to
keep the balance but uh by playing
actively often if you have a choice
between active passive moves if they uh
both look roughly level play the active
one put your opponent Under Pressure
surprise them and one more move by with
the white Knights taking the black G4
Pawn off the board serious threats
against the black king you can tell on
the body language Magnus a bit
frustrated and uh just a bit bemused
perhaps because he must have loved his
position until this last uh this L lost
little sequence yeah Fab has definitely
dragged Magnus into complications in
this one with this uh creative resource
that you were talking about very
difficult to find but we've seen him do
that time and time again in this match
moves like Queen B4 earlier in their set
one and Magnus is going for it he takes
the F2 Pawn he's giving the G4 Pawn the
one thing in magnus's favor is that it's
very difficult on that left side of our
screen for Fab's major pieces the queens
and The Rook to transfer over to the
king side so he's got some time to try
to get Harmony within his own pieces
before the queen and the Rook I think C4
is a big threat for white it absolutely
is we're talking about the left hand
side he takes you with the E3 Knight
that's actually bit counterintuitive
usually you like to capture with your
less active piece pieces closer to your
own territory but he's opening up the
third rank for Tanya C4 push and the
queen sliding on over to G3 ignoring the
queen side so watch out Magnus Carl in
some trouble the left and the right hand
side it's more of the same Wesley so
he's played a perfect game thus far with
the black pieces he just opened up a
diagonal from his Queen towards that E3
Pawn he's blasting open the white king
side not down to 2 minutes 24 seconds
tick tick tick tick he just doesn't have
time and you see the Eva bar all the way
up now wow Abdus soro's position is
collapsing in front of our very eyes
simply the white King on the right board
there is going to come under heavy fire
Wesley so quick so confident Retreats
Black Knight two monster threats firstly
to eliminate White's Bishop in the
center of the board secondly to attack
White's H Pawn nobec is not long for
this world his dark squares are falling
apart Wesley playing aggressively but
also keeping all the Strategic points
under control in this position nck in
big trouble on the position with a big
threat of losing that H4 Pawn also down
on the clock uh and for Wesley with
black he has made it look easy in this
game so far never in trouble out of the
opening NC did not even manage to get
that a pawn up the board creating a
Potential Threat on the queen side while
all hell breaks loose on the other side
of the board it looks terrible for nck
and he knows it and it's sort of the
opposite of game three where nck he was
just waiting and Wesley was playing this
very ambitious provocative chest that
completely backfired here n had no
choice he needs a win in this game he
couldn't just play quietly make a draw
and say that's okay he needs to win to
take the set head to the finals but it
looks like Wesley so is about to take
this one and that means we'll have a
reset a third set for all the marbles to
get to the finals and we'll talk more
about the format of the third set later
right now Wesley needs to finish the job
that he started and is well on his way
so we see a trade on F4 which opens up
the E line for counterplay but is
counterplay going to happen with the H
Pawn falling and not just the H Pawn
falling the gwn potentially moving
forward and checkmating ideas on NC's
King yeah white King is doomed it's as
simple as that he's trying to create
some Escape squares here nbec Abdu satov
Whit King will try to run for the hills
but unlike Wesley s King in the previous
game it's not going to get very far and
uh I think we'll shortly see a
checkmating pattern occur on that board
but uh yeah wesle so he's done
everything right we're guaranteed more
chest no matter what the result in that
match at least what's funny about the
position the right side he does bring
his Knight in I was going to say he's up
a pawn so even if he doesn't deliver a
Checkmate he can just plant a knight
into the the E4 Square clog up that lane
and if that Knight's ever captured on e4
because checkmates will be threatened
The Rook on f8 suddenly stares into the
white position it looks really really
bad on the right hand side from n abdar
in the left hand side Magus Carlson's
Frozen he's under three minutes on the
clock because that Queen on B3 that
left- hand side Queen it's going to
slide on over the same line as the enemy
King and that's going to spell some
serious danger for Magnus and that's not
the only thing needs to worry about that
pawn on A5 can become a big Thor in
magnus's position if he allows Fabby to
capture on B5 suddenly Fabby will have
an A5 passer and we've got a result
coming
in WoW Wesley so it looked like they
spoke to each other it was a draw Wesley
offers a draw in a totally winning
position because that secures him this
set of the match and Wesley gets it done
there was no hope in NC's position he
accept the draw with this G Pawn moving
forward with NC's King Under Fire he
takes the draw which means there will be
a set three between these two players
and to me it looks like Fabby has made
great progress Robert you pointed out
that the Queen's sliding on from the
queen side to the king side I'm looking
at that A5 Pawn if Magnus allows that
trade I think that's one more thing to
worry about for black and he doesn't
allow it he was choosing between two
evils either he goes and protects his
king or he allows an a pawn to be passed
with few black pieces to St it so this
queen it can take a pawn back on C4 I
would not be caring about material
Fabiano doesn't he slides it over to G3
and if he could get a rook to the H file
it's going to be a lad Checkmate so if
Fabby could bring his Knight to F3 King
to F2 Rook on over to H1 that's actually
going to be a check I don't know if he
has time for it but I'm already looking
in that direction yeah look at that
black king magnus's king sitting on the
edge of the board literally has no
shelter around it uh the black king
drops back of course Fabiano won't
repeat the position but it feels like
there should be a knockout punch the
white Rook can come up via A3 G3 the
third rank is totally open as well I
love that idea David Rook A3 Rook G3
looks extremely strong here maybe
there's something even better Black's
Rook on F4 so short of squares feels
like Fabiano on the verge of a knockout
punch and it's no surprise you need
Pawns in front of your king it's as
simple as that in chess and Black's King
has zero right now the might of the
White Queen and the white Knights
leaping forward should be decisive
Fabiano he has kind of lost control of a
position similar to this before though
that's the one doubt in the back of his
mind but I love that Rook A3 Rook G3
maneuver because Rook lifts are always
fun but especially when the black king
has no Pawns in front of it and little
has separated these two players
historically in match play their world
championship in 2018 12 draws In
classical chess Rook A3 here Rook G3
next the king it just doesn't have
pieces to defend it beautiful awareness
from Fabiano and Magnus looks like he's
not just in trouble I think I think he's
toast and it's so easy to forget about
these Rook lifts cuz you're focused on
one side of the board you're looking at
ideas of improving your knight getting
that into play going Knight F3 and then
suddenly from the other side of the
board this reinforcement a really big
reinforcement into the attack and now
Fab's one move away that Rook lands on
the G file and Magnus could be busted
yeah we know Fabby loves going to the
jery loves working out yesterday was leg
day today is Rook lift day and he's
lifted that Rook yeah simply three four
attacking pieces for white I'm going to
count both those white Knights because
they mo they most likely will play A
Part soon the White Queen and with the
added spice of that white Rook against
the naked black king how can you fight
off uh that amount of
ammunition even if we calculate
variations I'm struggling to see a way
for black to cling on and even if the
evaluation bar wasn't through the roof
saying white is objectively winning with
less than a minute on his clock how do
you defend a position like this I know
look at Magnus he's looking away he's
pretty much giving up he's shaking his
head he knows he is lost oh my gosh but
he's going to fight he's not going to
give up at this very moment I think the
biggest problem in magnus's position is
what you want to do is you want to get a
rook on the G file but Rook F7 isn't
even possible because there was a check
on 86 forking the rook and the king so
no way to get the Rook into the defense
he tries to block it with the bishop
after Rook does slide over to G3 I think
Magnus wants to bring the Knight over in
front of the Rook to defend that Bishop
on G5 I think that white can even there
just win a piece quite simply you can
always throw in like a rook G3 Knight H6
check and Black's position is collapsing
so Rook G3 is step one if he does go
Knight F7 I actually think Knight H6
check just ends the game so he blocks
with his queen that way well Knight H6
is still there I does that work I think
Knight H6 is strong but Magnus does love
giving up his Queen in general and the
number of times He suggests giving up
his Queen in analysis it's uh it's crazy
I think Fabiano doesn't want to cash in
too soon for an attack that's worth more
and uh Knight 86 check is not going away
anytime soon first he's just going to
eliminate that Bishop that black Bishop
I think the problem is that black is
frozen Magnus Frozen on the camera
Black's pieces are stuck the attack is
incoming it's all about the G file and
black is collapsing under 20 seconds now
he gives up material to fight against
the threat on the G file he's trying to
run away with the King but the threats
in the G file continue because that
Bishop on G5 is still on the pin I don't
even know where that King thinks it's
going I guess E7 but that's not going to
run all the way to the queen side if you
could lift that King up and then
teleported to a square like B7 maybe it
starts to feel safe but that's a long
journey away mag is doing the right
thing though his Rook on f8 it could
slide on over to the H file and maybe
the white king could feel a bit of the
heat for now fa has everything under
control he's also doing really well in
the clock and he just needs to put
Magnus away which he couldn't do two
games ago yeah and he has to be careful
about that because exactly with the
white pieces in game two in a winning
position there were a few imprecise
moves made and Magnus was all over in
that game then so for Fabby he needs to
still finish the job he's up in exchange
to me it would make a lot of sense to
just draw back with the Knight and try
to capitalize on the pin along the G
file Knight F2 would be the move of my
choice here because I also stopped the
check on E3 is there another way to
probably just with a stronger blow here
right now I like it Tanya you've done
the hard work you've won material white
is up a rook for Bishop so why not just
create smaller threats why not regroup
your pieces um I think you don't
actually need to do anything too special
there might be stronger moves might be
more direct moves but ultimately Fabby
needs to play quickly the only time it's
gone wrong for him is when it gets super
messy he loses a little bit of control
and he has no time on the clock so just
keep the time Advantage the wind should
be relatively straightforward if you
play moves such as Knight F2 he's about
to decide he reaches out for the Knight
and it's on the board and one thing I'll
note that if the Queens do come off and
maybe Queen H6 for black at least you're
not getting checkmated for mag you have
a bishop and one Pawn for that Rook so
there is quite a lot of material and
he's I think about to go for this I
don't think the task is that simple for
Fabby if the Queens come off and the
thing when you're playing against Magnus
is you have to be so precise even when
you're ahead in material we've seen
Magnus turn around in this very match
itself in this against Fabby itself and
it looks like this is a big Brer can he
is there I was going to say Rook takes
Bishop but Queen takes Rook is with a
check yeah the problem is there's a pin
on the G file black is also collapsing
on the other flank Fab is now going to
infiltrate on the SE line and actually
the E6 Pawn is hanging with the check W
Magnus is really really Fallen apart
these last few moves it was lost anyway
but this is really bad but what a smart
thing Fab did he put his Rook on C1 in
The Bishop's line of site it couldn't be
captured because the queen was behind
now he's taking this Pawn the Knight has
to move the Knight moves the bishop out
that's a resignation and that's a tide
match that's a tied match that goes into
Armageddon as Fabiano caruana does it he
Strikes Back leveling their score and
this one goes into sudden depth which
Fabby needs to win to stay alive to take
it into set three but he will be feeling
confident Fabiano caruana right now he
is a wow One of a Kind beating Magnus
Carson so many times and did you see
that David Magnus he was so angry on the
screen he can't believe it that he
didn't finish this off well do you know
why he's angry CU Faby hasn't beat him
not once not twice but Thrice in these
last two days in Rapid chess the only
thing separating them is that Armageddon
game yesterday I'm curious what their
bids will be today yeah Magnus will he
be confident taking black yet again
after experiencing that nightmare in the
previous game Fabiano crushed him wiped
him off the board with that Killer
attack Magnus Carlson is an angry man
right now and he's angry with himself
with what he's let happen he has to
fight it out in the Armageddon right now
and he's got to forget about what has
just happened wow that's going to be an
exciting battle but Fabby he really kept
his nerves in those final moments and
wrapped it up as quickly and precisely
as he could and this is where we are
Wesley so Strikes Back Against ANC Abdu
satov will take it to set three and
Magnus Carlson has to win the Armageddon
to go into the final if Fabby wins that
one goes into set three as well Bobby
needs to take this one in Armageddon I
think the reason why Magnus he so just
displeased himself is not because he
blunders because fabi's just outplaying
him and Fabiano may be the only player
in the world right now who can take down
Magnus in the series of games like
this it's going to be an exciting battle
to watch World number one and world
number two in the sudden death bit for
Wesley so it was a quick a quick match
he took it he did not need the
Armageddon and he was impressive David
with the black pieces yep Wesley so
impressive in this last game and with
black never looked in doubt the way he
closed it out as well really really
cynical and it was in this position
where we were talking about Black's
Advantage we were talking quite
theoretically here we were saying okay
black has a space Advantage black has
these beautiful pawns clamping down on
the center but it's also the fact that
the black pieces have swarmed towards
the king side and here he broke through
Pawn to G4 opening up this black Queen's
diagonal yes this Pawn is defended but
watch out for it later first of all
going for the white king and after H4
trying to plug the king side Wesley
simply took a calm step back opening up
an attack against the H4 pawn and also
trying to eliminate this key piece the
H4 Pawn now is doomed the piece was
traded off and actually Wesley Now by
infiltrating with his Queen and then
bringing his Knight in could have gone
on to win this game but here a draw was
agreed if black had wanted to Black
could have played on the idea of G3 and
bring the queen in would have been
powerful and just a decisive Advantage
ultimately though a draw was enough and
Wesley was happy to offer one and not
never got off the ground in that match
his pawns they were stuck because black
had this clamp Wesley played really well
in that game to seize the initiative the
upper hand and a pawn and in the other
game the way Fabiano Carana played I
mean so brilliant the it looked like he
was the one under attack but he was able
to strike back and in this position it
looks like the black king is unsafe the
white king not feeling too safe either
but you need more pieces in the attack
and C4 was a great strike because that
queen wants to head on over to the king
side and not just that if you just try
to put all your pieces Defending Your
King C takes B5 is a huge threat trying
to get an outside pass Pawn that black
will not be able to stop so Magnus took
the pawn on C4 the queen was able to
slide over to G3 and after a few moves
Magnus was forced to give up his Rook
for a knight because he couldn't stop
all of the threats and with the extra
material Fabiano was able to convert
quite
handily yeah beautiful win Fabiano I
love The Rook lift followed well
actually the queen lift first of all
just swinging across the board Fabiano
did everything methodically just and uh
kind of turned it into a decisive
material advantage at the right time
Magnus barely got a chance in that game
just Flawless play from White yeah just
amazing chess there start to finish by
fabibi in that game with the white
pieces and he gets the win and he breaks
the Magnus spell and we saw Magnus react
uh when that game finished while he was
sitting down to put in his bids and look
at that he is just maded himself for
what he let happen on the board David
your Norwegian what do you say um I will
not say it it's it's a kid friendly show
here but it wasn't nice what Magnus was
saying to himself there and uh he's
frustrated more chess for him is not
what he wanted yeah and if Fabby is able
to get the job done in the Armageddon it
will go down to set three so we've got a
big big fight coming up between these
two you don't want to close your eyes
you don't want to miss a thing as it is
sudden that it is the Armageddon and
Fabiano kwana can and he finished the
job that he started with his win in
round four against the world number one
these two face off in
[Music]
armagan oh my God I can't believe it we
are here with Gotham chess he our
headliner VIP at the chess kid Festival
yeah that's you and I just found out
he's going to be streaming from the VIP
room are you saying there's a CH I could
be on your stream no no not not not you
but the kids the kids can be on my
stream Mike and that's what's important
oh man I guess I got too old for this
event I'll be there but if you're a kid
in elementary or middle school you get a
chance to be on the biggest stream in
all the land Gotham are you worried any
of these kids are going to come for your
job uh maybe one day but I have over 4
million subscribers so you guys got to
start today practice up ches kids you
may just get to be on Gotham chess of
stream sign up for the Gotham chess VIP
package and we'll see you at the chess
kid national
[Music]
festival a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things another one of the VIPs from the
chess kid nation Festival we have the OG
Papa Bear here I am Danny wrench and
he's going to be starting a very
Innovative concept what do you got yeah
I'm going to be facing off against
women's grandm Jennifer Shaha and our
first ever puzzle be we've actually been
excited about doing this for years and I
think it's going to become something
special so solving puzzles against Jen
let's go and what Danny doesn't know is
that we actually have a new prize we
have a golden peska we've been working
on this and the winner gets this peska
want to hold that guy yeah it's real
gold what is going on gold my friend was
this in the budget I don't know so it's
worth a lot come find out who wins the
very first golden
[Music]
peska
watch
[Music]
you
w
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're back in Toronto where all the
action of the Champions chestar finals
is happening and it's been a dramatic
week and it's a dramatic day of the
semi-finals as we've got a big
Armageddon Clash that is coming up for
day two we see Sports on our screen and
it's ice hockey and there is going to be
more chess coming up as well as Sports
Fever takes the city right now it's
Armageddon fever that's on and Kaa is
with Fabby and Magnus revealing their
beds we have another armagon between
Fabby and Magnus you guys go ahead and
turn your boards to see those bids we
have
958 10 minutes okay that means black
pieces for you Fabby how do you feel
about
that I don't know I played so many
harmageddon I have no idea I'm just
happy to uh to have gotten back and I
promise Dan Armageddon so that's I guess
what we got super close uh bits Magnus
how do you feel about playing with the
white pieces here it's okay I mean
obviously like losing out by 2 seconds
it's not ideal but I had no idea what to
write so that's okay I'm on is coming up
back to you
guys a smiling Fabby a not smiling
Magnus SC soon as Fabby does get the
black pieces and he beats Magnus with
just a two second bid and we are going
to have the first moves really quickly
he beat magnus's bid with two seconds
has he outsmarted Magnus to get black
maybe but will he live to regret having
the black pieces that's the big question
the games are
beginning five extra minutes from for
Magnus Carlson could be decisive he
needs to win however Magnus with white
plays the Spanish it's the Spanish on
the board and we're going to quickly
jump into Toronto with Levy and James
and their thoughts on the bids we saw
and the opening that we are seeing right
now thanks Tanya yeah the opening
definitely a bit of a surprise I mean we
have some sort of weird uh we have an
open Spanish which I think is definitely
in Fabiano's wheelhouse I just want to
say something we were going to stand
here as commentators and say wow Magnus
bid 10 that was his Max he knew Fabby
was going to bid 958 and then he said I
had no idea what's right it was funny
yeah you know I was going to be like oh
that's so so such a brilliant read by
and then he just goes yeah I had no clue
they have so little time to make that
decision that's true bro it's very quick
I mean of course 958 usually you see
Magnus is the one that does it like
Magnus is the one that always out bids
You by one or two seconds here so Fabby
may have a little mental edge here you
see how Magnus was pissed basically you
can just tell this is not the friendly
Magnus right now he's trying to close
out and I do just want to say this open
Spanish as we're about to throw it back
there to Oslo for them to get into the
X's nose this is an open Spanish this is
not a closed Spanish white black has
taken the pawn on e4 lots of theory here
so Fabiano despite the time disadvantage
is going to get to play a ton of moves
that he already knows 100% And then
after that it's just maybe three or four
critical decisions correct he might be
in good shape cor I think it's a great
choice as well open Spanish you get a
lot of moves in as Notre back said
before when you going to you know you
need to get get to like move 60s you get
that extra time and stuff like that so
this is going to be exciting especially
we have an open Spanish so yeah man we
might have what have two tiebreaker
matches today all right Oslo take it
away thanks guys uh James you're right
no increment until move 60 for the
players where they get after which they
get a 1 second increment now Fabby gets
the result odds the draw odds starts
with 9 Minutes 58 seconds on the clock
and to me that's a pretty good bargain
yeah I think he's done everything right
in the opening uh Levy and James there
kind of referred to it the open Spanish
it's one of the most forcing lines as
well in chess in general like Fabiano he
gets black gets draw odds gets an
opening he knows in and out tension will
be minimal here it feels like
everything's gone right for him still
early stages but uh I'm loving what
Fabiano's done with the bid and with the
opening Fabio does have one unhappy
memory though on the black side of an
open Spanish and that occurred in Madrid
last year against hikaro Nakamura it was
an open Spanish a forcing line a
material imbalance five lost that game
and with it his chances at a world
championship title but we see in this
game he is solid in the Center that
Knight on e4 looks like it's under
attack but that just leads to a series
of exchanges that black is not unhappy
about and after Knight to D2 I've been
wondering can it's some point black push
the F Pawn that looks a little bit risky
maybe inste he should put his Bishop out
on F5 and it resembles what nybeck and
Wesley had in their match as tension on
the E4 square and to release that
tension you can trade pieces and you can
start with trading the knights and then
put the bishop on F5 as you suggested
trying to get rid of as many minor
pieces as possible a draw would mean
that Fabby wins the match Magnus with
white has to create his chances he has
to but how he pauses now when the most
obvious recapture would be by developing
White's Bishop uh the white Dart Square
Bishop on C1 hasn't moved why not take
back this Black Knight but Magnus he's
looking for something creative because
at some point he'll need to surprise
Fabiano he'll need to switch it up maybe
hit him with a and kind of shocking
unexpected move and maybe he takes with
the queen to try and bring the White
Queen closer to the king side but either
way I still love Black's position and
Black's chances in this game the clock
differential has now reduced to only 4
minutes and material might reduce if he
takes with the bishop on D2 just
developing his undeveloped Bishop then
black pushes the pawn the center up to
D4 and suddenly it's not just things are
blowing open that the white King's in
any danger but pieces are leaving the
board and Fabiano still has so much time
on his clock 8 minutes 34 seconds a
reminder to everybody that once they
reach move 60 then there's 1 second
added for each and every move you make
so this move Queen takes D2 I think it's
trying trying to meet D4 with that Queen
escaping over to the king side perhaps
trying to initiate an attack well I've
played these positions with black as
well and you're absolutely right there
are two ideas either black tries to
trade off the light squat Bishop with
the move Bishop F5 we see Fabby go for
that I think the problem with the
immediate D4 is also you have to
calculate what happens if the white Rook
slides onto the open D line and that's
why Magnus chose to vacate that square
and capture with the Queen Bishop F5 to
me it looks like Advantage Fabby out of
the opening he's already managed to uh
to swap off two pairs of minor pieces
and that's good news when you're
fighting when you're looking for the
draw yeah I simply don't see anything
wrong with Black's position and Tanya
you made this uh I mean this exclamation
Because a queen trade in a must-win
situation it's counterintuitive right
that's what I would think Robert Queen
F4 and I would grab that Queen if a draw
is what I needed for the match Victory
but going into an end game against
Magnus Carlson is always a scary thing
and it's not just magn it's the type of
position that we have here because while
Black's position does look healthy a few
things stand out to me that pawn on C7 I
see a diagonal opening up and that pawn
on C7 can be attacked if the pawn goes
up to E6 and he just goes forward with
D4 and look at Magnus that C7 Pawn
really is a weakness and look at the
advantage bar it's going up for white
the evaluation bar is showing an
advantage for white what does Fabiano
have prepared once this SE file opens I
think he's planning to move his Knight
unfortunately you don't have time to
come out with your bishop and skewer the
white Rooks because uh ultimately the
white Rook on E1 is defended by White's
Knight so this would be a poor choice
white would be up two pieces for one
black rook and uh two pieces better than
the rook in this case instead I think
he's banking on Knight to B4 coming for
this Pawn but also trying to head back
into the middle of the board what he
might have underestimated or only now
realized Fabiano is that after Rook
takes Pawn the Knight dropping back yes
this is a fork yes this is a double
attack but if the white Rook just moves
suddenly black is stuck this bishop is
attacked so Knight takes Bishop Rook
takes would just be a trade and white
would emerge a pawn to the good and if
you move your Bishop out the way to try
and gain time against White's Rook white
Rook can save the day swoop up and
defend its Bishop either way Magnus is
winning a pawn and he goes for it and
maybe this is the moment that you stop
and the idea you pointed out threat is
better than the execution stronger than
the execution do you just simply defend
that Bishop on E7 with the move that
you're pointing out and now I'm
attacking your A2 pawn and Knight D5 a
big move on the board coming up it's a
tough call though because there's a lack
of clarity here so many pieces remain so
Fabiano spends some time right now and
realizes that if I start with this
Knight D5 in the live position and TR up
instead he does go for Rook E8 I think
it is a good call but I say you have to
assess do I actually go down one pawn
and that's okay because all Rook end
games are drawn it still would have been
a tough sledding ahead but he decides to
go Rook E8 and now with A2 pawns
threatened Knight D3 Knight D5 all sorts
of Knight jumps that white has to worry
about I'm liking Black's position uh
right now there are all these threats on
the board I'm planning to equalize the
material uh for Fabby
he hasn't burnt that much time on the
clock although I do see that Magnus is
still ahead by 5 minutes what do you
think how would you evaluate this
position David it's tough I don't think
we can make generalizations here I think
it's very concrete if white isn't able
to fend off one of these threats or if
white isn't able to save this Pawn then
black is safe black is fine and will
easily make the draw so Magnus should
spend as much time as possible here uh
as much time is as is practical and
decide what to do next the biggest
threat of all is Knight to D5 we should
mention hitting the Rook hitting the
bishop so you need to move one of these
two pieces essentially uh I think
there's simply no other option Knight to
D5 is a winning threat so he moves the
bishop out the way maybe he could have
gone in a different direction but he's
aiming to trade off and go for the F7
Pawn Magnus I'm really surprised he
didn't invest much more time there
because uh there were options available
but still testing Fabiano I think a
continue testing him because if we just
go down one more Knight D3 looks like it
solves all of Black's problems hits The
Rook hits the B2 pawn and the E5 Pawn
all at once is there E6 can you throw in
that move just causing chaos because if
you take the Rook on E1 that's not a
free rook because e takes F7 is check I
get the Rook right back and you see the
evaluation is all the way at the top
because white is not just one p and will
likely win a second at the very least so
this is something that maybe Magnus is
going for it's not just a trick I think
it is just objectively a good decision
and then the black king isn't feeling so
safe yeah and if you take this Pawn
suddenly There's real Targets later in
the game and okay Fabiano Dodges this he
plays F6 and big question for Magnus do
you drop back and maybe lose your
winning chances or do you go in and uh
hope to muddy the waters Magnus sitting
back in his chair looks shocked he's
reaching out and he does go in he's
going for the aggressive approach The
Rook on d8 is hanging is it time to
start stepping up with that Rook to
Target White's Queens side pawns how is
Fabby going to react to this and let's
also point out if Fabby loses this match
he is out of the finals he needs to get
this game to get to a third set like
Wesley so was able to accomplish and
this is such a critical moment because
our first Temptation probably for
everybody to save The Rook but all the
way up to D2 putting pressure on the
pawns but I'm realizing that once white
pushes the pawn forward to E6 we have a
protected pass P from The Rook behind it
and that black Rook can actually take
the pawn on B2 it's stuck to that D6
Square because if the Knight you push a
pawn then get your knight out suddenly
black is not able to deal with all the
threats and after E6 I don't really know
what black does I mean this is showing
is just going to be losing I don't know
how Fabby holds on here I think he just
simply forgot that Magnus could keep the
ewn alive he wanted to trade it off at
all costs but he didn't have enough time
Fabiano and suddenly I mean this Pawn is
just a monster there's always tactics
actually even on the back Rank and I
don't even see a good move for black you
cannot move this Knight I mean if you go
in for example Knight D6 I think your
idea Robert still on the cards if you
remove this Rook remove the blockada
White's Pawn will just motor through and
promote Fabiana in big trouble suddenly
and four minutes on the clock this
turned in the space of one or two moves
he was on the brink of safety but
suddenly letting it slip Magnus with the
ewn big favorite and everything started
so well right you start with this open
Spanish you quickly Blitz out the moves
you're able to trade off the pieces
really quickly the pressure is dissolved
and then these last two moves just
inaccuracies by Fabby big trouble can't
take the pawn on B2 can't put the knight
in the way of The Rook the most
important move to stop for Fabiano
Carana right now do not allow Magnus to
go Knight to D6 that E Pawn will become
a queen yeah but how do you stop that
eventually happening if you keep your
black Rook on the defile it means you're
unable to go and grab pawns Black's
Knight can never really recentralize
because uh then you block the defile
allowing it to happen again okay I have
a question what if Fabby just doesn't do
anything makes a move like A5 I'm
waiting how do you improve his white
hair stop pushing pawns to the king side
Queen side yeah there are going to be
some there at some point if I get my
king off the first even Rook D7 comes
into mind but what I'm looking at right
now is black I think is one tempo short
of Knight C2 back to D4 going right
after that E6 Pawn because David made an
excellent point they're actually are
back ranked Checkmate ideas just to show
Knight C2 Rook to E4 and then Knight to
D4 and you go Knight D6 here it looks
like you just blunder this Pawn E6 with
let's say even Knight takes E6 or Rook
takes E6 just grabbing that pawn but I
can just take you on E6 and then I back
rank Checkmate you so of course there
are going to be moments where you can
get away with something like this but
not here not when your king doesn't have
any Escape squares beautiful beautiful
tactics and this type of thing if not
this exact variation this type of thing
will keep recurring it's all about the
black king being stuck right now and uh
at some point I guess this Knight just
might be booted out he gives his King
some breathing space so guarding against
those motifs we mentioned the black king
now can at least mobilize but how does
Magnus continue that that is the big
question is there a way forward can he
eventually brute force it and push this
Pawn to Glory still some work to be done
for the world number one a much better
waiting move a kind of a waiting move by
Fabby the move H5 like you said just
giving a lift to Black sking and now
ideas of Knight C2 or Knight D3 are in
the air Magnus putting pressure on the
clock reaching out to make his next move
Fabby does hit the under three minute
Mark still far away far far away from
meeting move 60 getting that additional
second so it's not only keeping it on
the board but Fabby also has to avoid
getting flagged 2 minutes and 55 seconds
in this position you have to reach move
60 just to get that bonus time with
every move made and this is such a
tricky moment for Fabiano Carana but
Magnus is doing the right thing
investing some time here because perhaps
you could put the game away not caring
about the clock even if you gave fa a
day you see the evaluation bars all the
way up here I'm already looking at ways
to go after the H5 Pawn if I can land a
rook on h8 my coach always Tau me about
dream moves that would be checkmates a
rook back to C5 at some moment that
looks very enterprising to me trying to
go for the black king yeah I love it
Robert or pick up the white Rook on E1
somehow plunk it on h8 Rook E4 Rook H4
take the pawn uh yeah all these ideas
popping through Magnus Carson's mind
right now he must sense that he's doing
well and I think the moment it became
tactical he banks on his chances uh both
on the board and on the clock but still
he wants the accuracy the top players
are perfectionists they don't want to
let any opportuni slip and okay he's
pausing what to do first does he push a
pawn kick away the Black Knight does he
lift the white Rook up the board does he
I don't know push White's kingside pawns
forward there's so many options for
Magnus Carson critical moment he's in
the tank now 2 minutes once he starts
playing I'm expecting a quick flurry of
moves it's where players often go wrong
though when there are too many choices
you think this one looks just as good as
the other but there could be a flaw and
you could give black just the necessary
time to get back in the game and black
does have some threats a knight coming
into D3 that hits the Rook on E1 hits
multiple pawns and for Magnus he paus
and he does bring his Rook up to E4 so
any knight jump here doesn't come with
an attack against that rook and Rook H4
Rook takes H5 Rook h8 Checkmate not out
of the question yeah far from out of the
question and first of all posing a
difficult question to Black's Knight
three possible squares I think you
simply have to move that Knight perhaps
you can defend it with Black's Pawn but
uh there's downsides there's pros and
cons to every single night jump and
Fabiano it's basically a one and three
one and four I even forgot that this was
possible but it's so far offside now
that black knight it's not coming back
into action anytime soon Magnus
therefore has the luxury of a few turns
to really uh close in either push the
pawn or go for that black king as we've
mentioned Fabby levels the material for
now but in that deal he does put his
Knight completely offside does this give
Magnus enough time to try and go for the
check mating idea that you pointed out
sliding The Rook to the hline the one
defensive resource that Fabby has is to
push that g Pawn to G6 to make sure that
the H file remains blocked and at least
for the time being Rook h8 will not be
Checkmate probably definitely does not
want to open up the seventh rank but it
may be a sad necessity just to avoid
that immediate demise so G6 at any
moment for black does defend that pawn
that's sticking out there but that
seventh rank being open is very
dangerous so I'm looking at this for
Magnus everything does look good but if
if you go for Pon I actually don't see
how to end the game and that's good news
for Fabiano he may believe he's got a
Fighting Chance under two and a half
minutes right now he doesn't only have
to fight the board again he has to fight
the clock as well it is what is that
it's 35 moves to make it to move 60 and
that's a far way off with complications
still on the board the E Pawn two steps
away from from queening so there are
checkmating ideas on the king side you
have to avoid White's Knight jumping
onto D6 the pawn promoting further to E7
there's a a lot to fight for in this
position how is Fab going to manage this
it's not going to be easy I think
Fabiano's moves will be influenced by
magnus's moves right now the Black
Knight simply fixed on A2 no retreat
squares Black's Rook stuck defending the
D6 square and uh actually I'm looking
for mag Magnus just manifesting just
imagining perfect pawns perfect pieces
if white could land a Pawn on F5 protect
his Advanced E Pawn he's simply winning
so maybe push the pawn to F4 he actually
defends that pawn with his rook and the
eval bar slides slightly down
uh this idea I think is a dual purpose
threat firstly attacking Black's A6 pawn
and secondly creating that D6 Square for
the White Knight to hop back to and it
frees up the E4 Rook as well to go on
over to H4 but Fabby he backtracks with
his own rook and the A6 Pawn can be
captured so white will be a pawn ahead
but that black knight it survives it
goes up to C1 and then may back around
to D3 if Fabby could pick up that Knight
and place it on E5 to trade off a pair
of knights he will have better chances
but his not Knight's been offside it's
not a good piece and Magnus he maintains
this uh momentum and I just feel like
for Fabby every single move is so
challenging and to make it a good piece
Fabby thinks it's worth giving up upon
is Magnus going to allow Fab's Knight
back into play he is reaching out I
think for the Rook to capture that A6
Pawn but hesitates pulls back Magnus
does not look happy though he does not
look uh so convinced that it's totally
winning we see the eval bar but I think
it's deceptive as you know the stakes
are high if a set of Rooks disappear if
the knights ever disappear drawing
chances only increase so you need to
still continue being energetic and
accurate to maintain this Advantage he
tries to trade off the Rooks now because
that would allow the White Knight to
come back to more active squares the
White Knight ultimately is the one that
will remove the blockada of the E Pawn I
think this was a key move for Magnus
Carson yeah and that white knight will
not only jump to D6 but if black Rooks
Rook moves forward to E7 it will attack
it further from that F5 Square
eventually getting that that E6 Pawn
rolling down the board Fabby cannot
afford to let that happen side steps
with the rook and The Rook is back on
the seventh rank Knight D6 once again a
threat on the board that's the killer
blow for Fabiano the death now because
he wants to bring his Knight back into
B3 he does just that but once you get
Knight D6 in here the the only thing
that Magnus need to care about is if
that black knight gets a C5 that Forks
both of his Rook so Rook C1 check
followed by Knight C5 at some moment
unfortunately after Knight D6 his Rook
on8 is under it attack so I don't think
he's going to survive this one oo watch
out this a threat of a draw right now
Perpetual check Black Knight if it comes
down to F1 checks the white king and uh
the white king cannot escape and Magnus
with a headshake he was not expecting to
move Knight to D2 he thought he had it
in the bag when he played Knight D6 and
a Fabby throws a curveball with this one
big threat he's lucky he's still winning
Magnus Carson after missing this nasty
sneaky move the white Rook is attacked
but you cannot move it if you move the
white Rook or if you capture the black
Rook draw on the spot the Black Knight
comes to F1 check forces the white king
back and we'll see a yo-yo the black
knight move discover check and uh this
dance will last forever Magnus needs to
give some space to his King it's the
type of move that completely rattles a
player you can see Magnus he needs to
regroup right now and just like
yesterday when he's one who sacrificed
his Queen Fabiano finding a desperate
tribe but he pushes a pawn does Magnus
Carlson he trades off a pair of Rooks G7
is now loose so Magnus despite the
initial shock he still found the best
continuation that's where having time on
the clock is such a lifesaver here
Fabiano simply doesn't have enough time
down to just over 1 minute we're only at
move 33 increment a distant dream it's
going to be a race on the clock even if
he weren't losing this position but it
does unfortunately look like that white
ewn is going to decide matters wh King
now given enough air to survive on its
own it will take care of itself the
other white pieces will get job uh get
the job done and okay he's sliding
behind good try from Fabiano trying to
put his Rook behind a pass Pawn that's
what we're taught in all positions but
it's just collapsing the G Pawn is now
up for grabs but don't take it with the
Rook because if you take that pawn with
the Rook the king steps the side hitting
the Knight on E8 the Knight can't move
because the it's the only piece
defending that Rook over there so Magnus
still has his work cut out for him fiveo
creating a challenge but now that pawn
is one square away from promotion and I
think it's going to get to the other
side and Magnus gson taking his time
this could very well be Fabiano R's very
last moments in the Champions Chester
final and you can see it in him and
Magnus knows he's close to victory in
this one Fabby pushes the F Pawn is
there a night jump Knight moving to C7
do you do you have the path right now to
get that E Pawn to E8 perhaps although
the Black Knight goes back to F6 and
holds things for now that's why Fabiano
has vacated the F6 square with this Pawn
thrust but it is desperation Magnus
doesn't need to break uh kind of this
formation actually black is stuck black
can barely move anything at all the
White Knight jumping out the way you can
play that at will later on U maybe he'll
play it now maybe he'll move the Knight
he can even take the G7 Pawn if you want
to be really flashy with the white
knight but uh I'm expecting Magnus to
just take a calm approach not allow any
counter play or any tricks at all 5
minut is down to 42 seconds and this may
be the last 42 seconds of his entire
event here if he loses he's eliminated
look at that move G5 taking away that
Knight's backtrack beautiful move from
Magnus Carlson there just removing any
defensive hope at all yeah look at
Fabiano in pain oh he's got no time
simply under 30 seconds now oh and I
think he's just coming to terms with
everything that's happening because it
is not just about losing this game
Fabiano Carana will be eliminated he
will be knocked out of the Champions
chest off finals he takes a break he
does pick up the pawn but now that
Knight will not jump back to F6 to guard
that E Pawn from promoting there's a
check on F3 but I think it's only a
check and Magnus needs to pause
calculate he does it he realizes that
Knight F3 is just a check grabs that G7
pawn and it's handshakes Fabiano Carana
is eliminated Magnus Carlson stamps his
ticket to the finals and what a great
game there from Magnus he even missed a
tactic he was shaken but he was able to
regain his composure he eliminates
Fabiano karwana but congratulations are
in order to Magnus Carlson he moves
through to the finals without a third
set being necessary and you can see the
disappointment on Fabby it was quite the
start to the Armageddon he got the black
pieces he had enough time and he got the
opening that he was hoping for that
Magnus Carlson gets the job done and
there's a spring in his step yep he's in
the final he's relieved after a bit of
an up and down day but conratulations to
Fabiano who put up such a good fight
who's such a warrior beat Magnus several
times in this semi-final Clash over the
last two days and it's unfortunate he
had to go home yeah their day one had
five decisive games that saw Magnus
eventually win and day two Magnus takes
the lead against Fabby but Fabby Strikes
Back to take it to Armageddon but Magnus
with his end game end game touch do not
trade Queens against Magnus gets the job
done wins in the armagedon and he is our
first finalist who will play Magnus
Carlson to fight for Championship will
it be nbec Abdus satro or will it be
Wesley so there is a big big set three
coming up with a lot at stake there's
more chest nobody should go anywhere
because we have more chess ahead of us
today and while Magnus Carlson he
deserved to make his way through to the
finals as David said commiserations to F
Carana because very few people can force
Magnus into Armageddon two days in a row
when trailing in the match winning on
demand Fabi Carana prove to everybody
and hopefully himself that he can hang
tough with Magnus Carlson yeah and
Magnus Carlson that in the end did
eventually take the end game and it was
just due to Fabiano not having enough
time on the clock to find the correct
defense in what was a tricky position
and I wanted to highlight one moment
that Fabiano went a bit wrong he let in
equal position slip out of his hands it
was tricky uh we will add that he had
sacrificed a pawn earlier wied up here a
pawn and there's an attack against F7 he
reacted very naturally with Pawn to F6
but if instead he'd first played the
move Knight to D3 attacking a bunch of
Pawns and attacking this white Rook he
might well have been able to hold the
game Robert earlier mentioned E6 the
best try here for white but if for
example The Rook had moved then simply
Knight takes pawn and a level position
this would have at least gave him a
safer position better chances but
unfortunately after F6 white was able to
keep the pawn alive first with a threat
and then pushing the pawn to
E6 so close and yet so far for Fabiano
Karana he had almost equalized that
position and got that draw but in the
end it is Magnus Carlson who makes it to
the finals and we've got more chess
coming up as we will have set three
between nbec and wesle so and our crew
in Toronto is ready to take it away he
is with our first finalist and we'll be
right back with Magnus
[Music]
Carlson I am beyond excited to announc
on February 23rd through 25th we will be
hosting the first ever
chess.com
Invitational presented by Discraft at
the famed course in Brooksville Florida
we will be kicking off this year's disc
golf pro tour in style with not only
incredible disc golf but many more
activities there will be a one-of-a-kind
chess disc golf crossover you won't want
to miss as well as an exclusive
chess.com fan Zone I personally couldn't
be more pumped to bring epic disc golf
competition and fun hope to see you all
[Music]
there it doesn't look like much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
hello so this is where the magic happen
happens and this is where all the magic
has already happened yes that's a good
way of putting it that's my world junior
I 87 it's difficult to tell you how many
doors that open for me and what uh what
historical moment it was and when I got
back the chess
Oscars very nice these five of them of
the W five and there's one on top that
is the sixth one so since he had already
got five they didn't want to give him
the same trophy so they gave him a
trophy of a king with the world in his
hand this is anand's first ever
mentioned in a newspaper oh so this is
his first ever was mentioned V Anand
achieved a national record by winning
all the nine rounds to notch a maximum
of nine points in the sub junior
Championship but imagine now TS ri's
daughter Akita is part of the West PJ
chess Academy I mean it's so beautiful
to see how you know life comes around so
World rapid chess and mind Champion so
this was nit gave me this nice prob why
do I get the feeling that ARA knows all
the trophies and why you want better
than you remember it cuz I cleaned the
because it's true because this
true did you have a favorite thank you
so much Anand I feel this is extra
motivation for all the youngsters this
opportunity to actually come here and
witness these achievements and spend
time with you in this stunning room
Anand ARA thank you so much for
[Music]
this a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
we are here in Toronto the first
finalist is now known surprise surprise
it's Magnus Carlson the number one
player in the world he defeats Fab on
Carana for the second day in Armageddon
Magnus you heard everyone talking out
there people were rooting for chess it
was like a predictions right in front of
you that uh you heard us rooting for
Fabby a little bit we wanted more chess
and you spoiled it you sent him home I
didn't no I didn't hear I didn't hear
that uh I mean I I always I'm that way
myself like watching
if games can go to overtime I always
root for that I usually root for
underdogs so you're not holding it
against us no of course okay yes okay
we're good no no we were but I was
joking because you walked in and we were
all like me Wesley and Maxine were like
well we're all rooting for Fabby we're
rooting for more chess and you walked in
and it it was pretty funny but anyway
man talk a little bit about this match
obviously Fab's a beast not many people
can beat you in Rapid chess he he beats
you several times in this match overall
you did get the job done obviously in
Armageddon but talk a little bit about
carwan if you don't mind and just how
how tough this one was yeah he's really
um he's really strong so it didn't feel
like I was ever out playing him much I
was mainly holding on and to be fair
like
um yeah he could easily have won this
match like there's no doubt about that
with the chances he had that he could
have won this match so yeah managed to
pull through felt that he was really
nervous in the Armageddon now
um uh but um but yeah I mean of course
he's he's extremely uh he's extremely
strong and uh yeah not not an easy guy
to um to kick did you really have no
idea what you were going to write down
for the Armageddon like we were all out
there discussing if it was genius if you
wrote 10 000 cuz you knew he was going
to bid 958 or but then you answered like
I had no clue I just wrote something and
yeah I was just pissed after the
game I I had no idea what to write
really so
uh I did like the most my brain was able
to process with that he wrote like 958
or something or 9 no no sorry like 10:01
or 10:02 or something yesterday so I
thought I'd go a few seconds lower which
is like the
most basic it's like if your opponent
did um rock the last time you'll do
paper you think you'll do it again so
yeah uh no there was not much thought
into it but I've been I mean I've been
struggling so hard with black today that
I yeah that I thought I'm I was not
unhappy to to play White congratulations
you made it to the final so you got the
minus 10 on the goals we won through
there um of course maybe having some a
little bit of fun of obviously in
Toronto too the B3 thing are we gonna
see that in the final one3 yeah I don't
know I I don't know about that but I I
haven't uh I haven't thought about it I
would say there was there was one really
big
moment during this Armageddon I I think
first of all he did fine from the
opening he was doing well then we
exchanged queens and he pushed the pawn
which was a little bit risky I think he
could have done other things uh but
anyway the key key moment was after I
played Bishop G5 it took it took and
after F6 I almost went E6 mhm cuz I was
absolutely sure that he' play play
Knight D3 instead of
um instead of F6 so I was so shocked
that I I almost like played you almost
touched the wrong piece yeah I almost
touched the wrong piece cuz I was in my
mind he' already played Knight D3 and
then I looked at the board I was like
this is this is F6 which I thought was
not a good move yeah uh or at least yeah
it would give me great practical chances
so
um yeah it tells you something about
like some sometimes we're just way too
like locked in on something and might be
too philosophical I don't mean to butt
in but for second item on your list of
accomplishing you know you had the B3
and the minus 10 what what is fun for
you in chess like how do you have fun
it's just winning fun like game is fun
what is fun when you feel flow in the
game that helps a lot uh and uh to be
honest like there was no flow in these
games like fa is too good uh um so uh
yeah there was little little flow I mean
winning is winning is fun but
um um yeah fun equals winning with flow
okay you you you talked about the
emotion you had going right from a lost
to Armageddon you don't have time to
collect your thoughts we obviously see
this in online formats a lot right where
you just have so many games to play you
don't have time to collect yourself if
if the momentum is going wrong right and
now here we have an over theboard format
that is also very very fast right you
don't have time from a lost Norm again
do you like this do you like the idea of
it of it being in a in a way that maybe
challenges the emotions the sporting
elements kind of the uh the toughness in
that or are you like hey I actually in
those moments would would have preferred
a moment to take a
breath honestly
um there seems to be some issue every
time that we're about to start the game
like I always get like two more minutes
three more minutes like it always seems
to take longer than it was supposed to
originally and good or bad when I've
lost the game big game I just want to
like take couple of minutes maybe go to
the
bathroom but and have a little bite but
that's it then I just want to you want
to play yeah I just want to play yeah
well I mean we got to we got to fix the
format guys I mean makes sense I mean I
I don't think he's saying that I think I
understand what you're saying know but
at least if you're uh do you do you feel
like you play a little better if you're
a little on edge what is the best Magnus
right that's a great question H I really
think the best Magnus is when I play um
with confidence without fear when I take
um take risks um that's that's when I
when I play the best yep well are we uh
are we going to have the the best Magnus
tomorrow you you you're feeling better
you feel like you started off today yeah
I mean I I in general felt a lot better
today than the last couple of um couple
of days so you know uh hopefully that
Trend can continue and fbby is really
strong so I'm not too unhappy with the
way that I played today um in general I
just face a strong opponent
and yeah another time he might have um
definitely Nick this one last chance I I
got to ask it I think it's the normal
sporting thing to do you get to pick
your opponent at this point so or Notre
Beck who you
picking
um probably
um probably not back is but I
mean they both have great moments and
they both have extremely vulnerable
moments so it's very hard to say I mean
from game to game you cannot predict
what is happening next like it's there
seems to be a lot of nerves so I have no
idea what's going to yeah what's going
to happen there and I think Notre Beck
like getting that win with black I think
is was important he saw that Wesley was
vulnerable even today uh so I don't
think he'll be
um feeling any less confident confident
than usual before the um yeah the the
third match all right well we're going
to see we're going to be watching with
as fans hopefully you'll be watching too
but congratulations man good luck
tomorrow thank you enjoy your night and
uh we we'll see you then there's our
first
finalist punching his ticket and this is
uh this is what it took for him to get
there a couple of 3-2 victories over
Fabian o Carana in Armageddon and like
Magnus said this match in some ways
could have gone either way right Fabby
did have his chances and uh just was
unable to get it done in some of those
big moments and that's why Magnus
Carlson is usually the last guy standing
cuz he does tend to get it done
in those most dramatic moments but all
right Fabiano is with Kaa talking about
the loss and his experience here in
Toronto he has given it an awesome fight
but it ends here in the CCT finals for
Fabiano how are you feeling right now
pretty disappointed uh I think I had a
good position in this last game I just
uh rushed a little bit when I probably
took on C3 or took on F5 I mean I should
be completely fine in that position um I
thought that I I thought I was okay
after night B4 when I took on C3 I Me
Maybe it's already unpleasant after Rook
C1 but yeah I rushed at at some moment
in the opening um and uh and then I got
un Pleasant end game probably very
dangerous end game and I don't know
maybe I could have defended it better
but it it started to look really
dangerous and N yeah looked looked like
a bad position do you feel though with
game four here especially that you do go
out with
style yes it doesn't really matter I
guess uh how how you lose um I left a
lot of chances on the table so I I do
have some regrets for sure what has been
uh your highlight from the CCT finals
2023 well I I enjoyed it overall quite
uh quite a bit but um yeah I don't know
maybe I'll when I reflect back I'll I'll
uh have a bit more perspective now it's
just a bit um disappointing I know
you're very disappointed right now but
can I get your predictions for uh uh
what will happen here now with Wesley
and order backck first of all I think
most likely we'll see Magnus against
Wesley in the final but anything can
happen now Fabby what's up for you in
the next uh few weeks here I'll play the
world rapid and Blitz championship and
before that I have some rest but not a
whole lot so it's about 10 days from now
and obviously uh there will be a
candidates tournament Happening Here in
Toronto um in some months do you feel
that you will come here with a good
feeling oh I I have to prepare quite a
lot for the the tournament and I suspect
candidates will be very tense but I am
looking forward to it Bobby thank you so
much for all the entertainment and for
your thoughts here in the mix Zone thank
you that was Fabiano caruana for you
back to you
guys there you see your heart goes out
to Fabio Carana not many people can take
Magnus Carlson to two Armageddon and
really have his chances but Bobby did he
couldn't quite hold on Magnus is a
little bit more accurate not even a full
point wow wow your thoughts on that look
how close that that chess was I mean
it's tough you know you can feel for
Fabby there cuz he's like bro I'm
getting I'm like this close like I'm I'm
here Danny I'm here but then you're not
at the end of the day it's really tough
it's really tough to see I mean we just
saw world number one versus number two
okay I mean guess that's what we should
get right admittedly classical chess
that you could call that the real F it's
like when uh when the top two have to
play in the in any semi in any knockout
type of event that could have been our
final match no your versus Wesley could
have been you know like but but this is
the reality and unfortunately for
Fabiano uh his road has come to an end
in the most brutal way two Armageddon
back to back yeah and you saw him just
kind of say like hey right now right now
I'm not shaking this one off maybe
everyone else expects me to lose to
Magnus but he doesn't go into those
matches expecting to lose to Magnus he
knows he can beat Magnus and again we
were a game in each match from it going
the other way as Magnus said so how do
you build on that I guess yeah you know
uh I think taking obviously this
experience and going into his next
tournaments with you know a clear head
if you saw Dennis got knocked out and
then one title Tuesday like who does
that just lose to everyone or lose my
matches and then Crush everybody else in
title Tuesday so I think he'll be in
good spirits actually after he lets it
settle in go and get prepar for the next
tournaments I I I say that Fabiano takes
the loser of Wesley versus Norbeck and
just like grabs him we playing for third
like we're not getting no third and four
split there is no he's like we're
getting a bronze medal match up on the
stage we should have done I mean damn
but that's not a bad
idea that and Fab's going to suon right
he's playing in the world yeah he's
planing to yeah yeah so he has a chance
to still grab a medal and potentially
have a good event yep and I'm just I I'm
a Fabby fan I'm biased I hope ends the
year strong and maybe Fabby will be with
us in the show tomorrow I think he's
hanging out for the weekend so stick
around if you're a Fabby fan a lot of
people do love his commentary I'm sure
we'll get him on the show but all right
Wesley so has earned a lot of new fans
every time he seems to to smile or laugh
or down in some content whether it's
white elephant or some sort of Rapid
Fire uh he and I decided to to have a
little bit of a challenge a little bit
of fun and I played blindfold Blitz with
him he's blindfolded not me here's
here's a quick preview of what happened
it's pretty much impossible these days
to think of challenges that are
difficult for Wesley so but we're going
to we're going to try to come up with
one right here right now which is that
we're going to play blindfold blitz so
I'm actually going to get up right now
and I'm going to Blind fold him all
right this is you know nothing weird is
going to happen here trust me there you
go close your eyes right no funny
business are you going to move the
pieces for I'm going to move the pieces
for you so all you got to do is just say
the move and I'm going to move the
pieces for him and we're going to see
how this goes are you ready yes I'm
going to start your clock you just say
your move and hit your clock so okay
play one B3 okay okay so he plays B3 I'm
going to play Knight F6 Bishop B2
[Music]
G6 Knight
F3 Bishop G7
F4 F4 yep yes yes yes indeed he got a
good position all right Knight takes D4
Queen takes D4 check Knight to F6 Queen
E3 I think you're doing great just so
you oh thank if you're worried yeah
thought it looks like a very boring
position give me your best Danny I'm
um to my best but suddenly I'm lacking a
little bit of a plan let me think here
why am I struggling so much with the
right thing to play here um my plan now
is just to try to flag you yeah which is
first of all a genius plan queen to V6
yeah I think Mo I have 2 minutes and 24
seconds you have 4 minutes and 45
seconds may I should I'm giving you a 10
minute right all right I know I know I'm
old and slow on all those things you're
not for to
hit all right I'm going to play Rook to
d8 I'll
play
Rook
fd1 you play a lot of good chess moves
has anyone ever told you
that no h hold a freaking draw here come
on di all right rotate you one yeah Rook
takes
Rook I got to do what I need to do to
win you got to do what you got to do to
win they respect it Knight to F6 ah what
are you doing you're training something
oh I know I
mean I was like uh King to
E3 why did you have to see it it was
one Rook to D Rook to D1 D D1 yeah I
feel you Daddy okay
ah you have 2 minutes and 15 seconds all
right I got a you're turning something
uh I'll say rope to
C4 okay Bishop to
D5 I play Rook the Fe
three Wesley this is your chance to
blunder you can do it Rook to
g1m push
A5 no more mate Rook to G1
I'll
play B
E4 oh was an accurate move Bishop to a
B7 okay I'm just kidding I like going on
A8 I can't do I can't take advantage of
a blind
man I'm getting M I'm getting M King to
G7 H why why are you running that was a
good move by me it's not over yet Knight
E8
check I'm going to play the most boring
to
F7 Arrow takes mishop A6 it Wesley yeah
King takes E8 King King
E6 King to f8 all King to
F6 oh wow that hurts actually that's a
big time oh I lost on time that was a
big time I lost track of time wow good
game I almost feel okay about myself
almost yeah you're doing good for your
first game after a long time yeah yeah
all right well thank you for your time
thank you D best of luck in the rest of
the week we'll let you go get some
dinner I got to get some dinner thank
you so much Danny we'll talk later than
sure you guys think you would beat him
in that same
format uh probably not but I do better
than you 80% accuracy same same I feel
no the problem is he played this like
stupid B3 thing like play some Mainline
stuff yeah you wimp what are you you you
you abs come on Wesley he purposely took
me to some stupid positional chess I
don't have time for that nobody has time
for B3 what wow you 80% though not bad
yeah well speaking of Wesley he also
played 1 B3 against Notre backck and
that got the job done in their first
game first game of that match and uh I
don't mean to butt in but I'm absolutely
going to but in like that that 87.5% I
really feel like from Norbeck was that
first game that B3
game without that game I feel like he's
back over 90% that was a crazy first
game I don't know what happened there
but clearly really thrown off by that 13
unironically I guess Wesley was inspired
by
his I didn't even make that connection
but you're right right worked against a
lot of people feel better about
themselves when they when they beat me a
chess feels like a really big
accomplishment let that
sit let that sit
theet that anything about beating me
inspired Wesley but he did Play 1 B3
successfully against Notre Beck we'll
see does that again in this in this next
match up but all right we're going to
get to previewing this next matchup here
in just a second but before we do wanted
to uh a lot of you saw Paul MCB Beth if
you don't know that's the goat we're
here with the goat Magnus Carlson the
goat of disc golf I said it I'll stand
by it Paul McBeth for those of you who
maybe play might be wondering why in the
world is chess.com involved in a dis
golf tournament well um it kind of came
about organically and accidentally and
I'm going to I'm going to let the video
explain kind of how we got ourselves in
that stick situation and then we'll see
you on the other
side ah what a beautiful
day what in the
world chers is attacking they're
[Music]
everywhere we have to
fight take that
Checkers hey what are you doing
those are my
discs do you work for Checkers no I work
for disc craft why are you attacking me
I'm not I'm here at a disc golf course
throwing
discs those aren't Checkers no these are
prototypes of new discs for Paul mcbath
and you're in my way and you ruined a
bunch of
them who's Paul MC Beth oh my gosh Paul
man first of all of all I'm a huge fan
second of all I am so so sorry the green
pond can get a little out of control
sometimes and uh well you know honestly
in his defense there's a very long
history between chess and checkers that
I I could tell you about if you if
you've got a few a few hours Danny I
really don't have the time right
now okay no yep I get it I feel you on
that um can we can we replace the
discs right now with the holiday Seas
and the disc cting thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars I don't
think there's much you can do okay um
there's got to be something man
anything actually I think there is
something chess.com is a proud sponsor
of the inaugural chess.com Invitational
presented by Discraft join Paul McBeth
and chess.com Danny and Eric from
February 23rd to the 25th in Brooksville
Florida this is the disc golf tournament
you don't want to
miss so disc golf huh yeah it's like you
take a disc and you're just
like so that's basically what you do can
I try I mean
sure yeah it's like that but you're like
trying to throw to like that basket
hundreds of feet away it's not like that
I
mean
I mean not really you kind of want to
like you want to like behind you you
want to like explode through it's
like okay kind of like
that yeah
okay oh my gosh did they all go in like
that that was amazing Pals
[Music]
work first of all check out the special
effects in that video you see I mean
unless you believe I actually made it
that far is that classified as a real
sport disc golf yeah it is that's crazy
so either have you played disc golf
regular golf in fact regular well no
that we like to call it stick golf
you're discriminating okay it's disc
golf and stick golf I am not about to
get canceled play Real Sports guys Real
Sports
okay fun fact Eric and I are huge huge
fans of disc golf we we do want to
continue to have chess grow into other
communities Magnus is actually a disc
golf player and I'm not going to out the
family member but he has a relative who
is actually one of the top disc golf
players in Norway just in the family
this just we'll see whether whether
Magnus and and and anyone else can can
make it to that that event in Florida
but um anyway it's going to be epic so
shout out to the dis Golf Community Paul
MC Beth and anyone who thought that was
the weirdest collab of all time it's
pretty much a personal selfish thing but
all right let's get personal real quick
before we send it back to Oslo you're
handsome two game oh wow yeah well you
said let's get personal you look super
good
sorry okay two games now okay so Notre
Beck uhuh y I'm not going to make you be
on the spot with a prediction but your
thoughts real quick about what what
we're about to see well the momentum is
obviously in Wesley's uh favor but again
I'm just going to go back to the fact
that before the semi-finals I said
Wesley is going to win the match now
momentum is on his side he's also
probably the better straightup rapid
player by this much but it doesn't
matter he chose ner Beck can we we're
not going to forget that he chose nck
nck punched him in the mouth first not
actually as far as we know Wesley struck
back he's still a slight favorite in my
opinion we're better to see who's Jo
Magnus I agree in fact I think uh Wesley
actually when you know what did they say
when Magnus has more games it's harder
to play against Magnus I think with
shorter it's going to be harder to play
Wesley in fact just having two games
there qub is going to have to bring his
best and Wesley is doing everything I
mean he got B3 you got B3 right so two
games right I do think we're getting
Armageddon think you think I'm hoping
for Armageddon we're hoping for the most
chess possible I think I I I would agree
I also picked a Carlson so fin him when
we did that but at the same time Magnus
made a great Point as my earpiece pops
out that's live TV I can hear you there
in Oslo I can hear you uh Magnus made a
great point which is Notre Beck wasn't
upset before emotionally when he lost to
Fabby and then rebounded to beat Hikaru
so the kid seems to have the stuff when
it matters most we'll see if he does it
this time on that note we're going to
throw across to Oslo y'all are ready to
take it away I just use y'all
correctly oh we saw that uh video Danny
and did y'all enjoy it but my first
question to you is did you really get
that out of if it's called a hole-in-one
in dis golf or was that special
effect I'm going to let the uh we'll
leave that one to mystery going to let
the dis golf speak for itself let the
dis I'm going to let the dis Lev's going
to retire on that when he's going to
walk off camera there he's going to let
the disc golf speak for
itself uh yeah there it is that's a
replay look at that the
Bri I mean the
trajectory I think the trajectory of the
disc kind of go ahead
yeah the editing was great we'd never
know if Danny actually got that one in
or not uh but right now the big question
for nck and Wesley can they get
themselves in into the finals and who
will it be it's a set three It's the
final set and this time it's a best of
two if it remains a thigh it goes into
Armageddon today one thing's clear it
was Wesley so who dominated set to he he
dominated the entire day against
nck all the games but nck has so much to
take away from yesterday as well where
he was the one who was just crushing
through yeah nck played a great set one
a day ago today in set two didn't start
his way hopefully he learns that if the
position looks a little bit shaky he
doesn't have to go all in there's only
two games we'll see who's in better form
heading to set three start and uh here
we see nck in great spirits as he takes
his seat and hey guys can we changing
the chairs thank you more chair drama
great chair quality out there in Toronto
nck now just wow switching things up
we're getting some help it's the most uh
Manpower I've seen having to move one
chair in any tournament Hall if anyone
out there wonders what goes on in venues
this is it we're playing cherami or
something you know I don't really know
what's happening there but the players
they may be a little bit superstitious
they have their preferences and those
chairs they're pretty bulky they they're
good for your back good support solid
secret lab chairs right there so uh
they're choosing they're choosing their
chairs they've also got to choose their
openings and it's going to be so much
about who gets their kind of positions
because we saw in set two Wesley just
seemed to get really good outcomes uh
from the very start of the game yeah
Wesley start with B3 he mixed it up
because he said he wasn't impressed with
the positions he was getting out of
playing a Kings Pawn opening but not to
his credit he struck back in game three
down two to nothing he played a really
nice game three with the black pieces so
he's showing that even when it looks
like he's about to lose a match he could
still climb back yeah back to B3 or will
it be back to the Kings porn for Wesley
so who takes his seat glasses are off
players just getting that PO now they
look ready to go and we're ready to go
here as well o it all comes down to this
part and look at that death stat the
games haven't even started but NC
playing the Mind Games looks like he's
ready for that chess boxing match but
this will all be settled on the chess
board Wesley no more B3 Cowboy for him
he's back to his King Pawn opening but
which King Pawn opening will it be no
more scotch game which led to that
disaster in game three it's back to the
Italian maybe inspired by Fabiano
karan's success in this opening against
Magnus Carlson and Black's Knight comes
out the two kns defense here against the
Italian provocative stuff and look at
Wesley he was eyeballing his opponent
there and he goes in oh hoping for the
fried liver attack what will we see
Black's Knight Dodges there was a poison
porn in the center we see a quick trade
but this is a porn Sacrifice from nbec
aboro and not one it can be I was going
to say another Pawn can be given up if
the queen moves up to F3 but a different
opening approach he does retreat with
the bishop the fried liver attack it
promises to have Madness on the board
very very early on what do you think is
going to happen will who is better
prepared here Robert in this opening
right now D wasn't expecting it I don't
think he's pausing he's calculating and
these players they study their fellow
top players games woo Knight G4 jumping
out the Knight on G5 is not protected so
that Knight likely has to move away from
its current Square uh but what I was
going to say is that they studied their
fellow uh competitors games and hikaro
Nakamura has played the white side of
this position many times in important
battles so Wesley he moves his Knight
away it's going to be a real sharp game
because black has given up a pawn but
White's moving those minor pieces
numerous times at this stage and he's
got to move them some more because very
often in these position black marches up
the board with that F Pawn it's all
about trying to create play compensation
peace play for that sacrificed Pawn F5
is on the cards and David it can happen
now it can happen now it most likely
will happen now one thing I should
mention is that two years ago on the
Champions chess tour Wesley so was
playing this quite consistently he even
played this variation with the bishop
back to D3 against Magnus Carson and got
a huge Advantage Wesley so created a
Chesser bow course in 2021 and it was
about this variation we talk about the
top players doing their uh research and
wow F5 on the board a quick flurry some
Knights disappearing black going for the
white king the F2 Pawn now is a big big
Target who cares about the pawn
structure which is crazy black is Pawn
down but he's going on the attack
clearly notb back doesn't care about his
Pawn structure that is this strangest
spawn formation I've seen on the board
we are on move 12 and look at black
spawns I would never play in this
fashion with either color it looks too
risky black has currently a pawn down
but there are so many open files and
diagonals you see that dark squore
Bishop that just developed it's staring
at the F2 Pawn the golden Pawn right in
front of the white king white is not
castling kingside in this position not
when the H files also opening up so
Wesley needs to be extremely precise I
actually think that Wesley he goes wrong
he could be losing in just a few turns
but if nybeck doesn't know how to
continue here and keep this initiative
he is down upon PA after all and his the
rest of his Pawn structure is shattered
look at Wesley's body language here he
was shaking his head quite noticeably
for a while then a bit of a kind of
brush of the brow there now he's uh just
nervously looking at his position
eyeballing his opponent there he is
flued this was a surprise Knight to G4
it's a known move but it very rarely
happens at the top level and if you
haven't researched this recently if you
haven't refreshed your mind haven't
looked at what the computer suggests
here as Robert says it could be knockout
within a few moves you have to be super
accurate here you're treading a fine
line as white he brings his KN out as
far as I know one of the main moves and
uh How Deeply does nbec know this
position and that's the big question
Wesley is the first one to Spring the
surprise with Knight to G5 the fried
liver attack but not about counter
surprises Wesley with his own night a
couple of moves later jumping on to G4
getting this absolute chaotic position
Wesley makes a developing move the E4
Pawn currently hanging also so much
tension on the king side with the hline
open Black's Rook pin behind the H5 Pawn
strategically Black's in terrible shape
right he goes Queen D4 Checkmate in one
is threatened now Wesley castles and his
next move if F2 doesn't come under any
more fire he wants to push his Pawn up
to D3 and develop his dark Square Bishop
he desperately needs to get more pieces
into the defense now after the castle
Kings said the F2 Pawn is hanging once
more Queen E1 slide that Queen over
bring all of your pieces defending the
pawn and only then push your Pawn to D3
I think Wesley knows this quite well
yeah Wesley pausing but he does
eventually play the only move in that
position the key move sliding across
defending stuff with his Queen and
earlier Robert you name dropped Eric
Rose and the Stafford Gambit this looks
like a variation of the Stafford Gambit
it looks like white is about to get
checkmated but if you hold things
together long term it is worth some uh
worth suffering for you do have extra
material potentially you do have all
those targets so it's all about this
initial storm if white survives most
likely Wesley will win longterm if not
we might see a quick miniature finish
Abdu sattorov pausing here slight
surprised that he's pausing because he
was the one who initiated this craziness
by throwing the Black Knight to G4
surely he knows what's going on with
black and it is up his alley it is his
style he's looking away maybe he's just
choosing between two promising moves
here and eventually he takes the pawn so
level material yet again but it's all
the double pawns isolated Pawns in the
world for black and it does give white
the time to play your move Robert but
the ugliest Pawn structure I think we've
ever seen like there are two sets of
double isolated pawns on E file and G
file then we have the isolate A and C
Pawn so it's really a hideous structure
for black but after D3 which was
necessary from White you can take this
Pawn on D3 and in the very near future
there is going to be G4 to G3 exploiting
the pin on this dark Square dagle maybe
you could play Rook takes F2 first even
just to trade even more pieces Rook
takes F2 would be met by G three and
white escapes you can see the Eva bar
still hanging towards the center but
Black's getting rid of that really
horrendous Pawn structure yeah and uh
there we go he starts trading off just
before it's too late I wanted to
highlight this Pawn structure one
isolated pawn two isolated pawns doubled
isolated pawns double disolated pawns
yeah long term uh this is suffering for
black so do not try it at home unless
you know you're going to land a Killer
attack he does tradeoff and Moment of
Truth Wesley pauses will he take back
with a pawn the bishop or will he drop
his own Bishop in I don't think he
should actually go for this one because
black would sacrifice the queen and uh
here is too much material one Bishop
will fall yes the queen disappears but a
rook will fall with check and it's more
about counting here more about the maths
Bishop bishop and Rook for the queen too
much material Wesley continues with his
headshake not happy with the opening
outcome and I wonder if that has
something to do with the position that
we have or the fact that he was
expecting nbec would be surprised by his
opening choice but nck on the other hand
continues to Blitz out the moves and now
he's got to show more in this position
does he go for the sacrifice on F2
because you have to be quick long-term
nck doesn't survive this one Rook takes
Pawn is that the only way to go forward
I would definitely be playing with that
in mind because I want to liquidate and
get rid of My Double isolated pawns the
problem for notbe is even once the
Pieces come off there's still enough
Firepower left to go after Black's
remaining pawns they're all spread out
it's like bowling you never want to
split you never want pawns split like
this o this feels really not fun for
Nock and he's now spending some time
here because he wants to figure out do I
trade all pieces or do I have something
in this position going after the white
king we keep saying that it's not fun
for nck but there's only one guy on our
screen shaking his head and it's Wesley
so and what what's going on in his mind
because the position looks defended for
Wesley but awful for black and we see
nck is in with Rook takes spawn why is
Wesley constantly shaking his head in
this opening we've seen Wesley's recent
tweets or his posts on X we've seen him
in interviews he's trolling people it's
a red herring I don't think nobec should
read too much into the body language
here if Wesley didn't know what was
going on he would have spent 10 minutes
not just two three minutes so Wesley's
just trying to recall everything maybe
if he's shaking his head it's just about
the fact that he didn't kind of check
this line recently he hasn't analyzed
ized it with the latest engines or not
in the last few months at least but Rook
takes pawns on the board fireworks
Wesley has to defend accurately but is
he going to take this Rook back with his
own Rook or with the queen that's the
first question Queen's on or off the
board as nbec stretches looking
confident he's flexing right he's
showing that he's worked out he's just
getting in those uh those what the traps
and so you see that Rook takes F2 it's
setting up a bit of a trap because black
does want to push this Pawn to G3 and go
after the pin and look at this decision
from Wesley he gets all the pieces off
the board I get the feeling he still
knows what he's doing he may be shaking
his head grabbing his face all that
stuff I really think that Wesley has
studied this position and he might even
have more lines to go perhaps the
headshake is because he realizes that
nbec also knows exactly what he's doing
because it feels like he's managed to
equalize the position at least that's
what the bar says it's easy for us to
say but once again the position doesn't
look as easy as it looks and for now he
at least delays taking that F2 Pawn the
umbrella Pawn as you call it Robert
which keeps White's King safe so far in
the position not opening up the F line
for the black Rook to slide over yeah it
feels like one of those openings and
this is very common in uh modern chess
especially at the top level it feels
like a line where you test your opponent
you've both done the clicking you've
both checked the engine what the top
moves are you have to remember it of
course but if you both remember the game
does fizzle out towards a balanced
position but white is the one testing
black right now yes Black's got an extra
porn but Black's Pawn still ugly I'm
expecting Wesley to continue after a bit
more thought uh to kind of develop his
pieces once the white Bishop darkart
Square bishop and Rooker into the game
we will see a roughly level end uh end
game here and let's remind everyone it's
a best of two so this is Wesley's only
white in this match so perhaps uh just a
bit disappointed that he didn't get more
out of the opening than he was expecting
from the surprise and to break down the
action more we got reinforcements coming
coming in from Toronto as uh Dany is
being joined by Maxim Vash lra uh take
it away Danny this opening this outcome
of this what do you think uh will nck
hold his game one with
black thanks Sonia I'm gonna I'm going
to ask Maxine that question because he's
uh he's probably the one who has a
little more to say than I do in regards
to whether Notre will hold but I will
quickly say ites does look like Wesley's
a little frustrated maybe because Notre
Beck knew this line um and the fact that
the kid is up 2 minutes on the clock
doesn't help but Maxim we're going to
dive in and analyze this your thoughts
on what we see on the board before we
maybe talk about the story lines off the
board I think West Land opening surprise
very well uh I like his position I was
considering moves like okay First bishop
D2 of course get this Knight back to B7
yeah I
mean no or later and then Knight G5 to
avoid Bishop E6 okay create some threats
around the king but of course the
problem of doing that is this Pawn on F2
becomes very relevant so maybe it's a
bit too risky uh like Bishop G4 is
possible still for
black um yeah but in general of course
there are much safer ways to play for
Wesley like he can grab the pawn on F2
and is very slightly better but
um yeah he he can push somehow so so you
think Wesley it feels okay though about
his position right now
right now I think he feels okay it's
just trying to find if there's a way to
to push for an advantage like you can
play C3 first you can play many things
right um so do you think he feels
pressure in a two- game match to to push
here with white obviously Notre backck
has had some good victories is white so
well first of all I think is we gain
confidence after this first match of the
day yeah where he was dominant he had
did sleep in the third game but in
general it was like
uh clearly the best
player uh today and so you know I don't
think he feels bad at all if he if it
goes to a second game with black of
course when it comes to Armageddon it's
a different thing cuz it's all relies on
one single game so uh but he knows that
Noy Beck will go for for a full fight in
the second game and then um maybe he'll
try to make use of that but right now
he's looking is if he has something to
actually put pressure maybe something
like very direct C3 before A4 to to play
A5 um so just Pawn C3 Pawn B4 Pawn A4
and just try to advance on the queen
side yeah then I'm guessing A5 will
happen but maybe it's maybe it's a way
to go cuz then you can go
with um maybe black plays A5 though yeah
yeah yeah that's what I was saying maybe
you go some Bishop A3 somewhere like I
don't know because the bishop on B6
becomes also a little vulner a little
bit vulnerable I don't know it's a very
complicated position I must say like um
you can easily make mistakes if you if
you try to over push with white or with
black I like that even with the Queens
off the board that there's a lot of
complexities going here okay so we've
seen inside the crystal ball of a super
Grand Master's mind maybe some of these
variations will happen on the board for
fans but I want to ask you the same we
just asked Magnus I think a lot of us
saw Wesley as the favorite coming in for
a good reason a lot of people I think
feel that way but Magnus said he thinks
nottock recovered well the day before
and thinks not's you know in form right
now so who do you think is
uh we had this excussion with Magnus uh
I'm still going for
wle um well you're rooting for
Armageddon first and foremost of like me
CU more time on the couch out there of
course I was very disappointed that we
didn't get a sear set between M and
Bobby yeah yeah because we want more
chess we want more chess that's what
we're here for yeah uh but in general I
would
say uh so Magnus said that if feels
Wesley is a bit shaky so maybe he has
more inside because he's in the room
when when they're playing maybe he feels
uh more the tension that inab bits wesle
but yeah in general I feel
like um it should
be it should be the favorites it's funny
what do you think about magnus's
comments about when he said he think
both players have had great moments here
but both players have also looked
extremely vulnerable at times yeah I
think it's true for almost everyone
maybe besides Magnus or even Magnus you
think I would say Wesley was very
dominant in the one Robin
section um Magnus has been quite
dominant but against Fab didn't true he
had some moments yeah yeah yeah he
didn't show total control for sure so
yeah uh we'll see how it goes um like
wesler has been the most stable player
of the field but it's true that you had
this moments of um nervousness yeah okay
well there's a lot at stake here I
guess okay um I think Tanya is going to
going to chime in here go for it yeah
really uh cool insights there Maxim on
uh the psychology of the opening that
we're seeing but I've got one more
question for maxim Danny that we here in
the studio we've been talking so much
about NC's Death Stare just the way he
looks so confidently at his opponents
and I want to ask Maxim being on the
opposite side of nck has he what's been
his experience with that has is that
something that he's noticed about
nck t is asking about I was hoping you
say could you repeat please turn could
you repeat please turn yeah go ahead the
uh the Johnny no um Johny is asking what
it's like to play Notre Beck cuz they've
been talking in the studio about the
fact that he's very intense over the
board he's got a death stare he kind of
stares you guys down obviously you've
played a lot of intimidating characters
in your time but does that bother you at
all or what are your thoughts about
about uh the way he can really gaze into
his opponent's eyes in general during
games I very rarely look at my opponents
I'm completely un buzzed I'm focused on
my
play I might be looking at just
sit more than their faces you think
that's true for all players though or
may just me okay yeah y all right when
you're looking at the ceiling are you
like are you going full Beth Haron up
there like what are you looking at are
you thinking about what you had for
breakfast I can be thinking about any
sort of random thing like like a nich g
probably n all right well we're we're
having a good time here anything else
you want to say before we head back to
the couch and just
analyze um no I'm good okay you're doing
good good yeah all right we're going to
we're going to he's uh he's unfazed
exactly unbothered unbothered and we're
going to go back to the
couch and chill out we're going to throw
it back to you guys now
yeah that's we're going to do that's
what we're going to do all right bye
guys thanks guys uh unbothered unfaced
really interesting because I think when
you're playing against a guy like n you
need to do that you need to just block
out any sort of eye contact with him he
can be really scary and I saw him give a
little B bit of a stare once again there
I think the only thing making Maxim
uncomfortable was this conversation and
standing next to Danny so it was
successful in that regard they're going
to head back to the couch but for these
two players there's no taking it easy I
mean that King on H7 right now for nir
Abdu satarov it doesn't have too many
squares if you imagine a white Rook
landing on the H file it could fall
victim to a checkmating net that's not
out of the question and the bad Pawn
structure remains for black even
material but Black's pawns are worse so
I do prefer just like Max Team said
White's position I think Wesley has
chances in this end game definitely and
White's next few moves are
straightforward white would love to for
example land a rook on H1 as you say
Robert so maybe plant the King on E2 if
you want to focus in zoning on this E5
Pawn then you just shift your Rook to
the E file uh simple play there
beautiful Outpost for your knight if you
can land it and maybe even expand pawns
on the queen side for black it's far
less clear what you should be aiming for
you need to balance out the long-term
strategic deficiencies especially these
isolated pawns with Dynamic play active
play but how do you achieve that I was
looking for example at this knight jump
to try and hit the bishop but the bishop
just slides back with a check and uh at
the very minimum you just move your Rook
across pressure black is the one
certainly on the back foot and uh I
don't think nbec is his type of position
yes he's great in end games but this one
is far more static his weaknesses and
unless he can gain that energy that he
loves and uh make it more about
calculation then I think he's going to
struggle but we know not he's so good
when it comes to end games and right now
now though he has pressure and reasons
to be worried about but the kind of
endgame technique that he's been showing
in this tournament I'm not worried for
him in this one I definitely am worried
I just hate his Pawn structure and
something that people should remember is
that we like our Pawns in the center
during the early stages of the game
because they restrict the enemy pieces
but in the end game flank pawns can
actually be super dangerous because they
tie your opponent's pieces down to the
side of the board while you activate
your own pieces in the center and one of
the main moves we were just talking
about D was suggesting Rook over to E1
next to that white king very logical
going after this Pawn on E5 I just feel
like there's so many weaknesses that
black has to keep an eye on and for
nybeck here he's a great endgame player
but nobody would be comfortable playing
this from the black side all right so
nybeck needs to be a little careful a
little precise though he can start
thinking about his own play we know he
loves the initiative he does take out
the bishop The Rook eventually hoping to
land on the f file to try to put
pressure on that pinned eventually
pinned Knight on F do but uh first if
Wesley gets in the pressure on the E5
Pawn will he go passive with his own
Rook or is he expecting to continue more
development get that Knight to D6 hit
that Bishop on C4 is he going to look
for initiative in this one make it sound
easy Tanya that the black pieces can
flow forward and of course after to he's
an expert and making it look easy uh on
the board and I think you're right that
black knight will come in with gain of
tempo in the next few moves do you line
up uh the black Rook against the white
king first of all that's one question
not sure whether the tactics work out
there you need to calculate a bit very
minimum you just defend your ewn but no
he goes for that other option every move
with Tempo gain time hit the opponent's
loose pieces the Knight hitting White's
bishop and uh forcing it away to slide
back I think that Wesley can make a
quick move he's not playing this game
that quickly overall which I think is
worrying for him as his time trouble has
been really a problem in his match
against NC yesterday n was able to win
an endgame with the Evo was right at the
middle because Wesley was not able to
handle himself without too much time on
the clock but I think he can slide his
Bishop back to B3 next trade the dark
Square Bishops if he ever needs to by
putting that one on the E3 square and
Black's problems persist I'm not trying
to exaggerate the issue black should be
able to hold but should have would have
could have these are words that are not
so meaningful when we're talking about
Blitz chess which is the time control
we're about to enter and the one thing I
will mention today because it's going to
be a marathon day of Chess is that the
last time we had a day this long on the
Champions CH tour finals it was when
Abdu sator took down Nakamura just a
couple of days ago so he does have the
stamina if he can survive this game I
think he'll be feeling super confident
now that it's just a two game uh
shootout essentially uh I think this one
it's just important to survive with
black you don't want to get too
ambitious if you save this you move on
you have white maybe an Armageddon but
you younger you have energy I think he
might become the favorite if he
holds that's the big if and uh again I I
think he uh he would be able to do this
I see the pawn structure that you're
pointing at but I love The Bishop's
activity in this position The Rook
lining up on the F line but he decides
to First defend the ewn that can start
marching up the board and create threats
of his own right now NC doing everything
right and it's been quite a journey for
nbec from the start took him seven days
to get the visa done to get his travel
sorted to reach tono so stamina is
definitely not on his mind because he's
here a determined uh NC very determined
nck such a phenomenal player I think
it's hard not to root for him but Wesley
so has many fans out there as he trades
off those dark Square Bishops so um
minimal pieces remaining that may seem
like good news for not because white
can't attack the weak pawns without
pieces of his own so both players are
handling this very well whatever winning
chances Wesley hopes to have are in the
long term but in the short term it seems
like Norbeck with the lead on the clock
playing excellent chess and now he has
to worry about two different pawns see
Wesley he's poking and prodding yeah and
the good thing in this position for
black is that the White Knight doesn't
have too many squares to jump into the
game to start putting pressure on that
black E5 Pawn so Wesley has managed to
maximize his pressure with the Rook but
there isn't an another assistance coming
in to attack the weaknesses meanwhile
nbec his own Knight can start jumping
into enemy camp Knight C4 in the
air possibly yeah maybe he needs to act
uhgive ively and actively here because
suddenly you don't want to curl up and
be passive a big weakness on the C6
square and critical moment Wesley so
throwing a spanner in the works hitting
this Pawn your move Tanya I guess would
force the white Rook to decide do you
step back defend this Pawn do you slide
across with a check Suddenly It's
getting a bit tactical this check could
mean that you eat this Pawn you grab
this Pawn with gain of time next move
I'm not sure where the black king goes
but you can take this Pawn hit the black
Rook right now Rook C8 Rook C8 you have
to to do something with this bishop yeah
maybe it's working out for black uh
maybe this Pawn will simply drop next
move but this is what they're
calculating right now and uh the
alternative I guess for Wesley so there
is to just drop back defend and say how
are you defending this one not too easy
because the Rook might get overloaded he
does play Knight C4 does noty backck and
he's going to have a difficult next
choice because you bring a rook to C8
then you've lost sight of the E5 pawn
and I can kick your knight out of C4 go
right after that E5 Pawn thank you very
much for the material so these decisions
are really difficult for nck and that's
why I tell people at home that when you
have the eval bar it doesn't always tell
the full story because not's on the
defensive here and Wesley knows it he
knows it he gives a check not the move
we were thinking not keeping control
maybe he's calculated something maybe he
realizes that this Pawn is Juicy he
wants to by force snap it off the board
so a check and uh the black king has to
decide you normally don't want to go
towards the edge of the board ever in
chess and especially in an end game
where you want to be centralized I'm
assuming the black king will step
towards the center but the question is
what happens here is a tactic I think at
the end here Wesley wants to play Bishop
to B5 and after Knight takes B2 there's
Rook F3 and all of a sudden you're being
met by G4 or Rook takes F5 with Bishop
B7 check but no I'm wrong because Wesley
decides to go a different direction he
just pushes the pawn that was under
attack but there all sorts of tactics in
the air here wow suddenly getting really
really uh kind of concrete suddenly it's
not about these general principles that
we've been discussing it's about whether
black can kind of survive hold on move
by move especially this C6 pawn it might
just drop you do not want to go to the
edge of the board ever your knight will
simply be pinned here and stuck here
defending a mere porn so that's the last
thing on Abdus soro's mind right now
Knight attacked porn attacked and he's
on the back foot yeah NC doesn't Retreat
he doesn't go backwards so I want to ask
you a question is a knight to D2 a
possibility it gives a check but I can
very well end up getting trapped or
losing material also after giving a
check on D2 White's King will step
forward putting pressure on that Knight
The Pawn on C6 still hanging and I'm
trying to figure out do you move back
with the Knight to the center of the
board do you know what tells the biggest
story even more so than the moves that
are being played I'm looking at the
clock n der was up several minutes and
now he makes the wrong choice goes to
the edge of the board and Wesley at any
moment can push his B Pawn One More Time
Kick That Knight out of there to win the
C6 Zone but I like what Wesley is doing
he's not rushing he's not giving key
squares back to nybeck KN on the rim is
looking dim here and these pawns still
are a problem for black the Knight looks
dim the position looks Grim he's pushing
forward with his pawns but uh I always
talk about the theory of two weaknesses
in Middle games end games here black has
the horrible porn structure all of them
isolated now the second weakness is just
the placement of his night Wesley can
play against that long term he's happy
to trade off the other minor pieces
because if you compare the final pieces
is remaining uh the white Bishop will
always dominate this Black Knight on the
edge of the board so a check if this
Knight is not captured it will simply
slide back blockade Black's Central Pawn
this is really classy stuff from Wesley
so this is where he thrives and I still
think nck is really going to need
something special to save this game
that's really great technique there
because when you trade it's not just
about the pieces that you've traded but
what remains on the board and if you
compare the white Bishop to that black
knight it's clearly superior to the
Knight which will be on the defense but
also notb back does not have an option
he has to go for this bishop takes
Knight Rook takes Bishop there's still a
big threat of that B Pawn moving one
step forward and deflecting uh the
defender of the C6 Pawn B4 how do you
fight it and let's not forget that the
E4 Pawn is also on a light square and
white has a light Square Bishop so G5 is
a great choice from no dearbeck it
allows him to bring his King forward and
keep it attached to that pawn but Wesley
he's not going to rush love that move
Rook to G3 that Rook did not have much
real estate now it's gonna slide to the
H file that's a fully open line to work
with the white king can step forward at
any moment the Black Knight is not
participating right now it's merely a
defensive piece he's undaunted Wesley so
his Rook was a bit stuck there he's
simply going to take his time out here
dropping back he's going to reposition
his Rook repurpose it I mean this is
just so so tough for black to defend and
you can tell looking at the clock Abdus
t look at the body language as well
scratching his head he can barely find a
move there not that much productive to
do and sooner or later as soon as that
white Rook activates the threats will
increase so uh okay he activates his own
Rook trying to cut off the white Rooks
access to open files really clever move
there but now the black eorn has been
abandoned yeah there was so much
hesitation by nck before he made this
move so he's definitely feeling
uncomfortable in this end game and again
I've been talking about this idea of
just winning the C6 pawn and I'm trying
to get my head around why has Wesley not
already gone for B4 and Bishop takes
Pawn because sometimes the pressure is
actually the way to beat these top GMS
you can win a pawn then give them
activity he just stole the pawn at the
right moment so I love the way he's
played and no der does look
uncomfortable here he's trying to will
himself back in this game but he lost a
C6 Pawn E4 is now under attack white has
these outside pass pawns that he's going
to struggle to deal with he brings his
King forward maybe he wants to go
further even more but Wesley gives a
check so if the King goes forward Rook
G4 check will win the G5 pawn and look
how gal Wesley looks right now just say
body language and meanwhile n back with
the the peace toing you can tell that
you don't even have to look at the board
to understand what the evaluation is you
can look at the players and you know
what's going on then again a bit of a
scratch on the head of Wesley so and
he's repeated the position the second
time we've seen this again the second
time we've seen this position if Wesley
gives a check he might have the option
to repeat but he is a porn up surely
with white he should be playing for the
win he might be worried though because
if the black Rook can successfully slide
to d8 and it comes to D2 and that white
king is forced back to its first Rank
and that can be scary where you are up
material but your opponent who has the
coordinated pieces that Rook on G3 is
actually quite misplaced in this
position it doesn't have too much wiggle
room so nyback he loses upon Pawn I
don't even want to say he gave it up I
think Wesley outplayed him there but he
still has good chances yeah and Wesley
he has to decide ethical decision here
do you play for a win in a short two
game match with white a porn up but with
a bit of risk attached or do you take
the draw bail out now
safety get closer to that Armageddon he
gives another check second time we've
seen this position as well and he plays
on he plays for the win he's going for
it he wants more in this position Wesley
so is up upon PA and he's trying to get
the match advantage in this one the
bishop is attacked watch out Rook on
coming to D2 as well once the bishop
moves but this is clever stuff from
Wesley he repeated once then he spent
his time he can bring his Bishop to
attack the Knight the problem is if the
black Rook gives a check he first
protects his Bishop so look what he's
doing every sing single move he's
restricting Black's access I think
that's a nice try but it's clear the Eva
bar is not the biggest fan it says the
black is actually holding on can you
repeat here immediately with just the
king Shuffle keep attacking the white
trook I think Wesley has calculated well
there if the black king shifts over to
attack White's Rook the white Rook
slides to the center and look at the
black pawn in the center it will drop
off and once the white Rook takes it the
Black Knight will also be hit so
actually he's kind of setting a trap
here Wesley so if the black king moves
white would have had his decisive
Advantage instead the pawn pushes
forward a vulnerable square but closer
to promotion now the white Bishop is
really stuck you cannot move it out the
way because the black Rook will
penetrate will drop down to D2 with a
check you need to keep the black Rook
passive and I think this is a really
really important move from NC and my
question was going to be what's Black's
next move and Wesley he poses the same
question if you can't actually improve
your pieces let's go push those pawns up
the board and notc pushes his own Pawn
so now white has access to a pass Pawn
he can in fact take that pawn on A5 if
the Knight takes back down goes that E3
Pawn in the center he takes it more
pawns off the board but pawns on both
flanks more importantly so the bishop
better than the Knight and now can he
take on E3 can he take the black pawn
sitting in front of White's King if he
can he's simply two points up and should
win the game but perhaps that Bishop is
loose on D7 so tin his idea from earlier
King G6 just to kick that Rook out of
there so Wesley might Retreat his Bishop
now that Knight is on the rim so Bishop
back to B5 the E3 Pawn is still a
weakness maybe black has to go all in
but you look at the time right now
Wesley he's down about 40 seconds no
deck at 53 both players getting nervous
wow if Wesley so captures the pawn the
most natural looking move the black king
just follows the white rook and there is
no way to keep the B to keep uh the
pressure on for white and that one
Wesley needs to find a way to keep this
game going if it's not King takes Pawn
how does he keep the pressure he can't
move the bishop the black Rook will jump
in how do you continue the game I like
Robert's move move the bishop where you
control the Black Knight just keep that
Black Knight sidelined on the edge of
the board but he does take the pawn and
now will we see this dance between the
black king and the white Rook you have a
check on E6 but Wesley just repeating
and is he going to give a check on E6
next that's the big question and he does
give that check there's no reason that
he should just force a draw if the king
moves back that white Rook can attack
the Black Knight this is getting very
messy though because that Knight can hop
around with some checks was he need to
be careful at this stage yeah the white
Bishop is really stuck right now the
Knight is attacked but the Knight can
jump out the way with a check the Black
Knight has to save itself do not trade
off White's Bishop for that Knight white
is two pawns up and now the white King
has to walk into a pin attacking this
Black Knight but once the Black Knight
moves White's Bishop is it doomed but I
think he's giving up his Bishop he's
recognized that if I can trade Rooks I
can't lose that end game even though
black has an extra Knight white at the
very least can go to the king side and
steal that last G Pawn he's got pass
Pawns of his own so it's going to be a
counting game and no back down to 25
seconds is that a pawn too d dangerous
great practical decision from Wesley so
playing on testing nbec zero risk still
for white surely he's going to defend
his Bishop now Wesley so the white Rook
can step up one square to hold the
bishop for a move longer yes that Bishop
Falls but Robert your idea go for that
black pawn now white has still three
pawns remaining the Black Knight is a
short-range piece uh piece can it deal
with all three pawns wow and look at Nur
he just sets aside all the pieces and it
is go time for both these players as
Wesley saw he has two seconds on the
clock he's burnt so much time the good
news was it was a series of Trades quick
moves they gain three seconds per move
the Knight does chase this pawn and so
the question is can the Knight get back
in time if that were a bishop black is
holding because Bishops are longrange
pieces but that Knight might be slow to
get back and Chase down a potential pass
G pawn and here we go the Pawn's
disappearing and it does look like Nock
here will be safe it's only two pawns
now the Knight will deal with one the
king deals with the other handshake draw
nck survives what a fight Wesley did
everything he could to maximize his
chances but NC with some sneaky defense
in the end sacrificing the pawns gets
the job done for himself that's a draw a
final rapid game coming up as the score
remains level what a hold from no dear
back up you see him breathing out for
probably the first time in half an hour
what a save by him because he was in
huge trouble Wesley was pressing and
outplaying
him just fantastic fantastic resistance
there by nbec under so much tremendous
this pressure Wesley declining
repetitions not once but twice but in
the end nbec he managed to secure that
draw a really critical Half Point save
especially in a best of two David yeah
it was essential to hold that game he
was on the back foot pretty much entire
for its entirety right from the opening
nbec Abdu satoro and I just wanted to
highlight that flurry of moves in the
beginning of the game where Abdu satoro
actually out prepared his opponent
Wesley so basing his preparation on
Wesley's Chesser ball course and uh
launching a novelty a bit later so it
was here where black after a trade of
Pawns on D3 played Rook takes F2
initiating tactics but after some queens
were exchanged after black won the
sacrificed Rook due to this pin we saw
an end game and it was here already on
move 21 such deep preparation nybeck
played the novelty the First new move of
the game not covered in Wesley's Chester
ball course and despite the fact that a
few moves down on the line despite the
fact he had isolated pawns weak pawns
all over the board he was able to hold
black here is in real difficulties but
that half Point could be Priceless it
shows how deep preparation is at this
level in this day and age but Maxim V
gra Was Right Wesley was in his comfort
zone he had the upper hand he almost
converted there he stole a pawn but
nybeck deserves a lot of credit he never
gave too much ground he was able to hold
off Wesley so really nice start for him
with the black pieces he gets white in
game two you might have to give the not
to nck having the advantage going
forward it will be a set three game too
the final rapid game coming up uh this
was game one and the scores remain level
Magnus Carlton is already through to the
finals after he sends Fabiano Carana
back home with his victory and it is a
big big game two coming up with so much
on the line and for the players they
walk a tight Trope how much risk are
they willing to take in Toronto for that
fight to the finals and it is going to
be exciting between nbec and Wesley so
we will be
[Music]
back so we are here in Toronto I am H
Kaya excited for the CCT finals here
with Wesley so nice to be here in
Toronto yes good to I'm also very
excited and good the feedback after such
a long time only eight of you made it
here to Toronto so what makes you
excited I did very well last year yeah
hopefully it's a good sign and uh it's
the same place you know this one of my
most favorite hotels from last year so
hopefully that's a good sign what are uh
the fans in for this week you know
things are going to happen very quickly
right from the very beginning there's a
lot in Stak here so players are going to
be very competitive and uh obviously
sometime ago you learn that the finals
would be over the board what was your
reaction to that in an but we're playing
in a computer right no no you're playing
over the board oh we're playing in a
real board yeah yeah oh so you're
learning that now yeah I was quite
confused I don't know what mag has been
doing playing online all this time
then wa okay so thank you yeah can you
describe your playing style when I was
younger I would always play one E4 and
play the Sicilian with black like I was
very aggressive I'd go for mating
attacks but I could not play the end
game and then when I turned 16 I
started reading a lot of opening books
and then when I reached 2600 I realized
that you cannot just go for the attack
every single game and hope to win
because 2600s are not stupid they will
they will bring you down and what would
it mean to to to Win It Wesley it would
be amazing uh my last ter of the year
it's really it's really a big deal uh
this year it's much stronger though than
last year you got Magnus you got sappi
he got hikaro so there's a lot in St W
is old thank you and good luck in the
CCT
finals it doesn't look like much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com
Mount them in seconds with a tool-free
magnet kit and swap them whenever you
like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code Chess at displate.com
[Music]
two
give the gift of Chess as we celebrate
the holiday season with the chess kit
there's a 20% off for the rest of the
year until the 31st of December for the
chess kid gold membership so get going
going on go. chk.com
ck20 and use the command ck20 in chat
for all the information and it is one
chess kid we've got our eyes on it's
nbec Abdu satro who's fighting for that
spot into the finals to face Magnus
Carlson but he's up against Wesley so
the first game n Beck under big pressure
survives and Ka had a chat with him
right after
that all right that was game one in set
number three how are you feeling right
now not backck feeling good but um yeah
obviously my um my you know my quality
has been dropped since yesterday so yeah
I am a little bit disappointed um but um
yeah obviously I have one game ahead and
that's with white pieces so I'm looking
forward to to put up some pressure yeah
it must have been so important to come
out of this game with a draw after
Wesley Maybe coming into set number
three with momentum after winning set
number two yeah it was important not to
lose and yeah he he came extremely close
at the end I think I was just holding by
you know some miracle but uh yeah it's
it worked out well and um yeah it's it's
been just a pure luck at the end so you
definitely know how to win games against
Wesley so we saw that yesterday what
will you take from that into game number
two here well I think we are a little
bit I mean I'm a little bit struggling
with white so I will take it um easy and
we'll see do you think this will go to
an
Armageddon um most probably oh okay well
good luck in game number two thank you
thank you okay you heard him he thinks
this will go to an armagedon we'll see
back to you guys really interesting
insights there into not a back's mindset
he says he survived by luck but you make
your own luck on the chessboard and I
think he was very resourceful with the
black pieces in game one surviving a
difficult difficult game and he also
said that he's not feeling very
confident with the white pieces David
yeah a bit of a surprise because
traditionally he's been super strong
with the white pieces and maybe it's
just influenced by today's uh games
often uh as chess players we have this
short-term memory we only really
remember what's just happened uh we need
to block out the rest because it uh kind
of it's just too much
yeah just judging by his body language
he's banking on the fact that a one game
shootout an Armageddon might be his best
opportunity he has beaten Hikaru
Nakamura into Armageddon so I wouldn't
be surprised if that is his strategy
going into this next game nuk has been
The Comeback Kid so far and he did lose
set du to Wesley it is momentum Wesley
but nbak survives game one of a set
three what what would you say are the
chances of this going into the
Armageddon well Notre seems like an
extremely honest person maybe too honest
for his own good when there's match
strategy at play but he says we're
probably heading to Armageddon I've
struggled with the white pieces I think
he's taking us to Armageddon so if
everyone is excited for that you should
remain at the edge of your seat I
believe we're getting there but what
about Wesley I mean I don't know if he
heard that interview or not when you
know that your opponent is feeling a bit
shaky do you try to create your chances
Wesley's black we saw what Nordic did
with the white pieces in game two of set
two he went a little too hard with the
white pieces so I don't think that
Wesley is the type of player who goes
all in with the black pieces when he
doesn't need to I really think that for
Wesley it' be smart just to play the
position in front of him and if nck
forces a draw there's nothing you can do
this is the final uh rapid game of the
best of two nbak starts with the white
pieces the first game Wesley is the one
who put pressure is that also something
for nardack to think about the fact that
he really never managed to equalize out
of the opening till the very end it was
a tricky end game it will will be on his
mind uh nobec I think we saw it there in
his body language when he was chatting
with K he was mostly relieved uh kind of
slightly disappointed because he did
land some decent opening preparation but
in the end he was suffering and uh I
think he should actually take Confidence
from that who cares uh your track record
with white just in the last few games
white is white after all you have the
first move Advantage but uh it's up to
him I mean he knows better than anyone
how he feels he only knows uh kind of
his estimations his calculations with
risk versus reward of playing with white
now going all in Armageddon in the end
would be a fair way to decide and uh
maybe the only way to decide these two
Fierce competitors so much on the line
for these two players so much at stake
it is about getting into that finals and
play against Magnus gson it all comes
down to this final rapid game will there
be an Armageddon or not nbec has shown
so much tenacity and so much
determination and he's had quite the
journey to the Champions chest finals
let's take a look at his road to getting
here nbec Abdus satarov a rising star in
the Chess World won division two in the
chessable Masters to qualify for
division one in the chess kid cup and he
immediately Rose to the challenge notbe
is not going to miss this he solves
these for breakfast he solved these for
a Breck of 7 years
ago goodbye it's reable really just
clinical play here and there we have it
NC of the satov takes the match against
Jordan van furus
another great move Knight D6 there was
Rook D7 just integrating the tactics
perfectly and he's about to win a third
Pawn that might trigger
resignation Black Knight no good squares
for it to use and I think Fabby you can
tell body language there he leaned back
has he resigned he has Abdu satoro takes
the match in the Grand Final he plays
kowana yet again and with another
impressive match win Abdu satarov
emerges victorious in the chess kid cup
to qualify directly for the tour finals
Queen D2 is that the winning move and
that's it we have a winner n Abdu satov
wins the chess kid cup with an
impressive performance throughout the
season Abdu satarov has earned a total
of 325 tour points the same as Carana in
second place on the standings the
19-year-old is definitely someone to
look out for in
Toronto and where that the chest get C
there notc Abdu satov punched his ticket
to Toronto and what a path he's had
along the way knocked out Hikaru
Nakamura and he does fight for that spot
into the finals in this game too it's
going to be about his decision he did
mention that he would be okay to take
this to the Armageddon he's got the
white pieces will he push for more or
will he just block down uh all play and
take it to the sudden that Wesley so
still to arrive well for no de back as
David said he knows how he's feeling so
he knows best if he feels that his
chances are highest in Armageddon take
us right there force a draw get all of
us to Armageddon and for Wesley he's
probably not so thrilled that notbe put
up such resistance in that game it was
his chessable course after all it was
very deep preparation but it didn't land
him a full point yeah and what a fight
this has been right nck takes set one in
convincing crushing manner Wesley takes
set two in convincing crushing manner
the first game of big fight a big uh
dramatic turnaround at the end saw nbec
survive that so it does look like
Armageddon would be the fair decisive
game for these two how else to separate
them simply and uh we see him there
staring off into the distance nck I
wonder what's going through that mind
right now if he wants I think Wesley
wouldn't be a verse Wesley is so
pragmatic especially with black uh to
that draw to taking it to Armageddon but
maybe he's thinking ahead into the
future that Armageddon bid his approach
there depending on whether he gets white
or black the problem with Armageddon you
might get white anyway and if you're
struggling with white if you bailed out
with a quick draw with white would you
be feeling confident I just don't
remember the last time I saw nck play
for a draw but when's the last time you
heard him speak like that about how a
draw would be okay and he's struggling
with the white pieces so I just think
he's honest at the moment the handshake
the glasses are off will the gloves be
off that's the question that we all want
the answer to yeah was that a bit too
honest did not a b give away too much of
his mindset when he said that he would
be happy to take this into Armageddon
will Wesley be the one who start getting
ambitious the black pieces did pay off
in set two when Wesley had a crushing
crushing Victory and it's go time it's 1
E4 are we going to see a Berlin okay the
knights are out and uh Wesley still
adjusting his pieces I hope he said Jadu
and okay his night is out as well big
moments ahead NC does bring his Bishop
out it's the Spanish opening it is the
Berlin defense but anti- Berlin from
nobec so no forc draw yet if he wanted
the draw straight from the off he could
have forced it there and then and what's
this bishop A4 move a little cheeky try
from Nock usually you put your Bishop on
A4 after Pawn goes to A6 but he
voluntarily places his Bishop on A4 it
eliminates some of these Knight D4 lines
where black just tries to trade all off
all the pieces in the center so it's
funny game thus far from these two no
Force draw n direct showing that he may
want to play on yeah he means business
this Bish Bay for move Robert uh I don't
know why but I've had the bad luck of
being on the wrong end of it a few times
uh a few of my opponents have played
this one it just keeps the tension takes
out these Knight D4 ideas quick D5 ideas
no way for black to break the immediate
tension so we're pretty much guaranteed
a long maneuvering game and uh I must be
uh I must admit I'm a bit surprised here
it's not consistent with nock's
interview he said a draw Armageddon
pretty much it's fine but he wants to
fight he wants a long battle here and
Wesley again the first to think it was
that little Bond move when move number
four when nck played D3 going in for the
anti Berlin that seems to show that nck
is in for the long game in this one and
Bishop to A4 that last move by nbec at
least it made Wesley go into a little
bit of a think and use up some of that
clock which is critical in these
situations it's not your standard line
so for West he can't rely on all his
preparation and he does lash out with
Pawn to D5 this can ruin Black's Pawn
structure you may think with double
pawns but I would prefer to have the
bishop pair in an opening position so I
think that uh for ner backck he's more
likely to bring his Knight out from B1
out to D2 just defend that pawn in the
center I do not think he's capturing
that Knight on C6 with his Bishop yeah
and trading pawns off in the center also
has its downsides if white takes this
black pawn in the Middle with his own
Pawn black would have a space advantage
so uh really tense position we mentioned
a lot of maneuvering ahead Wesley is the
one to try and clarify the tension he's
the one to try and trade things off uh
try and guide this game towards safety
Suddenly It's nbec thinking yeah I was
praising him a moment ago this bishop A4
move a nice sneaky one okay he keeps the
tension doesn't spend too long uh so
backing up this small surprise in the
opening yeah this one it feels like it's
going to simmer for a long long time
it's just about whether it eventually uh
explodes later on this middle game yeah
and N back continues with his
development uh not giving free play you
really don't want to trade on D5
allowing a weakness on D3 so keeping the
tension in the center but to my
understanding in these openings when
black does get a central break like D5
that's already a mini success for black
it is a success because you get activity
for your pieces most of these top
players don't like sitting passively but
one of the downsides is when you push to
D5 like he's done instead of D6 your E5
Pawn can be a bit tender uh he has it
all under control thus far thanks to his
Rook on E8 and Wesley takes away uh the
G5 Square from any of White's pieces for
nir backck often times you bring your
queen out to E2 or your Rook to E1 but
this is a draw that we could possibly
see you got Rook E1 Knight G4 we've seen
that in so many different positions
where someone goes after the F2 Pawn The
Rook slides back and the Black Knight
slides back as well I I'm just you know
joking here but it is possible that if
the players don't really want to
continue this game there are ways to get
this back and forth three time
repetition which means it would be a
draw I just wonder if nck wanted that
early draw would he have gone for an
anti Berlin would he have not just gone
for the trades the normal Berlin and
kind of secured it faster yeah I think
we were all a bit thrown off we were all
a bit speechless we thought this might
be a short game but suddenly the players
really digging deep all pieces all pawns
on the board Clarity far far away right
now and uh Robert you're kind of joking
but not really joking about this uh this
maneuver because if nck does play his
Rook across one square right now into
the center rookie one probably the most
natural move in the position black does
have that option and we could see a
quick repetition so nck may be mulling
over in his mind as well whether to keep
the fight alive whether to play a move
such as pawns H3 and maintain the
tension and uh yeah I also just reminded
of this interview we had with Danny and
Maxim fash grav avoiding the nbec death
stair Wesley through out today he has
had his hand on his head just uh
breaking eye contact we see nobec
mirroring that body language right now
yeah Wesley not so unbothered about the
death there I think he's just not been
looking NC's way so if nck was to choose
the pawn move that you were hinting at
on the king side step up the H Pawn One
Step Ahead that would at least imply
that he wants the game to go on how
ambitious it is of an approach we'll
find out later but at least it keeps the
game and keeps the tension on the board
so on the other hand if he slides in
with the Rook we might have a really
really quick road to the Armageddon and
he does slide in with the Rook but this
is moment number two because if Wesley
does go up with the Knight there is one
more way to defend the F2 Pawn Yeah The
Rook can slide up instead of back to
where it came from uh so Knight G4 is
the move that we have been discussing we
have seen this in high level games when
people would just want to make a draw
The Rook goes back to F1 and because the
Knight is not really doing anything on
G4 anymore it can go back to F6 and The
Rook slides back to E1 it's not really
not rebeck's style to make a draw in
this manner and as Tanya was indicating
you can bring your Rook up into E2
rather than to the side it's just a bit
awkward to do that you will play H3 kick
the Knight back and then probably move
your Rook back to E1 anyway because it's
on an awkward Square so uh these are
decisions that the players don't take
lightly and for Wesley you look at him
is he in a fighting mood in this game
does he really want Armageddon because
if we believe what some of the people
have been saying he's the stronger
player the higher rated player player
with more experience maybe he wants to
try his hand in a rapid game versus an
Armageddon game where the odds May tilt
in the youngster's favor yeah Magnus
mentioned in his interview earlier that
he likes to see it go down to the wire
if there is an option for the match to
continue longer we'd all love to see
more chess but for now Wesley doesn't go
for the move that we were talking about
which could potentially invite a
repetition but instead he goes for the
ponade and now if not back was to
recapture with the pawn the most natural
one we could still see the Knight
jumping onto G4 and similar lines yeah
Moment of Truth Wesley still has this
option Avail available to him and uh you
mentioned Magnus wanting to see more
chess Magnus also wants to tire out his
opponents before tomorrow because he
know uh he knows he's facing one of
these two he wants to see them push each
other to the Limit but Wesley doesn't go
for this uh night jump doesn't put
pressure on the F2 square instead gains
some space on the queen side prevents
white from advancing on that flank Maybe
maybe also activating the black Rook
kind of down and across the board we've
seen so many Rook swings Rook lifts this
whole tournament and I think he's
justified in playing on there's no
reason to kind of bail out to try and
Escape there's no reason that you're
worse with black simply and right now
still pressure on nbec to justify this
whole opening why should white be better
here he moves his Queen gets off the
first Rank and uh just looks very level
very even to me it is indeed and we've
seen this type of position at the
highest level in the Madrid candidat in
2022 hikaro Nakamura Tamar rajabov had a
similar structure like this with a Pawn
on A5 it's good because it stops white
from lashing out with Pawn to B4 and
gaining some space but it gives the B5
Square to White that A5 Pawn can be
targeted especially if the Knight on D2
hops out to C4 so this may seem quiet
the eval bar may be right in the middle
but just like game one there could be
more to it that meets the eye and both
players do need to keep a watchful eye
on different Square and different pieces
and Robert you were in Toronto last year
where Wesley went on to win the event do
you feel that he's in the similar
mindset do you feel he's got the same
Focus same Zen with all respect meant
towards every single other player that
was in Toronto last year a certain
player wasn't Magnus Carlson so I keep
saying it and it's not even because I
want to root for anybody I never do as a
commentator but when Magnus Carlson
plays on even terms with everyone else
he is the favorite so Magnus was not
there last year Hikaru was there to
really nicely played match from Wesley
to take down Hikaru Nakamura when most
people thought Hikaru would win the
whole thing so Wesley that was his
really shining performance in his career
but Magnus wasn't there so I don't think
the mindset is similar and by Wesley's
own words he said he just wanted to
finish I think top six or something like
that he's doing way better than that
yeah absolutely and that was at the
start when we had had a chat with Wesley
asking about his Ambitions in this
tournament and he revealed that he'd be
happy to
just make it to survival to be in the
top six but the chest that he's produced
the aggressive play that we've seen him
all throughout the round robin stage
going on up until even today what we saw
it again it just feels like a very
different Wesley not the solid Wesley
not the one who's just waiting for his
opponent's mistakes but the one who's
provoking those mistakes with active
player yeah and uh we should also
remember that there's so much at stake
in this game alone uh you talked about
Wesley trying to come top six now he
wants to come top two minimum the
difference between second and Joint
third place for the player who's
eliminated here is an incredible amount
of money tens of thousands of dollars
and that's life-changing uh I mean
especially for someone so young as Abdu
stov but also for Wesley it could really
set him up um yeah plenty of stake both
players fearing defeat but also
desperate to win I wonder if that's on
their mind because there's a $50,000
difference so if a player wins this game
they secure themselves minimum
$100,000 the loser well they'll take
some Solace with the 50k still a great
prize day for them but that's a lot of
money at stake and that could make
people more nervous it's a lot of money
but I think for these two players right
now they're not thinking about any of
that they're not even thinking about
meeting Magnus in the finals it's the
position on the board it's about getting
through this very match uh and for that
the big question is will it be decided
on this one will the players try to push
there is no margin Forever This is a
best of two this is the final rapid game
or will they take it more kg more more
cautious approach taking it down to the
Armageddon but in this format You Can't
Hide for too long from a decisive result
You Can't Hide for too long and we did
see a shake of the head from Wesley so
briefly uh before he tried to uh revert
to that poker face and I think it might
be because White's position has been
improving blacks less so or at least
less obviously so Wesley's messed around
a bit uh especially this last Rook move
a bit mysterious the black Rook on B8
unless he's throwing pawns down the
board here and now then uh that could
just be a Superfluous move meanwhile
white has achieved the dream setup in
any Spanish opening or Italian opening
the two white Knights love to park
themselves on these squares F3 G3 and
great attacking potential for abdor
suddenly and as da likes to say if you
do step a you have to continue step B
Rook B8 hints at the move B5 but I don't
think that black can get away with it at
least not in a way that Wesley would
prefer because there's a queen on E2 and
a bishop on A4 teaming up on that square
there will be some tactics here but B5
Bishop takes B5 this has to be
calculated and the engine is also saying
slightly better for white so not the end
of the world but Knight D4 tactics it's
really the ones you try to uncork white
can take this back with the Knight which
does protect that Bishop over there on
B5 there will be some trades in the
center but white temporarily at least is
up a pawn black would have to prove the
compensation yeah this is not Wesley's
style to sacrifice specul speculatively
like this and uh try and hope that he
gains enough compensation later on maybe
he does because the black Rook on the B
file is so active the black Rook on the
E file is so active uh this Pawn is
extremely weak but yeah it's hard to
envisage him going for this one right
now B5 it looks like the consistent
followup but he's hesitating the longer
he thinks the less inclined he'll likely
be towards that pawn push and what else
you would love to kind of copy white and
put the sorry my arrows are going funky
there put the Black Knight over on G6
but the problem is the E5 Pawn might be
hanging on the way so after after a
Trader Bishops you'd be forced to take
back with the Knight just to hold this
pawn and suddenly it looks a bit clumsy
these two knights are clearly inferior
to whites stallions on the king side and
yeah it just feels like he might get
tied up in knots so what's he going for
he plays Bishop to D6 another clumsy
move the Bishop looked active now it's
very much passive but it's all to do
with this Knight maneuver next he wants
to bring his Knight over to the king
side it's also a trade that you want
right you want to get out of this uh po
potential pin but also get out of this
uh light squ Bishop Dynamic that exists
Knight E7 would offer the bishop trade
and allow a more free hand on the queen
side for Westley to go forward I do like
the idea of Knight D7 Bishop D6 a
retreating move but uh it comes with a
plan I just don't see why Rook B8 was
necessary like Bishop B6 makes perfect
sense to me you want to wrap your knight
around and if he can successfully get
that Knight to G6 I do believe he's
equalized but I think he's shaking his
head because he feels that Rook B8 was
inaccurate doesn't actually have a point
to it and for white right now for nyback
he needs to play precisely because if he
doesn't keep up this pull in the
position it will just be neutral
territory it will be equal maybe like
Rook D1 I think that does make Knight E7
harder to accomplish because after
knight7 if I take on D7 once again you
can't take with the queen because the E5
Pawn is vulnerable there and the engine
gives up a pawn no problem I would be
looking at this and saying what did I
just do the engine just doesn't
care all right it's a moment for nuk to
think if he wants to play prophylactic
chess there's also ideas uh that black
has with this move Rook B8 which you
often describe as a mystery move in
these openings it kind of is preemptive
of Pawn advances of expansion on the
queen side and then suddenly Rook B it
does make a little bit of a sense I
think it's one of those slow moves that
in the beginning it's harder to
understand but once the pawns start
moving down the board you're like okay
this I'm glad I have my Rook on B8 yeah
the top players they somehow make these
mysterious moves work
sometimes they play a move it looks a
bit silly and then 10 moves 20 moves
down the line you're like oh wait that
was the point so you might be right
Tanya and Abdu sator seems to agree that
you're right because he's blocked the
advance of the black B Pawn the Black
Knight goes back now as predicted if we
see a trade of light squ Bishops yes
White's left with his Superior Bishop
but uh the more pieces off the board the
less cramped black is look at this
maneuver nobec preempting Black's
decision to try and rroo that Knight to
the king side now he's trying to land
his own Knights maybe into the F5 Square
interesting idea Knight on F5 dark
Square Bishop for white that has the
makings of an attack so you do need to
be careful if you're Wesley you want to
trade on your own terms and trading off
light score Bishops that should favor
white and if you ever push your Pawn to
C6 to keep your light score Bishop on
the board you're keeping those pieces
that's true but you're also creating
weaknesses for yourself so these are not
easy decisions I like not back's clock
usually when he's ahead by a couple
minutes it's when he's playing best
chess and putting the pressure on Wesley
in game three of set two earlier today
nyck was down two nothing he had the
black pieces he was up on time he even
made a mistake that let Wesley back in
the game but Wesley didn't have enough
time at the end and Norbeck brilliantly
won that one so I do like the clock
management for Abdu satarov all right uh
happy with the clock management here for
n back uh it is about whether the
Bishops stay alive or not and they don't
they do get traded off and Wesley
continues to offer trades right now
Queen to D7 if that's taken off the
board we're going to see black trying to
get those pawns moving up meanwhile
white that attack that you're talking
about without the Queens it loses uh
teeth yeah and a trap in the position
that's always a bonus uh just to mention
there is a pawn up a grab suddenly we
see the point of Wesley's move Rook B8
he's saying oh no my pawn and if white
goes and takes this Pawn The Rook goes
back where it came from and suddenly
I'll know my queen the queen is trapped
on the edge and uh really sneaky idea
there um you mentioned that Tanya after
Queen to D7 if the Queens disappear I
think black has no problems whatsoever
the pawn will land on A4 the pawn will
come to B5 the Black Knight is actually
poised perfectly to start hopping into
some holes in the white position and
this would be dead level so if nobec
here wants to maintain some tension
wants to play for the win I think he
might be forced to retreat but suddenly
black has certainly gained something in
this exchange white has lost a bit of
time and uh whether that's advanced ING
with the black pawns on the queen side
whether that's planting the black Bishop
back on a nice diagonal before the white
Bishop reaches this Square on E3 I think
Wesley has solved his problems I think
he's equalized it's all about those
holes because the D3 square like you
mentioned the F5 Square for White Knight
and neither nordbeck or Wesley I mean
they don't know the evaluation here
whether to trade Queens how equal is it
it's looks equal it should be with best
play but you never know if one side has
a slight advantage and for NB he
typically doesn't like trading down and
just accepting that it's equal he may
have some Ambitions but now he takes the
queen and he may be sending us arm again
looks likely at this point yes the White
Knight has landed on F5 but there's no
attack uh con connected to it because
the Queens are off the board I don't
think it's really a strategic threat to
even take this black Bishop Black's
Bishop is clearly inferior to White's
Knight right now and uh yeah he wouldn't
damage the black porn structure too
severely long term I think Wesley will
either move move his bishop move the
Black Knight maybe even start pushing
some Pawns in the next couple of moves
and really hard to imagine either side
winning this one not a back statement
from that interview earlier seems like
we're getting closer to that as the
pieces get traded off the board wh
Knight has found its active spot black
without any problem here white without
any weakness here if anyone I think
black can try to push if you think about
Pawn breaks here Wesley might be the one
who might start thinking again about the
Thematic break with B5 B four would that
give any chances for black in this end
game get some activity that's for sure
but anytime you play for a win in a
position like this you could be playing
for a loss to some extent because
throwing all your pawns forward it
leaves holes behind s sound like Stanley
yellat I'm just talking about holes all
the time but uh this position remains
all zeros it looks like that Knight can
take the bishop on D6 at some moment
white can push the pawn to F3 keep
everything under control I'm not too
worried for nck or for Wesley both of
them are with a steady hand it's equal
and to make it more equal perhaps nbec
will offer a bishop trade on E3 because
if you compare pieces that black Bishop
on C5 to me it looks more active than
the whes bishop and you also need to get
that A1 Rook into the game we've been
talking so much about nock's endgame
technique and how that kind of separates
him from his colleagues and uh his
generation just because he willingly
goes into end games and seems to outplay
from these minuscule advantageous
positions sometimes the advantage isn't
even clear how does a player really
improve his end game technique at such a
young age well it's impressive uh I
think NC one of his big strengths in in
the end game is his calculation he's
especially good in end games with small
imbalances he's especially good in Queen
end games where it's very forceful where
he can kind of work out his path
concretely um in general it's just about
practice these uh end games there are
books out there there are Chesser B
courses on end games um I'm not going to
name drop one of mine but uh but uh yeah
in general it's all about practice the
more you play end games and nbec plays
so many games throughout the year um the
more you learn essentially and he's
practicing against the best he's
learning from the best playing against
Magnus playing against Wesley Nakamura
all these fantastic endgame players and
that's what's made him so good today at
such a young age and it's one of those
hardest things to improve on right
because like you're saying it's about
experience the play uh the amount of
times you've actually faced an endgame
against a top player and for him at this
young age to get so strong at it it's
really a unique quality about uh his
chess and unlike openings where they
start from the beginning of the game and
you just make moves to get that
practical training I guess exercises
from an endgame what is an end game that
you should be studying what does a
position look like there's this famous
book endgame strategy by Mel sherfy that
I recommended time and time again really
wonderful it looks like just this
position most players would just shake
hands and you see one side out
maneuvering the other and you have to
look what are the pluses what are the
minuses what are some squares that I can
take advantage of right now I love
Wesley's move H5 that he played because
he wants to follow with his G Pawn
pushing and he's not going to hang a
Pawn on the right hand side of our board
so I think that you know to study end
games like this you go to a position
like this and you play it out maybe with
a friend U you just train a little bit
maybe even against the engine and see
how you do yeah requires so much
patience and we've seen so many tactical
finishes in in both of their matches but
to me the most one of the most
impressive was from set one this end
game that nbec actually converted and
Wesley himself he's a technical expert
but nbec in that two versus one rook and
night end game just outplayed and
managed to win that and that can be
really terrifying right now both players
of course playing very slow and I think
this is a very level game and it just
comes down to how much they actually
want to continue with this will they
take risks will they start pushing pawns
at some point to create chances you have
to push pawns you have to push pawns but
where and uh remember pawns don't move
backwards so you don't want to push too
far that the pawns become weaknesses or
the squares behind them become
weaknesses and uh you can see that
Wesley's pushed his Rooks pawns the
black a and black H pawns because those
only gain space nothing really serious
is Left Behind and uh yeah right now a
bit of a decision whether to chop off
that Knight or not Wesley says no the
White Knight looked like it was about to
become Strong by jumping into the center
but I'm going to uh fend off any threats
there I'm going to cover all the squares
and yeah actually if anyone and I like
the progress that Wesley's making he's
gained space he's covered squares
there's easy plans the black king is
going to centralize in end games it's
all about these mini plans small plans
of improvement first improve the poll
structure second improve the pieces uh
that type of thing and feels like both
sides uh both players are just well
versed in this I'm with David there just
aren't any imbalances here the bishop
can take this Knight on E3 if you're
looking at this from the perspective of
Wesley so but you would want to do that
if you could take control of a light
Square when your opponent has a bishop
it's inherently limited to that color
complex you want to take advantage of
the other complex as a knight can jump
from color to color but there aren't
squares to take advantage of here
there's only one open file we saw one
pair of Rooks trade we'll likely see
another pair of trade once that Bishop
gets out the way and without material
remaining on this board just seems like
there's not too much life left and you
can see by their movement here trades
are about to happen I think we're
heading to Armageddon we've been saying
that for a while and it looks like it's
going to become a reality on that last
night move it looks you might be asking
why is NC not developing that Rook on A1
it will develop if Wesley does decide to
trade on B3 U to land up on the open
file so Wesley delaying that decision
keeping the tension on the queen side
and I think neither players are going to
Blink with a trade with that a and the B
Pawn Yeah black definitely doesn't want
to trade and develop the white Rook for
his opponent on an open file without
even forcing The Rook to move and
likewise white will not trade off
because white will be left with those
split pawns we all learned from that
bowling analogy from Robert do not split
the pawns but wow really ambitious I
will say pushing the pawn to B4 uh
bypassing Black's a pawn because now we
talked about some uh loose squares and
it's about those light squares the C4
Square was ready and ripe for the Black
Knight to jump into he puts his Knight
on the rim to prevent the Black Knight
hopping wow abdor of putting pay to
these uh assumptions we're making and
that's the problem is when you assume
when you get complacent and your
opponent's still uh going on then you
can lose track of the position you can
lose the plot and I've had games just
like this where I just assume it should
be a draw and here comes the dark score
Bishop for white now that Knight was
threatened so Wesley jumps back to the
last Rank and I'm looking at the clocks
as well n has a healthy lead on time if
he can poke and prod and create maybe a
little hole maybe a weakness that A4
Pawn in particular he could possibly
play for a win at this stage and if you
are playing for a win do you want to
trade off the last Paar of
Rooks tough question I well I love and
hate that you both looked at me at the
same time because it's so difficult who
wants to trade the Rooks I would say
maybe white now just because with Rooks
off the board Black's a PA looks like a
bit of a uh bit of a Target it looks
like it's just stepped a bit too far
that's why I was so surprised earlier
that Wesley pushed the pawn uh we were
talking about porn's not moving
backwards it's so committal I have
commitment issues a lot of people will
tell you that but uh yeah that black
porn could live to regret the day that
uh it stepped onto White's half of the
board and yes the King has come into the
center but Moment of Truth can Abdus
satoro trade Rooks off he's in no rush
to because he can play Rook D1 in any
moment and there's only one open file
Black's Rook sits on that file he can
play a little bit on the king side Sobe
Rook G1 one of those moves that make
your intentions clear or so you think am
I really going to push that jeep on at
least you're going to have to calculate
it so for nir Beck he can trade off the
Rooks right now uh that will simplify
the position that A4 Pawn is hard to
touch white doesn't have too many pieces
remaining and that's all that black
needs to make sure he defended and we've
been trying to understand the mindset of
these two players do they want more do
they want to go into the Armageddon will
we see a quick draw will this go on to
be a grind and I think it's that
cautiously ambitious approach that we're
seeing he's still keeping the tension
the the play does go on and there are
still these small nagging problems for
black to be solved on the queen side you
pointed that a pawn the Bishop from E3
now quite an active piece the pawn on B4
limiting Black's own dark Squad Bishop
from activity and yes the only open line
is captured by Wesley's Rook but that
King onu it takes away all penetrating
squares yeah uh right now it looks like
white stabilized and I can tell by our
voices we've liked the kind of last few
moves the way they've gone in White's
favor but Wesley still not too many
weaknesses and now he's asking he's
offering a trade of knights and uh I
think if the knights disappear probably
the remaining winning chances disappear
with them but uh at this point who knows
Abdu satoro playing on I just wanted to
ask now we're around the 3 minute Mark
for both who's impressed you the most
when the clocks have ticked
down definitely no dearb for me I think
that wesy sometimes panics we saw that
in set one in that end game where he was
holding on for dear life and then
unfortunately for him he went wrong very
late in that game and here he's R doing
everything perfectly and he's keeping 2
minutes 44 seconds on his clock so I
think just in terms of time trouble I
would take n deer back in scramble yeah
I'd agree with you Robert I think he's
just shown nerves of Steel throughout he
doesn't let the get doesn't let the
nerves get to him nbec we've we just saw
it today itself right this crazy
position with black king and with nck
King out in the open how he went on to
play and convert that into a win he's
taken so many Armageddon and I think
he's been he's been just Fearless with
just seconds on the clock yeah fearless
and Wesley off offers no I was going to
say a rook trade the way he moved the
piece there was a bit unorthodox I
thought he touched his Rook he takes
with the bishop so leaving the tension
now it's actually white who holds the
defile for now and nbec really
ambitiously pushes his Pawn forward to
B5 that has totally removed the option
now of black touching queenside pawns
Black's a pawn is a huge Target long
term uh actually if the Rooks disappear
maybe white would be winning this
suddenly and he's pushing all of the
pawns forward on light squares notice
because white has a dark Square Bishop
therefore he wants to control both color
complexes Bishop dark squares pawns
light squares Wesley maybe feeling a bit
uncomfortable the problem for nir and
he's playing this so extremely well he
does have pieces to attack that A4 Pawn
with there's only one open file The Rook
on D1 is doing a good job there but if
he keeps pushing his pawns then that
black work will slide up to A5 and
challenge those pawns so it does feel
like NC has made progress and yet I'm
not sure where to next yeah it looks
nice and beautiful but that's always the
tough thing when it's almost symmetrical
the porn structure when there's no clear
weaknesses when it's the same uh kind of
balance of pieces both here with rook
and dart Square Bishop you need some
kind of uh targets you need those two
weaknesses here black has zero
weaknesses to probat so still should be
a draw but he's going for it nyck he's
really going for it he's just pushed
that pawn all the way to C5 now that
white king is about to arrive on C4 and
to me just looks like Wesley has allowed
too much to happen you were talking
about no piece assisting white to attack
A4 that King King is a piece in the End
Game King C4 King B4 and suddenly I'm
putting pressure yeah really ambitious
move and black does have the option now
of coming back with his Rook giving a
check kicking back the white king but a
rook trade and suddenly Black's Pawn
would be helpless the white king would
be superior and Wesley he's pushing
forward creating a route in for the
black Rook really clever play there from
Wesley so that he's going after the E4
Pawn he went F5 earlier so if the white
king starts running on over to try to
grab that A3 Pawn you'll lose sight of
the E4 Pawn so Rook C1 is there going to
be a pawn push to C6 you have to be
careful because if there's a rook behind
a pawn you can maybe even sacrifice a
piece to free it and spring it to the
other side I actually think Rook A4 here
would be a pretty big blunder from
Wesley he can't get away with that yeah
and this is really storming up right now
both players under two minutes Wesley
under a minute and a half right now and
this is the most exciting the game has
gotten so many structural changes black
has pushed that pawn all the way to A3
where it is a glaring weakness you
always need to watch out he loses that
bond that could be close to just a match
over yeah it's suddenly heating up and
it's not heating up in the typical way
with attacks checkmates it's heating up
in terms of the fact that Wesley is
walking a tight RPP he's got to avoid
certain uh kind of pitfalls here and he
trades a set of Pawns this doesn't
damage too much hesitation from nbec he
takes back and okay attacking White's
pawns now still feels like this could
switch this could flick um just uh turn
in either Direction with one mistake but
right now do you push a pawn do you
defend that pawn big questions for nck
or do you go for the Armageddon with
King to C4 Rook gives a check King comes
back Rook goes back we'll find out who's
ambitious here oh but then the Rook
black Rook could get in Via B4 and come
in behind Okay The Rook does try to come
behind but first having forced White's
Rook into posivity really tense position
how does either side make progress It's
not obvious anymore if you gave black
some free moves I'm not sure what he's
going to do so look a small pawn move
and Wesley brings his King back I think
white can bring the Rook up to B3 just
keeping an eye on that A3 Pawn I think
that neither side can really budge at
this stage they might have to shuffle
back and forth I don't see any inroads
yeah White's Bishop is tied down
defending the C5 Pawn White's Rook is
tied down defending B5 White's King is
tied down defending White's Central Pawn
it looks like he might have maximized
Abdu sator here he's really pushed
everything forward especially on the
queen side but no further and Wesley so
is just yo-yo going back and forth with
the black king he's got simple waiting
moves will we see a plan will we see a
winning idea from the youngster here
Rook back to B1 that hints at the answer
being no the Rooks come from this square
and Wesley continues to wait with his
King as well and I think it comes down
to this now both players maximize the
position as much as they can tied down
each other's pieces and nbec says that
this is it it goes into
Armageddon we got a big one coming up a
level game
that's what happens when two of the best
players play top level chess it ends in
a draw and goes down to sudden death I
was going to say there's little
separating them there's nothing
separating them right now it's an even
score we are heading to armag again you
see them considering they're talking to
each other and laughing they got to
focus on their
BS no that's not to happen 15
minutes 15 15 WL want some extra time
good negotiator time is it it's
545 6:00 6:00
or and they're figuring out when the
next when the armag get
start and finally Wesley gets are you
guys okay with
605 okay 605 in N is that good for you
605 so that gives you 20 okay NB
literally doesn't care
a 605 I'm ready and now they've got it
put down a bit and it's incredible to
see the good spirits both players are in
despite there being $50,000 being on the
line for the next game one player will
be eliminated one will go through 50,000
is the minimum differential between them
but both looking chilled especially
Wesley so and that's got to be on their
mind that's a very chill Wesley pose
right now he's probably been listening
to some Lo Girl music right before right
writing down his bid an Armageddon worth
$50,000 coming up yeah I'm not sure if
that's chill or exhaustion but this is a
stone cold nbec Abdus satarov he was not
going to let this match go we head to
Armageddon who gets white who gets black
that's the only question that remains to
prepare also I need you need to okay you
just use your if that's okay thank
you shout to Judith our great Arbiter
there for keeping the players in such
great
spirits and make sure you Circle the
color please okay they have to circle
the color they have to circle
white write down their bed okay and wow
I can't wait to see no it's good o it
all comes down to this the semifinal
battle goes into
armagen and notc he have still reveal
okay Shani Levy there everyone's getting
ready the tension is on NC first to
leave the playing Arena and this is what
they're fighting for that final final
space to fill in it will either be
Wesley so or nbec Abdu sat's name and
they will fight in the title match
against Magnus Carlson after a big
Armageddon we were talking about
momentum we've been discussing who does
it favor Wesley takes the second set
today then two level games ending in a
draw it feels like an absolute reset and
the Armageddon all momentum everything's
been thrown off it could be anyone's
battle it's a marathon we saw Wesley so
slouched in his chair and I don't think
that's him chilling we do love lowii
girl but I think that's him just tired
he has been having to calculate so much
nck is Relentless even when we think it
might be a draw he keeps it going so
both players they may be on their last
bit of energy that adrenaline will have
to kick in as we head Armageddon and for
one of these players this will be their
last game in the Champions CH off finals
Stakes are super high the tension has to
be super high right now as well
tension's high they have to rely on
their last reserves of energy the
adrenaline is guaranteed to pump in the
Armageddon game they will have been
playing for 6 hours by the time this
Armageddon starts so marathon is the
right word and it just comes down to who
has more left in the tank and no back
abdar mean he seems like he's always
full of energy it doesn't matter if he
was stuck in a foreign city for a week
just struggling to get his Visa it
doesn't matter he's playing six hours in
chess he's always ready to go he does It
For the Love of the Game wow and you've
got to be loving the game right now as
it goes down to the wire between these
two now David game two it was quite a
slow strategic fight what stood out to
you yeah I'm going to pick out a very
different type of moment than we used to
from these match highlights because this
one was void of any tactics minimal
calculation no attacks whatsoever it was
about small strategic advantages just
long-term weaknesses and I just wanted
to highlight this one position as a
indicator of nbec Abdus tor's strength
and ambition in end games here with
white plenty of us myself included would
have been happy to just sit and pretty
much do nothing there is no real way
forward for white and uh I'm just trying
to find my mouse but simply white could
wait with the Rook with the King instead
he pushed forward with Pawn to C5 and
once the black Bishop fell back he
decided to run forward with the white
king it looks like he's actually getting
towards the queen side but Wesley so
showing his tenacious side his
resourcefulness by pushing a pawn
forward and activating the black Rook as
we saw in the game in the final position
simply no way forward for either side
the white king is stuck defending the
white Central Pawn the white Rooks are
stuck defending the far Advanced pawns
on the B and C files and therefore it
was a draw but nbec did push as hard as
he could Unstoppable Force meets
immovable object it seems like nb's
always ready for the fight he gives it
his all every time but Wesley one of the
most precise players in chess history
he's not going to break that easily yeah
I I kind imagine a reality where Wesley
actually breaks but nck he's been
putting the pressure on when he gets the
opportunity it is a lot on the line for
these players and before uh we reveal
the bids we are going to Toronto where
Danny James and Levy will be breaking
down the action and the drama coming in
from the playing Arena punches are
coming up in the Armageddon gloves are
[Music]
on I'm here with nck up to satoro
finally in Toronto after a crazy travel
how many days have you been traveling to
get here so I travel to Berlin in on
November
30 so it's like more than a week finally
I got the Visa yesterday and just I'm
really really happy what is in store for
the fans watching this week there will
be a lot of um exciting games a lot of
those moments where you know where you
will never uh forget I think this is the
most like dream tournament for chess
pants this a lot of action and a lot of
excitement and imagine uh some days from
now you are standing there as the winner
of the Champions chess tour 2023 what
would that mean to you it's a long way
to to to get there but I would be just
um incredibly happy and you know this
would be my biggest individual
achievement I think finally for any new
fans watching can you please describe
your playing style pretty much all super
Grand Masters uh are are you know are
Universal so I would say I'm a you know
Universal player and um I like to to
calculate a lot and that's kind of my
style well nor we appreciate so much
your efforts to get here to Toronto I
hope you get some rest before it starts
and we wish you best of luck thank
you it doesn't look like much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
[Laughter]
n
[Music]
we are back here in the playing Hall at
the 2023 champ ions chess tour final you
know what's at stake Danny wrench
alongside James canny and Levy Rosman we
are getting set for what will be the
final Armageddon of this epic semi-final
Day called it you did call it you did I
did you also called it I think you guys
all called it but all right are you
surprised about how we got here right
the tensions seem high neither Player is
taking too many risks in those games but
your thoughts about the two games that
actually got us to the Armageddon I
think they just need to regain a little
bit of energy I mean the truth is
there's a lot of games to be played here
and we got a hotel contract we can't be
here for you know 10 days so it's a good
reminder we got we got to get out of
here like we got to you know we we have
a certain amount of time we're here so
the guys are a little bit tired they
regain some energy now it's Armageddon
time yep yeah they have some extra time
of course right as we're all waiting for
the games but I mean le as Davis say six
hours of play here right really that
stamina who's going to have the right
stamina especially in this last game of
the day so I think that's a a really
good point because I think we all talked
about the big storyline of the week when
Hikaru went home cuz somebody fans
wanted him to be here but one thing we
didn't talk enough about is part of the
reason he didn't have it against dobeck
is I think he was just exhausted that
was a very long day of eight hours of
Chess this day is going to be the second
longest day that we've had and I think
that both of these players have got to
be checking themselves before they have
like w or wrecking themselves chess puns
hopefully not checkmating themselves wow
we we have been here for a while and uh
we're going to be here a little bit
longer because the players have
Armageddon
and Ka caught up with them when they
gave their armagedon bid and let's uh
let's find out the big reveal who's
who's playing what color everyone's just
smiling when they're coming in here uh I
am so curious to see these Arma get on
bids you guys go ahead and turn your
boards let's see them
first same time same
time what you see N9
9919 927 with a cat but 9919 okay with
the black pieces what is this about um
yeah I don't know just I think doesn't
matter at this point just just choosing
black and hoping for best I saw you
write something and then you wiped it
out what was the first bid first bid was
9006 so I just you know yeah all right
well Wesley how do you feel about the
result of the bid here we'll see mean
it's been a it's been a long day so
anything can happen hopefully not the
break Place
badly must win now with the white pieces
do you think the cat will bring you luck
yeah uh hopefully it worked before you
miss your cat at home no no I I was just
at home so it's good and after this
tournament I don't have anything for two
months so that's cool okay well you guys
awesome bids good luck in the final
armag get on here back to you
guys I I I think did did Wesley draw his
cat or did he draw mittens that's
exactly what he drew it's mittens right
it look exactly the same it kind of
looks like mittens with like Wesley's
face actually though we can zoom in on
that Wesley human face that's human
that's mittens right there that's the
indication of was the gentlem I don't
mean to kill the mood but this chess
game is worth 50 Grand it's worth
$50,000,000 American not Canadian
dollars that's a lot of money are you
surprised that nottock is playing Black
in this one I thought for sure Wesley
would would would be getting low enough
to get black but he bid so low 9 minutes
and 19 seconds is a risky bid FAO said
he would never get lower than 9 Minutes
on a bid not worth it to risk he taking
a risk I mean he's like look I've tooken
out Nakamura I've made it this far I'm
playing strong chess I am a world rapid
Champion youngest ever to do it right
I'm I'm just going to take it this is
the last shot so I'm going in with
everything I got 919 listen I did
statistics in college I'm mostly just
fasc that was just a quick flex but I
fascinated about the uh the data F noted
yes because you know we we we're now
Gathering all of this data and
information of what's like a good bid
right what's a good bid so we don't know
919 is that enough of a Time deficit to
still have that second result I I don't
think we realized having two results in
your back pocket in a chess game that's
huge like white has to win I wonder how
much of this psychology here was putting
Wesley in a must-win situation cuz I
think Wesley is more comfortable with
the draw odds right and playing low on
the clock your thoughts on putting
Wesley in that where he has to go all
out well he did he actually did that
with Magnus with that Knight G5 he had
to go all out he did it so he can do it
but it's it's about him defending and
having that I mean I'm taking black
every time if I can get that second I
can draw F or how Magnus found uh the
Knight D2 to B3 draw six stuff if you
could find that draw you win the game
it's 50 extra, too it's 50
extra, how much that suit cost 50,000
was it um a lot okay might have gotten
the hook up you know say Jo banan shout
out
ban no but okay so Wesley has to go for
the win he did do it against Magnus and
maybe what has object arguably been not
objectively arguably maybe been the game
of the tournament so far yeah you think
Wesley can uh can bring the heat here
against Notre Beck I have been saying
this every time they put us on this
beautiful panel Wesley so was my pick to
advance to the final we have one game
left if I jump ship now then I am a bozo
say so I I got to stick with my pick I
think cols change your thoughts on this
no not at all I'm still going with flexy
Serrano but at the same time I do like
how Notre back is swinging I mean right
we we called him right the Magic Dragon
but now he's he's changed into morphed
into something else now he's a beast
we've been debating hisame I will get
back to everybody yeah snow leopard snow
he's everything he's been everything to
he's been everything today and he is
everything as Cy likes to say half man
half everything else as we can see there
on the graphic Magnus Carlson is still
waiting for whoever is going to join him
in the finals will it be Wesley so will
it be Notre beaus turov that one toone
score in the set format we have doesn't
quite do justice to where we sit here at
past 600 pm. on the East Coast because
they've played a lot more than just two
games ladies and gentlemen if you're
just tuning in Where Have You Been we're
rocking it's the 2023 Champions chess
tour semi-finals and we're going to have
an Armageddon game in just a second so
all right guys well Wesley uh Wesley is
going to have to win with white he did
do it against Magnus Carlson and their
Armageddon game yeah I will say like you
guys I'm still not going to jump ship
now I also picked Carlson Wesley but I
don't feel like Wesley looked excited
about what happened because now we're
talking about Notre Beck playing Black
look how low Wesley bid he bid 927
that's also one of the lowest bids we've
had Levy you talked about the stats
we're going to have on Armageddon over
the years I can't wait to see when we
look back and talk about the meta that
we've learned in terms of what the real
right strategy is the players were
discussing the this earlier maybe it was
yesterday and I I wish hopefully
tomorrow we have a stat of all the
Armageddon maybe that's a good idea
shout out to the to the team here but I
think white was doing very well in this
event yeah white with the time Advantage
was doing a good job now Karu might have
messed that stat upar didn't have his
best chest and he lost a few with black
but he had a few again there will be
outliers but 9 minutes and 19 seconds is
still plenty of time against a guy like
Wesley to play a solid game a e45 you
know we're going to get a main line
unless Wesley plays B3 again I would
love B3 I would I would love B3 all
right well we would love B3 we know
we're going to get all the chess that we
want and I think uh Osa would love if we
threw it back across the sea Tanya
Robert David the band the team take it
away are you guys ready for Armageddon
we're so ready uh Danny it all comes
down to this one and I think we at least
in the studio were pretty sure that this
will go down to the wire especially
seeing the first few moves of that game
two I was just surprised how long that
game two went but rest assured it was
always going to be armag yeah it's such
a big one with so much money on the line
so much glory on the line of playing for
the championship of a season long tour
David yeah this is uh one of the highest
stes games that these players will have
ever played especially Abdu satoro for
such a young career but he's already won
a World rapper Championship I do
actually think I was uh just pondering
in that last break maybe he was trying
to tire Wesley out that was the only
reason that last game went on so long
maybe he was trying to ask a few
questions saying you're a bit older than
me mate I'm going to try and uh break
you down wear you down eventually but it
all does come down to this one yeah and
we see nck stamina has definitely not
been a problem for that chest kid now
the armag getting bids NC starts with
the black pieces uh what do you make of
that because Wesley his bid ALS he was
also wanting black he went pretty low
for the black pieces well they both won
the Black pieces because nothing
separated them in that two game mini
match we saw two draws the first game
Wesley did have his Chan with the white
pieces it was a forcing variation so nck
with that 20-minute break that he just
had if he looks at that line he probably
doesn't feel that afraid to get black
withdraw what do you think is going on
in NC's mind winning that very critical
bid and getting black right now I think
uh actually it's a bit of an adjustment
I think maybe he's gone back to his
hotel room called up his friends called
up his seconds his coaches saying what I
do against 1 B3 I think it's purely
about the technical aspect right now
because if he emerges with the uh from
the opening in good stead with enough
time he will be the favorite with those
result odds but um there's no guarantees
I think it's very very focused uh kind
of thought process now for NC you left
really quickly from that uh playing
Arena as soon as he submitted his bids
we saw nck was the first one to leave in
this kind of a situation do you think
it's a better idea to just take rest the
long day that you've had and be fresh or
are the players really looking at the
opening lines and their approach right
now considering what Wesley tried in
that first game of set three I do think
that nck would be well advised to
actually prepare because Wesley he
showed that I will I'm willing to go
down that deep line you better know what
you're doing he made a ches course about
it after all so maybe watch a little bit
of his video that early night G5 do you
think he's going to try to get that or
will nbec switch it up from uh the king
spawn opening it's really hard to say
nbec in general likes to be a moving
Target he likes to duck dive dip Dodge D
yeah all of that stuff he loves to just
avoid his opening uh his opponent's
preparation he loves to be the one
dictating uh the pace the nature of the
game so I wouldn't be surprised if NC's
actually the first to surprise the
opponent unless Wesley plays B3 again oh
one B3 but that can't be too much of a
surprise for nbec he has to be ready for
that to me the approach of 1 B3 it feels
more like a one game opening rather than
to remploy it and there we've got the
players they are ready to start start
the action stay hydrated it's been a
long day of Chess they're ready to go
nbec with the black pieces and let's
remind everyone a draw would mean that
nbec takes the match goes into the final
eliminates Wesley Wesley with the white
pieces has to win to knockout nbec Abdus
satov this is such a huge moment in the
career of both of these players but in
particular nbec Abdus satarov he's
younger he has won a World rapid
Championship but Wesley so was the
dominant force a year ago in Toronto
back wants to send him home yeah
absolutely and in just a few seconds we
will see their opening approach so
critical with no increment on the clock
which player gets the kind of middle
game that they want they enjoy playing
will Wesley get his solid approach or
will not be able to create initiative
and Wesley surprises first with the
English opening the English opening it's
1 C4 and uh some quick moves here some
very quick moves from nbec as he builds
a strong porn center with black we see
pawns disappearing already in the middle
of the board and a transposition to what
we call the tarash defense where black
often accepts an isolated Pawn but
compensates with dynamism really fast
start to this game by both players and
for Wesley so he doesn't mind having the
white pces he beat Magnus Carlson with
white in an Armageddon but it's a very
different type of position than this
here it's going to be a struggle is that
isolated a queen Pawn that pawn on D5 is
it a weakness or is it something that
black can play around you have open
files when you have an IED Pawn the
adjacent files are free for the black
Rooks to step on those lines and stare
into the white
position and we are when you're the one
with the isolated Queen Pawn what you
have in compensation is play is the
activity you're looking at not only
taking control of the open files as
Robert pointed out jumping forward with
your pieces the night from F6 will land
on e4 at the at some moment for white
it's going to be all about doubling down
on that D5 Pawn one thing's for sure
that these middle games are going to be
dynamic with the asymmetrical Pawn
structure yep and uh Dynamic is not the
name of Black's last move Pawn to H6 I'm
really surprised by that one one thing I
will mention is that Wesley so is one of
the best players against an iqp that
I've seen in a long time uh when he
faces this isolated Queens born Wesley
so he has a great track record uh often
just controlling Squares Out maneuvering
the opponent both of White's Bishops now
are on the longest diagonals F and kod
uh will their x-ray vision come into
effect nbec having to play quickly tries
to break down White's quinide structure
I really like that move because you
couldn't let Wesley have all the fun
you're going to carve out some squares
for your own pieces if you take on A5
then that means the A3 Pawn that becomes
a weakness long term and if you don't
take and so you push your Pawn forward
that hands black some critical dark
squares on the queen side namely C5 and
B6 so this is the right approach from
nybeck you don't give your opponent all
the space without countering but he has
burnt a minute both players have burnt
around uh around one minute right now
and Wesley the first long pause of this
game he just needs to decide how to fix
the structure how to decide the
structure clarify it on the queen side
and uh the key moments are still to come
still ahead but uh kg start now
especially with Wesley so going into the
tank he needs to move he needs to keep
his time Advantage because Black's
position is still healthy for now that
last move it feels as if things are
Brewing up in the position kg so far but
A5 that's the first question in the
position that Wesley needs to answer
what does he do with the B Pawn it's
attacked not only by the pawn but the
bishop on E7 as well do you defend it
keeping the attention do you push it
giving away some key squares in the
position I think Pawn takes Pawn would
be the last option on my on my radar
here giving a solid weakness on A3 is
not what solid Wesley will ever do I
would want to push the pawn to keep the
game going and exactly not to force off
a series of Trades but look at how
quickly and confidently nck is
responding to Wesley's moves he
understands the plans very well he may
have made a quiet H6 move but he's just
developing the rest of his pieces now
that Knight can hop on out to a square
like B6 and there it goes it's defending
the iqp the light Square Bishop is free
and watch out for the light squares on
White's Queen side that Knight can hop
into C4 and suddenly it could be trouble
for Wesley yeah potentially missed this
last move by Wesley so because he's
allowing Black Knight to hop in and
suddenly trouble white Dart Square
Bishop is a big big Target I think he's
actually arranged his pieces
suboptimally here Wesley so and you can
tell the usage of the clock right now
nbec has spent 1 minute pretty much one
minute since he started this game Wesley
has spent almost 3 minutes so the clock
times are starting to get closer
together nothing wrong has happened here
at all for nbec so I think he wins the
opening battle and uh he should be
feeling the more confident of the two
already a kind of position where black
is the one who's pushing for the
initiative and once again it's white who
has to win on demand black needs only a
draw a night trade offered I don't
expect nbec to trade and ease off the
pressure I like the idea of the night
jumping forward to C4 to put pressure on
that Bishop ship on B2 also that A3 Pawn
on White's Queen side is a weak Target
he reaches out it does arrive on the
board it looks like Wesley's pieces are
lacking coordination right now it looks
really not fun for Wesley look at that
Knight on A4 it's on the rim it offered
a trade trade was refused that Knight on
C4 hits the bishop on B2 and if that
Bishop moves forward on that dark Square
diagonal that A3 Pawn is in the SES of
Black's pieces namely that Knight that
just hopped into C4 and the bishop on E7
I'm not liking this at all for Wesley
it's a must-win game he's the one who's
burning clock and nybeck he's just
making very natural developing moves to
have a clear purpose yeah black still
has the isolated Queen's Pawn but we're
forgetting about that factor because
it's not relevant right now Black's
isolated porn if anything just covers
some key squares and helps the black
pieces and pawn Sacrifice from Wesley so
he is saying take me take that white A3
Pawn he's trying to uh at least activate
the white pieces and I think a good
decision in an Armageddon game but
objectively can black take the pawn that
is the big question nobec for the first
time in this game is pausing stopping he
is tempted is greed good here and that's
the question black could just ignore
things develop bring out the black light
Square Bishop to a uh any Square pretty
much uh but key moment the first
critical moment of this game big
questions to nck and he has to decide on
the board he mentioned in his interview
calculation is what he likes to do but
he has to do it quick and he does decide
to not go into the complications with
White's Knight jumping on to B6
potential capture on F6 if you think
about going on the left side of the
board NC wants none of that he wants to
develop his pieces keep the activity
going rather than getting greedy I
didn't love his move he developed his
light score Bishop but it was attacking
a pawn that was easy defend I would have
preferred bringing that light scored
Bishop out a little further maybe to a
score like F5 but I think that pawn on
A3 it was capturable not by the Knight
because that would have handed white the
B6 square and that looks very ugly as
black is super cramped and white is
definitely going to win back some
material but he could take him with the
bishop but that's neither here nor there
at this stage of the game he probably
didn't like how discombobulated his
pieces look instead he's playing with
that I said Queen pawn it protects both
knights in the center he's using it as a
lever yeah and look at these two black
knights they are beautiful pieces they
are glorious pieces but actually what
are they attacking they're not creating
any threats right now black will tried
to activate the Rooks but actually it's
uh just hard to see what next so nbec
he's going for stability then again he
has moved this bishop twice it's kind of
done a shimmy step here to D7 and then
to E6 I think Wesley should be feeling
positive about this change in
developments suddenly rather than being
down a pawn with white he has a very
playable position yes he has given the
opponent squares especially the Black
Knights but white has squares too these
Knights compensated for by this Rock
Solid Bishop this powerful Bishop in the
middle of the board looking at both
flanks and uh I think this one still in
the balance and the clock could play a
key factor nbec interesting maybe a bit
of indecision there it was so tempting
to grab upon Wesley trying to shut
things down or at least trade off one of
uh one of the sets of knights uh
interesting move there a retreat I like
it because he's getting rid of his own
Knight on the edge for a knight that's
extremely active so definitely a trade
that will favor white also if it's done
on Wesley's term a knight takes Knight
the queen does fall back recapturing and
then there'll be suddenly attacks along
the diagonal with the queen and the
bishop lining up so wondering if uh nbec
will decide to just keep the tension on
the board keep that Knight on C4 let
Wesley trade it sort out your problems
of the isolated Queens Pawn that way a
lesson we learn when playing with the
isolated Queen Pawn we typically do not
want end games the fewer pieces that
remain the harder it is for the side
with the isolated Queen Pawn because we
want to be active around that pawn so I
would not be taking on B2 if we're going
to trade black to trade on his terms May
Rook C8 that way his Rook can join the
party on the C4 square but NB back he's
down under 6 minutes so we're looking at
the move 18 42 moves before you get that
1 second bonus time these are not easy
decisions for him to make I also
wouldn't be surprised if he drops his
Knight back to D6 because that Knight on
B2 it's not the best piece in the world
and that Knight on D6 can reroute to the
F5 square and may keep posing some
important questions in the center he
does drop back as you recommend Robert
but uh the move itself is secondary that
was a long think one and a half minutes
on the clock in Armageddon as black
that's a huge chunk a huge proportion of
your time and yeah that might come back
to haunt him it will get fast and
furious sooner rather than later so I'm
wondering whether uh that time was
better spent just choosing a move
trusting his Instinct it feels like he's
not quite in the flow yet neither player
actually uh kind of unleashing this
quick flurry of moves trusting uh their
instincts but okay it was a good
decision in the end keeping pieces on
the board uh it's just same move faster
would have been uh better of course but
Wesley so now up to him he would love to
just push the white aporn one square
forward solidify the queen side not um
kind of be too loose over that flank
anymore but maybe he thinks there are
more urgent priorities in the position
one of the priorities that I see for
black would be to try and get rid of
that dark Squad Bishop that Bishop on D4
to me looks uh like such a strong piece
taking away so many key squares and uh
he does it I was thinking about the
bishop move to F6 but nbec finds another
way he reroutes that knight from C4 to
attack that Bishop on F4 Knight jumps
over to F5 none of the pieces have been
traded off there's so much tension along
the D line as well it's those positions
where it's really Brewing up to explode
and with 5 and a half minutes on the
clock things are going to get very
tricky for nyck I do like Wesley's last
move though he's giving up his dark
score Bishop which looked like the pride
and joy of his position but a knight
that was on the rim on A4 it's wheeled
right back around to D3 that can jump to
F4 putting pressure on the light squore
bishop and that isolated Queen Pawn so
look at Noir Beck he's not taking that
Bishop there's no real Rush yes the
bishop can slide back but that doesn't
solve all of White's problems so both
players are handling this position
extremely well yeah really classy game
so far from both they've navigated those
critical moments those tricky decisions
really really well but now Black's Rook
occupies this powerful open Line uh the
SE file right now is ripe there's plenty
of squares for the for for The Rook to
jump into so it does feel like Wesley
should Challenge fight for the open
lines maybe he's just afraid of these
exchanges knowing he needs to win at all
costs with white but uh it feels like
the moment to be objective just
challenge there we go he activates his
rook and uh how will black continue the
momentum maybe it's time for the black
queen to move when do you trade off that
Bishop in the center big question still
and Wesley he made the move Rook to C1
and with a shake of his head every piece
trade makes his task a little more
difficult to try and create those
chances that he needs with the white
pieces in the Armageddon a must a
must-win game for Wesley so Rook C1
played but I'm getting worried for na
back he's spending so much time on the
clock now he's under 5 minutes and they
still a long way to go before the
position clarifies he's a speed demon
but he is getting quite low on the clock
especially that considering he has 39
moves make to get that extra time he
goes Queen D6 talking about trades Queen
A3 that's a pretty clever idea to get
those Queens off the board and without
Queens maybe just maybe nb's feeling
comfortable and that he can play the
next moves quite quickly really really
nice move but that one was a slow one I
think you're right Robert he at least
has a clearcut plan now and that's the
main thing in Armageddon no matter how
bad your position is no matter how bad
your plan is as long as you're
consistent and you have an idea in mind
it allows you to play quite quickly
allows you to get a flurry of moves in
and um I know that these days a lot of
younger players very rarely play without
increment but this is where the speed
really is necessary and I'm shocked I
thought the black queen was coming in
trade off the Queens but no nbec wants
to peer down at the white king the black
queen is on the same diagonal as White's
King making Wesley feel slightly
uncomfortable here um actually the more
I look at it the more I like this move
really ambitious from nbec not only
making him feel uncomfortable on the
king side but that Queen on the queen
side as well because there is a threat
of the D- Pawn moving forward to D4 and
x-raying that Queen with that Bishop on
E6 and if that Quick Pawn was to move
forward suddenly from becoming a
weakness it starts becoming a strength
in Black's position and that Knight on
F5 is actually such a heroic piece
because not only did it kick that Bishop
out of the center it protects the G7
Pawn so if white does Slide the queen
back to B2 and that's played right now
it doesn't carry a threat so I think
that trade is the name of the game
Bishop d six let's trade off those dark
sore Bishops and black does have a firm
command over the queen side and the King
side does feel well defended as well
look at Wesley on the camera he's
getting ready he's flexing he's uh just
trying to get in the optimal position
for the imminent time scramble it's 7
Minutes against four minutes essentially
still a three-minute Time Advantage half
what it was at the beginning of the game
but enough to cause uh some Delight for
Wesley so I think he's going to start
hustling on the clock you can see on his
body language he's itching to make moves
and nbec still freezing yeah it's been
three or four of these moments where he
spent 30 seconds 1 minute one and a half
minutes you don't have that luxury in
Armageddon chess whatever your move
trade off the dark Square Bishops like
Robert says push pawns tradeoff Rooks
whatever youve got to move quickly the
more pieces on the board the more
calculation based the position becomes
and with seconds on the clock you have
to rely on intuition you have to play
faster instinctively but right now if
nbe keeps continuing to keep these many
minor pieces on the board that's going
to be a tough task Bishop to D6 trade
off that monstrous Bishop on E5 he keeps
thinking and now he's touching the three
minute Mark he must be getting nervous
right now because there's so many
options he does go for a bishop trade
the Evar actually slightly goes up in
White's favor I like the decision I
don't like the time it took to get there
so for Wesley he now has just under
seven minutes he's well ahead in the
clock here's a moment where he has
several different options just don't
blunder your F2 Pawn because the most
tempting move in the position for white
is going knight from D3 out to F4 but
that will drop your F2 Pawn so just be
careful if you're Wesley No Game ending
blunders yeah maybe trade-off Bishops
first and then that move Robert it looks
like Wesley has to part with his Dart
Square Bishop that beautiful Bishop of
whites in the center of the board but he
can do some dancing with his Knights and
the nerves are definitely kicking in
Wesley occasionally he's looking off at
the clock already this early in the game
it's only move 23 he does trade off the
Bishops and now the white Knights do
they start rolling did they start
entering the center Knight to F4 looks
beautiful putting pressure on uh that
black isolated Pawn finding Abdus that
he took on the isolated Queen's Pawn no
he drops back a bit of a
counterintuitive move retreating when it
wasn't necessary he wants to stop
Black's Knight getting back into the
center where it previously stood strong
yeah and that kind of really throws the
ball on NB scor because Knight E4 would
have been an obvious move but suddenly
he has to slow down now he puts his own
Knight there's a big threat on the board
uh he has to take care of this Knight
takes Pawn coming in with a fork you see
how NC just leaned forward when he was
making this move move Knight to D4 so
looking for that pce activity it's super
complicated because white can bring his
own Knight to F4 which defends the E2
Pawn but then you need to calculate the
moves like G5 so things are getting
spicy Wesley calculates things quickly
or he just wanted to play for nbe's time
tra nbe's about to go under 3 minutes G5
is incredibly tempting but it likely
does not work yeah white can just
Counterattack I think here against the
Black Knight and yes pawns pieces will
get traded but the black king would
become open so this didn't happen Bishop
to G4 instead there's pressure there's
threat on Wesley so this Pawn is
attacked twice now nobec is trying to
save time on the clock forces his
opponent to waste time on the clock by
going on the offensive U this is a good
strategy in general when the clocks are
low attack it's much easier quicker
instinctive to attack than defend and
look at this contorting himself Wesley
so drops his Knight back clearing the
second rank the White Queen now
defending that row but yeah it looks a
bit odd suddenly Wesley forced backwards
when you need to win you often want to
avoid trades but I think Wesley's going
a little bit too far out out of his way
to avoid the trades he's going backwards
but so is not's clock I me it's ticking
down here this is a problem for black
you're not even at move 30 yet and you
don't get that one second at a time per
move until you get move 60 so Tanya I'm
starting to like Wesley's chances 100% I
mean it's the clock and the position as
well there's this long-term weakness
that you have with the isolated Queen's
Pawn Wes is going to play this out till
the very end uh and you can fight
against it it'll always give white an
edge unless black is able to create
proper attack on that F2 Square Knight
E4 is the move that you really want to
make in this position but white is just
in time to block this diagonal with the
move E3 but Tanya look at the clock 30
seconds only got 2 minutes left this is
too slow and he's been so fast
throughout the tour final and then
suddenly in this Armageddon with $50,000
on the line a final spot on the line not
back he needs to make a move wow he has
spent nearly 50 seconds on this turn he
is less than 1 minute 45 remaining is he
forgetting that there's no increment
because he hasn't played armagan all day
today they played six games of Rapid
chess with 3 seconds bonus time per move
but he is just stalled he's
Frozen physically incapable of making a
move right now what is he doing why is
he fiddling with pieces you've got one
and a bit minutes 28 moves only we're
still miles away from the increment
stage he plays Rook to d8 a passive
defensive move holding together Black's
isolated Queen's Pawn but he needed to
be consistent attack go on the front
foot when you're down on time and now
he's retreating this is great news for
Wesley so terrible news for Abdu satov 1
minute 20 the key moments are still
ahead there's still so many pieces on
the board and Wesley just makes the most
natural moves now it's easier for him to
play there is no attack on the E2 Pawn
on the F2 pawn and Wesley is going for
that isolated Queen's Pawn trade on
offer Wesley takes the pawn the thing is
for nck the moves are going to get
easier because a bunch of Trades are
happening but you're now just down
material so unfortunately for n he froze
he might be panicking internally and now
Wesley clearly has the upper hand simple
porn up for white no deficiencies to the
white position just convert that extra
Pawn he'll also be left with a bishop
versus a knight with pawns on both
flanks he's going to reach for his
Bishop he captures watch out for the
black king vulnerable to some checks on
the light squares nock's position and
Clark situation both collapsing
simultaneously he dropped his Knight
back attacking the bishop holding on
good move but uh look at that he's
panicking now he looked over at the
clock realizing only one minute oh my
God nck down to a minute no increment
down upon he needs a miracle to save
this one he rushes with the Rook trade
and it's going to be all about combining
the efforts of a queen and a knight
which can be quite dangerous and tricky
against a queen and a bishop and Wesley
you this Rook on D1 that was just
captured he moves his Bishop back out to
B3 he needs to pile pressure on some of
Black's vulnerable pawns so for Wesley
right now plenty of time on his clock
for noty backck he's down under a minute
he's down under a minute and uh okay
ignore the board he did capture that
black Rook at the bottom on D1 it's now
queen of Bishop versus queen and Knight
white is just a porn up so let's ignore
that small board for now let's focus on
the players and it's all about whether
nbec can hold on it's not going to be
easy longterm but he's got the move
counter there look at the tablet move 37
he needs to make 23 moves in just under
his chair is shaking like you can see
how nervous he is right now because he
does not have time to calculate he just
put his G Pawn forward so he's down upon
he tries trying to make space for his
King Wesley doesn't immediately have
threats that's the one bit of good news
from Noir back to be precise he's got 48
seconds on the clock with no increment
to be made the good news for nbec is
that he's got the queen of Knight but
how does the Knight find itself find a
good post into Wesley's Camp right now I
don't see a clear path and what an angle
we see visibly nervous now now shaking
he's trying to get the adrenaline
pumping I think he's just trying to set
up a fortress erect that fortress on the
dark squares white only has a light squ
Bishop so if you hold the opposite color
complex you might be able to fend off
the attack and uh okay we see a check a
quick repetition of the position Wesley
cannot draw he cannot repeat a third
time of course he doesn't but that gives
extra moves to nybeck that was very
helpful for nybeck and the bad thing for
Wesley is he doesn't have an eval bar at
his disposal he doesn't know that he is
objectively winning if the Queens come
off the board can the Knight establish a
Square blockade that's the big question
he's also dropped a second Pawn can
Wesley grab he does take on B6 and now
that's just one check it was only one
check the white King's safe if the
Queens come off now it is dead white is
simply winning due to the two extra
pawns especially the protected pass Pawn
on B5 he can centralize now I think this
is going to kill the counterplay Abdu
satoro is on the brink of elimination
and Wesley he did the right thing he
gives a check to centralize his Queen he
can bring his Queen back to help Shield
his King which is vulnerable in the
second row but he can even brings Queen
back to its starting square and he could
trade pieces anytime but this is even
nicer going in for the kill going in for
the kill look at the light Square it's
the Queen the bishop lined up a battery
on the diagonal white is threatening
Queen to F7 check next to the black king
that would be lights out Black's Queen
forced to defend for nck he's got no
time as well and lost on the board these
are the final few seconds of nck in the
Champions Chester finals and the queen
can take this Knight a new Queen will
appear and I think that will cause
resignation nck knows it he resigns
Wesley so is into the
finals what a game between these two and
you have to feel for the youngster and
look at Wesley he finally can catch his
breath he's been exhausted he's played
for over 6 hours today but he makes it
through tomorrow Wesley so Rises to the
occasion takes it in the Armageddon in
style with the white pieces and not a be
Abdus satra what a journey it's been and
it is heartbreak for the Young big
Phenom wow such close action notc he
just froze at the critical moments it
was the mammoth occasion it was the
money on the line it was the thought of
facing Magnus Carlson tomorrow it all
got to him and ultimately Wesley was
just too composed too calm that scum is
the name of the game when it comes to
Armageddon and Wesley is the one who
showed nerves of Steel in that one
playing quickly playing keeping his
options open in that position keeping
the tension going and I think this
Armageddon it just felt like n back
tension got the better of him W did the
right thing he was avoiding trades early
on no easy simplifications for nbec Abus
satarov and nck had $50,000 on the line
in a single game where he needed a draw
to move on so much pressure for a
19-year-old and credit to him he's been
an amazing event he is done here at the
Champions chess door finals but everyone
should give him a round of applause
because he gave it his all he is a
Phenom yeah he really did so much to
learn from nbec about how you need to
work and play with sheer determination
to make dreams come true but his dream
comes to a stop in the semi-finals and
it is wesle so who will be fighting
against Magnus Carlson and what a day of
stress it has been for Wesley and it all
came down to those critical moments in
this Armageddon where did it turn around
David yeah what a day it's full of uh
roller coasters in this semi-final
between Wesley so and abdusattorov it
had already gone wrong by this point but
I wanted to highlight the fact that the
clock played the biggest factor in this
armagedon here Abdu satov with the black
pieces it has gone a bit wrong he's down
a pawn white here having the extra e-
Pawn however black does have Queen and
Knight a famously strong Duo and black
has set up a bit of a fortress on the
dart squares with more time Abdu satoro
might have found an idea such as Pawn to
G4 locking things down creating the
threat of some counterplay and it would
have been really tough for white to
break through and win this game later
unfortunately though with only around 20
30 seconds left he blundered a second
pawn queen to E5 let loose the B6 Pawn
this was snapped up by Wesley so and yes
it was a check hitting the white king
but it was only one check Wesley had
much more time than his opponent and was
able to calmly find this block and then
this queen Retreat and the killer blow
Queen to C4 coming in with the White
Queen Wesley simply too fast and earlier
on Wesley he could have initiated series
of Trades but the game review gives it a
question mark but maybe it was a great
decision because it put the onus on Nock
to find Clarity in the position he
wasn't able to do it at least not in
time and for Wesley so he did earn his
championship bid he moves on to the
finals to face Magnus Carlson he played
a great game that was a great and to
that Armageddon Wesley at the early at
the start of the day said that he's a
fan of Napoleon and he played like a
true leader today and like a boss
winning that set to and then taking it
in this final Armageddon where nbec
never really got a
chance yeah it's as simple as that nobec
his only chance was to keep Pace on the
clock but ultimately yeah too many
freezes too many freezing moments yeah
and it was those moments that define a
player and Wesley was just the better
one in that Armageddon and we are headed
towards Wesley so Magnus Carlson final
and for more on that action we are going
to head over to our gang in Toronto who
is with the man of the moment Wesley
take it away
guys thanks David and Robert great call
on that action Wesley great chess on
that action you did it yeah thank you
guys you
guys you guys all pick me
yeah I have a lot of friends for rooting
for me and online so really great really
great stuff you have a lot of friends
you got a lot of fans a lot of people
look at Wesley so in Toronto and say is
that the best rapid player in the world
what go what's going on with with Wesley
so when he's in toron know uh yeah well
first of all uh all thanks to Jesus
Christ for giving me the victory today
uh it's only through his will I was
really running out of steam like in the
end I didn't even care you know I just
want to play make use of my chances but
we were really running on fumes it's
been a brutal slugging match it's been
really long really tough at the end of
the day it was about who had more energy
who had stamina left and uh I think I
was kind of figuring
no de Beck I mean first of all a big
congratulations and shout out to him
he's an amazing player he played really
really well in in this match uh but in
the end I thought I was kind of figuring
him out in the end like getting
positions that are better better suited
to my style than his so like uh I think
I lost almost three games with one e
four is it three or two with with white
yeah at the end of the day I had just
had to stop playing White W E4 against
him it wasn't working so that's why I
was trying new openings like
b333 B got B3 too didn't you the problem
with B3 is that I think it works very
well against one E5 like if black repes
E5 because he get the Target and stuff
uh but if black plays like D5 and the
normal stuff and then the B is SL
squared Bishop then he gets a good
position that's why I was hant to play
beater once again because not the bre
goes up to his room after pretty much
every other game too prepare I assume so
I didn't have the courage to play it
again although I would love to maybe
against Magnus yeah maybe I played beer
against Magnus in the speeds
Championship didn't work out well but
maybe tomorrow it would okay but it's
it's nice I mean it's I didn't expect to
still be I mean I'm very happy to reach
a semis but to I was going to say what
did you expect for today because you
lost you lost yesterday right and you
came today we we we kind of we kind of
scripted our our day take you through
behind the scenes we kind of we do our
pregame run a show rehearsal and we're
looking at the day I'm like well if
Wesley if Wesley's playing in the finals
that means we're going to be here all
day cuz we're going to go it's going to
take an all the way comeback in order
for that to happen and you did it yeah I
think uh I think everything played well
in this tournament right from the very
first day right since hearu didn't
accept a door against me like everything
had to go my way because if I finish
second even then Magnus would pick
another back for sure and then I'd face
a tough opponent with Fabiano and I
think Fabiano is a huge favorite Against
Me based on style wise so everything had
to go my way for me to reach the the
finals uh also I realized today that I
did I didn't tweet yesterday before my
match and then it ended really badly so
I was like you know what let me thr
Anish again see if it works and uh it
work giri under the bus on Twitter makes
everyone play better chess it's just
science yeah there was yeah just uh just
having fun my main idea really was to
you know I like I had no intentions to
start anything on social media like I'm
our family is very reserved very quiet
like we live in Minnesota yeah but my
idea was just to troll Anish and watch
the games uh online and then one thing
led to another but I'm hoping I'm I'm
hoping I qualify to a cand and I'll be
back in Toronto my lucky City okay very
very long day of chess for you of course
where do you get yeah very brutal where
do you get more of the stamina from
especially needing it in this last match
here where CU it seems like you're you
know you're just High Spirit feeling
good like you feels like look like you
you haven't you know you just woke up
like you look fresh so what where does
that come from not really no I was
really feel fresh doesn't feel fresh did
I do I really look like w I was like I
think at the end of the day both not
Beck and I were running on our last
energy reserves like I think the reason
why Magnus is so good is because he's
very fit compared to many other chess
players but you know not me but
hopefully I can put up a good fight um
well I could ask the same thing about
you guys you guys have been here since
like 12 what we're doing may not be
quite as hard as what you're doing um
although I appreciate that thank you um
but uh yeah it is a long day and you did
it you pulled through yeah for sure and
there was it's crazy like there was I
was thinking in the Armageddon game
there was a huge amount at stake like
51,000 so it's crazy that that uh so
much is at stake at a single armagedon
game playing $50,000 chess game $50,000
is it 51 cuz 51,000 I thought if you win
a match you get bonus 1,000 he count all
every dollar D don't ask me I'm not in
the details anymore don't put me on the
spot on that you don't read a contct
also of course I do but I you know I
hate to have the lose today because that
means I probably have to change my
ticket and all that and I I hate doing
that that's why that's the closing
anyway right if fana joining us for
tomorrow yeah he probably will he
probably will fb's got no place else to
go who are we kidding he going to stay
here yeah fa Fab's home is where chess
is you like any video games huh you like
any video games uh guys have been
playing uh Clash Royale against each
other so really I like I played I play
like Counter
Strike all
that like during the pandemic of playing
Counter Strike you know I thought I
thought I would never play over theboard
Chef again during 2020 I was like
killing di but he yeah life goes on but
uh um last week won a Nintendo switch so
it'll be very
interesting yeah what games he used but
also I'd like to thank take the
opportunity to thank our sponsors and uh
you know there's huge money at stake
here and I personally don't really play
CH for money but I really appreciate
that fact wait we have sponsor I thought
that was all just out of Danny's I
thought Danny was just most of no but
you don't have to ask the players to
take the sponsors Wesley just did it
thank you very much and of course yeah
also thank you to all the people who are
roting for me both here and on on on the
and online I think that's one of the
main reasons why I played so well in
Toronto last year and also this year and
also shout out to Michael brancato
because before tourament he said he
wished that the dream finals would be
Magnus and me and I was like what I
would reach a
semi-final I mean from little place in
uh in in Minnesota which I think is kind
of how they I always seen that meeme
like one day in Minnesota 5 days in
Minnesota and then you just turn more
and more into Minnesotan does the local
community there like know who you are
like around your neighbors do they root
for you do they talk to you do they know
they've got a beast chess player around
well I think I'm the only Grandmaster in
the entire state of Minnesota for now
for now for now until you make a chess
Academy and then you know idea until
alif Le gets her grandmas title yeah she
live St Paul but uh yeah I think the we
moved in this new place 4 and a half
years ago and then there's annual
neighbor meetings and they figure out
that I was a chess player so they're
like last year they were asking during
the party they were like oh who handan
who hand
name that's all they ever talk about but
I mean I think chess in Minnesota is
growing slowly but surely like it's
being included in high school and also
in acade in uh what do you call that
after after academic yeah so I like one
time I like some sometimes people
recognize me in a store like hey most
aren't you the chess player and they
like they be Googling me looking my phot
but it's not it's not like the attention
that you get in St Louis Missi yeah and
then they ask you if you've ever played
Hans nean is that what they ask you they
say have you ever played Hans nean I
Crush
that all right Wesley you know I will oh
sorry I was going to what was say uh
Minnesota gonna
say uh you're tired yeah yeah confus I'm
I'm gonna give you one last question
because I think setting up what Michael
brancato said his dream final would be
was probably based on the fact that
we've got the Champions chess tour
defending champion in Magnus Carlson you
have the chess.com Global Champion
that's you that's right if you missed
the memo right so you versus Magnus is a
true kind of marriage of what was
previously two separate online tours now
with one with one you know one ring to
rule them all right one ring to bind
them so let me tell you this let me ask
you like how does the best Wesley so
show up tomorrow the Wesley so that
believes he can beat Magnus Carlson in a
match well you got you got cheer me up D
ain't gonna pump me up like I'm asking
you want to go you want to cat your date
tonight you want to catch your date
coupon tonight maybe magnifi can switch
to CH
960 I'll be cool with that but I have I
mean overall I had like a horrible
lifetime performance against
Magnus uh but
uh yeah I I'll I'll give my best Magnus
if you're listening maybe take it easy
on me tomorrow give us a match well I'm
I'm sure you'll bring your best and I'm
sure that we're going to have a match I
I really hope so a lot a lot of people
believe in you a lot of fans a lot of
people think this is going to be a
thriller and there's a reason why a lot
of people wanted to see this so yeah
don't forget our date I'm not going to
forget our date you got the coupon I
could never forget um all right we are
going to let you go let you get some
rest enjoy your night you've got you've
got two more big days of Chess ahead
your job isn't done we wish you the best
of luck against Magnus Carlson yeah yeah
for sure I'm just very happy to be in
the finals but I yeah I really hope
it'll be a match tomorrow yeah all right
Wesley good luck bud thanks for being
with us well there we have it that was
our guy that is our guy Wesley so who
punched his ticket and now we know who's
going to play
the Carlson and Wesley so will throw
down in the title match it starts
tomorrow it's Friday and uh wow you know
it's Friday Friday we're going to play
just on
Friday but before we sing or do whatever
else we're going to do to get out of
here I'm going to let everyone catch up
with Kaa who caught up with Notre Beck
after that tough
match an incredible fight but it ends
here so how are you right now
nck yeah I'm bit of disappointed CU When
I play today you know um I I played you
know very badly but um you know also
Wesley you know shout out to him he
played very very well after you know
yesterday's tough tough loss but yeah um
yeah it sometimes happens you know I had
every chance to win this this match but
um yeah that's that's what it is and you
went all the way onto that final Arma
get on it was crazy to watch you were
shaking we could see your feet shaking
can you take us through the emotions in
the end there yeah no I got decent
position out of opening you know I I I
like these tarish structures um I play
I've played many games there you know I
I've got very very good position but
then you know I I somehow you know
started to to sing and you know played
passively um so yeah that's you know
that's why I I was you know I was
punished by by Wesley um but um
yeah you know generally I you know today
was not my day so uh I just I I have to
um I have to come back stronger and we
definitely think you will but uh what
has been the highlight for you the fact
that you've been here one of the
youngest players fighting it out and
making it all the way to the semi-finals
no it's been a great event um you know
first of all big big thanks to chess.com
for hosting this great event you know
giving opportunity for
me um yeah it's been a wonderful event
for me you know my highlight was of
course yesterday uh when I you know I
won the I won the match very
convincingly um even when I lose the
first game I I wasn't disappointed
because you know I was outplaying
him there yeah um but today you know
something went wrong and um he he was
clearly better than me well nck we know
you went through a lot to get here
staying in Berlin for eight days you
given us incredible entertainment thank
you also for sharing your thoughts here
in the mix Zone and we wish you best of
luck in the nearest future thank you
thank you let's nbe Abdu satoro a great
guy who is knocked out of the CCT finals
but what a what a performance he's given
us back to you
guys wow after being excited here in the
studio with Wesley it's hard not to now
just go quickly to the other side and
feel heartbroken for Notre back ly your
thoughts on on just the emotion how much
he clearly wanted this yeah listen um
losing one chess game is tough losing a
chess match uh is especially one that
you felt like you could have won is even
tougher and when you add on top of that
that uh it was potentially 50 to
$150,000 not to mention match with
Magnus uh I can't imagine like I I I
really I truly can't imagine it's it's
really heartwarming uh and special to
that the players here are giving these
uh solemn and open interviews to all of
us because uh historically chess players
do not give interviews when they lose
they run off somewhere and they are not
seen until the next day of action so uh
really nothing but respect to these guys
for being a part of this and you have
nothing uh I mean you just look forward
to their next event which for noer just
so happens to be in his home country the
world rapid and Blitz Championship so
love the guy looking forward to his next
uh set of tournaments same here I'm
looking forward to the next set of
tournaments I mean you got a feel for
him as 50k match that's a lot of money
there but he also made 50k he also
played against some of the strongest
players the strongest players in the
world so it's nice practice for him as
he goes into the next rabit tournament
this to do his thing I mean we saw
Dennis lose one title Tuesday right you
know so we see notbe lose here maybe
he'll win World rapper Championship we
don't know but at the same time there
good confidence for him at the end of
the day so got to feel for him it is 50k
I think for Notre Beck uh like like many
others it's not even necessarily about
the money you you know that he's now at
the place where he doesn't want to hear
things coming out of commentator's
mouths anymore like well next time or
practice or he's young he'll get there
he's tired of that you can see that he
wants it you can see how much he cared
about this and I think for the fans and
everyone watching it really helps you
appreciate that this has been a yearlong
or deal to get here right this this tour
has had a lot going on for these guys
with so much at stake so great to see
the emotion we do appreciate him um
giving the interview and we know it's
it's obviously not not ending the way
that he story lined it for himself but
best of luck to Notre Beck uh in his
next event and best of luck to all of
you fans whatever you're going to do
tonight uh be safe and uh and uh maybe
get some rest because we still have a
couple of days of Chess ahead so for
everyone here the crew KY Levy in
Toronto of course everyone across the
pond as well doing and everything that
they're doing to bring this to us
remember we have two more days of Chess
it's the championship chess tour finals
the title match between Magnus Carlson
and Wesley so it's here tomorrow don't
be anywhere else and we will see you
[Music]
then he just crushed nybeck never gave
him a chance Fabby he makes the wrong
night jump but he slowed down and now
the queen comes to G5 Wesley strikes
again with the black pieces and that is
it do do a win for Wesley so Wesley
keeping things alive with a nasty move
what a sick move what a fantastic game
I've never seen anything like that
Fabiano Carana is eliminated Magnus
Carlson stamps his ticket to the finals
we are getting set for what will be the
final Armageddon of this epic semifinal
day nck knows it he resigns wesle so is
into the
finals
[Music]
oh